LET'S CALL THE FEDERAL CALL THE
COMMITTEE TO ORDER. ARE WE WANT
TO OBVIOUSLY REMIND FOLKS THAT
WE ARE IN PANDEMIC SITUATION SO
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
GUIDELINES I NEED TO TALK
ABOUT- WE'RE ALL IT HEARING
SOCIAL DISTANCING IN FACE
COVERING- OUT WE HAVE. ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO ALLOW FOR
PUBLIC ACCESS- SOAP SO FOLKS
CAN ATTEND. IN ONE OF THESE TWO
HEARING ROOMS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE- PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WON DOUBTS IT.
RIGHT NOW THAT TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
SIX FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE
SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW. THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MERGE PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. NOW WILL YOU
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION PRESS
THERE'S ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU. TO A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE RELY NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE A
MUTED AND YOU WILL BE READY. TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK PLEASE MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHIG THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I'M GOING TO MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THIS HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING ERVICE OR
HAVE THE CONNECTIONS NEEDED-
WELL EVERY. EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE JUST. THE HEARING PROCESS
A CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN IS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER AS
THE CUSTOMER. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR BIRDS. WHO
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGY
SIMPLY REFLECTS RESPECTFUL
PATIENT. SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. AND WE
HAVE ELEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. WITH TWO BILLS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- YES THERE ARE
THERE ISN'T AN INTERESTING
ORDER AND- BY THE SENATE WITH
CASKEY IS WORKED OUT WITH THE-
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT. THE TWO
FINAL BILLS THAT TEN AND ELEVEN
SO THESE ARE SB TWO OF SEVEN.
AND SB TWO FORTY FOUR THEY ARE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR- THE
FIRST. FIVE BILLS ARE DOUBLE
REFERRED. AND THEN THE NEXT-
THE NEXT FOUR OUR SINGLE OR- SO
THAT THERE WE ARE. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S
LET'S ESTABLISH A- THANK ITS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
HERE ALLEN HERE BATES. BATES
COULD YOU TRY MIKE. SAN HERE.
BATES HERE DALY. GONZALEZ HERE
GONZALEZ HERE SKINNER. SKINNER
HERE STERN BY KELSEY HERE I
KASKY HERE. ALL RIGHT SO WE
NOTE THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM.
I THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR BEING
HERE IN A TIMELY MANNER LET'S
SEVEN LET'S LET'S FIRST START
WITH THE CONSENT CALDERON WE
HAVE TWO ITEMS ON CONSENT
EITHER ITEMS TEN ELEVEN S. B.
TWO OH SEVEN BY DOLLY SB TWO
FORTY FOUR. ARCHULETA WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSECUTIVE RIGHT BUT WE WILL
CASCADE. I THINK IT'S AN
ACCOUNT KEY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE CONSENT. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ARE ITEMS TEN
AND ELEVEN ALLEN. BY ALAN HI
BATES ALL RIGHT. CENTER WOULD
YOU MIND TURNING MY- HI EIGHT I
DALY FIVE GONZALEZ I WITHOUT
SIZE BYINNER ON STERN. OKAY
FOR THE WILL ALLOW RECOUNTS. A.
SO SORRY SAID MCCAIN HI SB IPOD
AS FAR ZERO OKAY X. GO TO THE
VOTING THEIR- WILL THE ROLE
OPEN FOR CENTERS. OKAY NOW
LET'S JUST RIGHTS WITH ONE THE
EDGE THIS IS THAT'S TWENTY SO
THIS IS ARE ARE COLLEAGUES AND
SKINNER. BOB ON CARBON SEEK.
AND YOU MAY YOU REST WHEN READY.
THANK YOU. HAPPY TO PRESENT SB
THIRTY TWENTY SO TWO SO I THINK
WE ARE ALL AWARE THOSE OF US
WHO HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING THE
SCIENCE IN OUR CLIMATE CRISIS
THAT IT IS- WE'RE THE CRISIS IS
VERY. NOT ONLY SERIOUS THAT'S
THE TERM CRISIS BUT THAT WE
HAVE A VERY BRIEF WINDOW. TO
ACT TO ADDRESS THE WORST
CONSEQUENCES OF THE CLIMATE
CRISIS IN OTHER WORDS A BRIEF
WINDOW. TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
SO THAT THOSE ABSOLUTE WORST
CONSEQUENCES ARE AVOIDED. AND
THAT IS GOING TO REQUIRE WE'VE
BEEN VERY FOCUSED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ON CUTTING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND WE
HAVE BEEN A LEADER NOT ONLY IN
THIS COUNTRY BUT NOW THAT A
WORLDWIDE. AND WE'RE DOING WELL
THERE BUT IS NOT ENOUGH WE MUST
ALSO CONTAIN AS MUCH CARBON AS
POSSIBLE FROM REACHING THE
ATMOSPHERE. AND THAT IS WHAT
SEQUESTRATION IS IT IS THE
CONTAINMENT OF CARBON SO WE
UNDERSTAND IT WELL IN
RELATIONSHIP TO WATER PLANTS DO
AND NOW WE UNDERSTAND BETTER
THAT OUR SOILS HAVE A ROLE IN
THIS. AND THAT OUR OCEANS
BECAUSE OF THE PLANKTON AND
OTHER MICROORGANISMS HAVE A
STRONG ROLE THAT THERE'S LOTS
OF RULES FOR. NATURE'S ABILITY
TO CONTAIN CARBON AND WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS. STRENGTHEN OUR
STATE'S RULES AROUND ALLOWING
ENTITIES TO UTILIZE THAT NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS WITHIN WETLANDS
FORESTS HEALTHY SOILS OR WHAT
HAVE YOU TO CONTAIN THAT
CARBON. IT IS ALSO ONE OF THE
LEAST COST WAYS TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE SO WE HAVE A
ONCE IN A. GENERATION CHANCE TO
FUNNEL PRIVATE MONEY INTO
FINDING GOOD CALIFORNIA CARBON
CONTAINMENT PROJECTS. THERE ARE
FIFTY THREE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
NOW SIGNED ON TO THE AMAZON
PLEDGE TO GO CARBON NEUTRAL BY
TWENTY FORTY. THOSE COMPANIES
INCLUDING UNILEVER MICROSOFT
IBM COCA COLA VERIZON. SO WHAT
SB TWENTY SEVEN SPECIFICALLY
DOES IS IT SUPPORTS OUR FARMERS
AND LAND MANAGERS. WHO ALREADY
ARE IN ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE
USING GOOD PRACTICES CONTAINING
CARBON FROM REALLY BEING
RELEASED INTO THE ATMOSPHERE
AND IT HELPS MAKE CALIFORNIA
MORE RESILIENT TO CLIMATE
IMPACTS BY DIRECTING THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY TO SET GOALS FOR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION FOR NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS. DIRECTS OUR AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO INCLUDE
CARBON SEQUESTRATION IN THE
UPCOMING SCOPING PLAN AND
ESTABLISHES A REGISTRY OF
CARBON SEQUESTRATION PROJECTS
APPLE PR FOR POTENTIAL PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE INVESTMENT FIRM
REQUIRES OR AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO TRACK THE CARBON BENEFITS OF
THESE PROJECTS. AND MY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT AS ELLIE COHEN THE
CEO OF THE CLIMATE PLAN. OKAY
WITH YOUR FROM. MISCON. IS YOUR
WITNESS NOT AVAILABLE AT THE
MODERATOR WE IS THIS YOUR CALL
IN. AVAILABLE FOR TESTIMONY.
ELLIE I DO NOT SHOW HER ON THE
LINE. WELL OKAY THAT'S CHANGED
EVERYTHING FROM A INTERNET KNOW
WHAT KIND OF TECHNOLOGICAL
PROBLEMS WELL I THINK I DID A
GOOD JOB INSTITUTING WHAT IT
DOES AND WHY AND I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ONE
OR WE CAN SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION RIGHT ALRIGHT LET'S
GIVE FOLKS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN IN SUPPORT OF HIS
ANYONE HERE IN OUR- HEARING
ROOM HERE I SEE NINE I LOOK AT
THE VIDEO OF ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT. FOR
THIS BILL SB TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND-
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. TWENTY. PLEASE PRESS THEN
THEY- AN OPERATOR PROVIDE YOU
WITH MY NUMBER. PLACE YOU BACK
TO SEE. ONE IF YOU WERE TO
SPEAK SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN NOW.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND TIME WE
HAVE FIVE PEOPLE IN Q. THANK
YOU FOR MAY GOD MAKE IT. THANK
YOU SIR NUMBER TWENTY THREE THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NOW PROBLEM OF THE
BUILDING CAMPUS TRADE COUNCIL
CAL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER IS YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CAROL MEMBERS STEVEN MY ON
BEHALF OF THE HAVE ATTACKED
PLAN IN SUPPORT. NATURAL AND
WORK LANDS AND TALKING COLLEGE
PLANS KIND OF TECHNICAL PLAN
PROTECT AND RISK OR TO
QUESTION CARBON AREAS ACROSS
THE STATE THAT ARE ON THREAT
DEVELOP. LOOK FOR THE WORKING
WITH THE SPEECH WHICH SHE THE
SECRET GOLD STANDARD AUTHORITY
OF SPEAK SEVEN THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
ALL. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR IN SENATORS LOOK AT
FOR ABOUT OF THE NATURE. BUT
CREATES A SKINNER LEADERSHIP
THIS ISSUE AND AS WE WELL KNOW
NATURE HAS ITS OWN BACK FOR
CARBON IN PLAY SOIL ROCKS AND
WE ACTUALLY TRY SEVEN IS A
AIMED AT MY- ENTERS A BILL TO
STORE AND GROW. FARMLANDS WEB
STORAGE NOT AFTER SYSTEMS AND
REALLY APPRECIATE HER
INTRODUCED THIS MEASURE YEAR
THANKS SO MUCH. BUT AT THIS
TIME OF THE GERMAN WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT LET'S LET'S
NOT SEE IF THERE'S ANY I DON'T
SEE ANYONE HERE IN OUR HEARING-ROOM OR IN TWENTY FORTY TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINES.
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU M CHAIRMAN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OF SB TWENTY
SEVEN. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL TAKE A LINE OFF
LINE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
TWENTY SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. WELL MISTER
CHAIRMAN. FOR AT THE TIME OF
THE CHAMBER WE DO HAVE TWO
PEOPLE IN Q. LIE NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS MIA
LOWER GOING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE YOU CAN PUT
IN A LETTER CONCERNS LAST WEEK
AND THE ALONG WITH OUR HEROES.
THANK YOU CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE ACCORDING.
TO OUR CONVERSATION WITH YOU-
MAINTENANCE AND OF. THANK. Y.
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AT YOUR TURN NUMBERS TO
LOWER SHE WITH THE HELP FARM
AND AS OUR CALL MISSION WORKING
IN- IF THE MIDDLE OF CONCERN
FOR THE- OUR CONCERN PUT ON
THAT RELATED TO THAT BUT TO
TRYING THAT OPENING FOR IN THE
BILL WITH THE- KERR UNDER WAY
AT THE RIVER STADIUM. WE ALSO
THE UNDER THANK PROCESS AND IN
THE STILL BE GOAL SETTING BE
WERE BECAUSE WITHIN ONE YEAR
AND IT SENATORS CAN NOTED LAND
AND FARMERS AND RANCHERS ARE
REALLY AT THE TO THE- THANK YOU.
OKAY MORE FOR SO MUCH- LET'S
NOW WITH. BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
ON SENATE ALL. YOUR BERNIE.
JUST A QUESTION AS A MAN THE
YOU HAVE TO SIGN UP IN THE
PROBE SO FAR IT FOR LIKE THE
QUESTION THAT WAS ASKED BY THE
FARM BUREAU FOR. FOR THOSE WHO
IS MANDATORY OR IS IT OPTIONAL.
THIS WOULD. BE ENTITIES WORK
WHO WANTED TO UTILIZE IT IT'S
OPTIONAL NOW. THE SORRY NOW
WHAT THIS BILL IS PRIMARILY
TRYING TO DO IS CREATE A COT
CREATE A PROCESS FOR. THOSE
LAND MANAGERS THOSE AGGIE-
ENTITIES AND ALL WHO ARE WANT
TO PRACTICE. ONE ENGAGE IN THE
PRACTICES THAT MOST CONTAIN
CARBON WOULD BE ABLE TO FOLLOW
PROTOCOL BECAUSE WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE A PROTOCOL DEVELOPED AND
POTENTIALLY THEN HAVE THEIR
ACTIONS. ABLE TO BE UTILIZED
WITHIN THE- NOT NECESSARILY
WITHIN CAP AND TRADE BECAUSE WE
DON'T NOW COUNTED EVEN IN THE
IN OUR- EMISSIONS INVENTORY BUT
RATHER IN PRIVATE SECTOR
PROJECTS NOW THAT ARE TRYING TO
INVEST IN CARBON SYSTEM
SEQUESTRATION PROJECTS WHICH
RIGHT NOW THEY WOULD NOT
QUALIFY FOR BECAUSE WE HAVE NO
PROTOCOL FOR THAT. SO JUST A
FOLLOW UP TO AS MANY NO I'VE
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR. INFORCE
FIRES TO BE COUNTED IN OUR
CARBON OUTPUT WHICH WE DON'T
RIGHT NOW RIGHT- AND THEN THE
OTHER I THINK THE OTHER
QUESTION IS THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO AS AS SOMEBODY
WHO'S IN OUR CULTURE. WHO
THERE'S CERTAIN PRACTICES I
HAVE TO DO ON MY FARM THAT ARE
THERE'S NO OTHER OPTION- BY
TILLAGE. THERE'S ALSO ABILITIES
TO USE- TO PUT CARBON INTO THE
GROUND THROUGH BIO CHAR AND ALL
KINDS OF OTHER GREAT RESOURCES
OUT THERE BUT IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAJOR THAT AND TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE YOU FIT IN THE PROCESS
OF- MAYBE THEY'RE GETTING A
CREDIT OR OR BEING PENALIZED.
AND SO I'M VERY CONCERNED THAT-
YOU KNOW WE DON'T PUT THE ONUS
ON. THE PERSONS I KNOW THAT'S
WHY IT'S VERY CRITICAL AND HOW
HOW WE IMPLEMENT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS. BECAUSE IT REALLY DOES
MAKE A DIFFERENCE WHEN YOU GET
TO THE GROUND. AND THAT'S WHY
IT IS NOT MANDATORY RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE WELCOME. OTHER QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY CASKEY. MISTER CAN YOU
EXPLAIN ARE CLARIFIED
THUNDERSTORMS HIGHLIGHT D. D.
POTENTIAL OR THE PROTECTION
THAT YOU HAVE FOR OFFSETS THAT
STATEMENT AND PRIVATE ENTITY OR
PUBLIC ENTITY MAY WANT TO TRY
TO USE THIS REGISTRY AS FAR AS
TO NOT FULFILL THEIR OBLIGATION
A STATUTORY OBLIGATION OR
WHATEVER TO REDUCE EMISSIONS.
SO THE- THIS BILL COVERS THESE-
FOR EXAMPLE WETLANDS
SUSTAINABLE FORESTRY AND SUCH
LIKE THAT AND RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
EMISSIONS FROM THOSE SECTORS
ARE NOT CURRENTLY INCLUDED IN
OUR EMISSIONS INVENTORY. THEY
COULD NOT FIVE. THEY WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO BE USED FOR AN
OFFSET PURPOSE SO THIS BILL
DOESN'T NECESSARILY ESTABLISH A
CONTEXT WHERE THEY WOULD WITHIN
OUR FRAMEWORK USED FOR AN
OFFSET BUT IT WOULD ALLOW THEM
FOR TO PARTICIPATE IN SAY
EXAMPLE PRIVATE SECTOR- HE-
INVESTMENTS FOR. CAPTURING
CARBON IF THAT PRIVATE SECTOR
CAN FEEL ASSURED THAT THE THAT
THE PRACTICE THAT WHICHEVER
ENTITIES ENGAGED IN IT ACTUALLY
CAPTURES ARE CONTAINS CARBON
PAPER I MEAN I THINK IT YOUR
BILL GOES DOES MORE THAN THAT
IS SPECIFICALLY DOES NOT ALLOW.
IT THAT THE CREATION OF A
CREDIT FOR- FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THE OF THE MARKET BASS THING
EXACTLY YES- AND THEN JUST SO.
MY COLLEAGUE WHO SITS ON SEPT
TWO OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
THIS IS BEEN AN ONGOING
DISCUSSION IN BUDGET TALKS WITH
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
WERE WE SPECIFICALLY PUT MORE
MONEY IN FOR WORKING LANDS
WHICH GIVEN THE REGISTRY THAT
YOU SET UP IN THE COOPERATION
WITH THE AGENCIES WILL PROVIDE
MORE. INVESTMENTS IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS WE'VE BEEN CUT.
LATER DOES A- SENATE. IDEAS
HAVE BEEN CUT DOWN TO ZERO SO
WE THINK THAT THERE MAY BE.
MORE INTEREST THIS YEAR I WISH
YOU GOOD LUCK HOW MOVE THE
BILL- AT THIS TIME BUT JUST TO
THE EMAIL THAT THAT THIS IS AN
ONGOING DISCUSSION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THE
ASSEMBLY THAT THEY THEY REMOVE
MONEY FROM HERE WHICH SEEMS TO
BE THIS IS A- A COUPLING OF A-
OF- CONFIDENCE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
IN THE MARKET OF WHAT'S GONNA
GO ON. BY THE WAY SINCE GARY I
HAVE BEEN MADE AWARE THAT-
KELLY CALLINGIS NOW AVAILABLE
BUT YOUR OF YOUR EVEN MOVED AND
YOU'RE GETTING YOUR DOING GREAT
BUT EVERYBODY OBVIOUSLY SHE'S
AVAILABLE IF YOU IF YOU WANT-
CENTER BATES. A YES VOTE THANK
YOUS ARE SENATOR SKINNER FOR
UPBRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
IT HAS A REAL NOBLE GOAL.
HOWEVER IT DOES SEEM TO BE A
LITTLE UNDEFINED ILL DEFINED.
IN WHEN IT GOES TO- THEY ARE BE
ON YOUR- GOALS ARE SETTING AND-
THERE ARE QUESTIONS RAISED IN
THE COMEDIAN ELEPHAS PATTERN. I
WONDER IF YOU WOULD ADDRESS ON
PAGE SIX OF EIGHT. IT SPEAKS
ABOUT THE AUTHOR ME WE SHOULD
CONSIDER ALLOWING- PRD DEFINED
PROJECTS. IN THERE'S ONE OTHER
THAN JUST HARD FOR US. THOSE
PAGE. IT SAYS. SINCE PARAGRAPH
IS THREE TO THE RED TO. FOR
PRIOR. THAT DO YOU TYPE OF WORK
BUT THE AUTHOR ME WE SHOULD
COME CLARA THE- YOU NEED TO GET
ALONE ARE ALSO RESULT. AND I'M
SICK HOME PAGE. SIX DEBATERS AT
THE TOP OF THE PAGE. REGARDING
DEFINING. SO IT I CAN CLOSER
THE AREAS THAT ARE A LITTLE
TROUBLE FOR ME TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY I I'D LIKE THE GOAL THAT
I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE BETTER
DEFINED CHEN IN A COUPLE AREAS.
IF I MAY ADDRESS THAT MR
DISAGREES. SURE I THINK THIS
IS. A TWO POINT CENTER BATES I
THINK THIS THE FACT THAT IT IS
THE BILL AS WRITTEN IN THE WAY
THAT IT IS SHOULD GIVE YOU
COMFORT VERSUS CONCERN. BECAUSE
IN I COULD HAVE WRITTEN IT SUCH
THAT I WAS NOT ONLY CREATING
THE REGISTRY BUT REQUIRING A RB
TWO COUNTIES EMISSIONS AND THEN
THUS REQUIRING. A WHOLE
PROTOCOL FOR THAT WOULD BE A
FORCE FOR EXAMPLE AS SENATOR
DOLLY POINTED OUT. VARIOUS OF
THE HTC'S CONCERNED IN TAPPED
TO PARTICIPATE AND US- THEY
COULD THEN BE ELIGIBLE
OBVIOUSLY FOR. THE STATE
OFFICIAL OFFSETS BUT THAT IS
NOT WHAT I'VE DONE IN EFFECT
YOU CAN VIEW THIS AS KIND OF
BABY STEPS. WHAT I AM TRYING TO
DO HERE IS ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE IS. PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTMENT THAT WANTS TO INVEST
IN PROJECTS THAT HELP TO.
SEQUESTER IS THE SCIENTIFIC
WORD I USE CONTAINMENT TO
CONTAIN CARBON TO KEEP IT FROM
GOING INTO THE ATMOSPHERE. AND
WE ARE HALF PUT OUR- WE HAVE
PUT ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA AT A
DISADVANTAGE BY NOT HAVING THIS
IN A REGISTRY AND NOT HAVING A
PROTOCOL. SO I'M TRYING TO
CREATE THAT SITUATION WHERE. IF
THERE IS AN ENTITY WHO IS
INTERESTED IN THIS AND THEY MAY
NEED SOME- FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
THAT THIS IS A WAY THEY COULD
GET PRIVATE SECTOR CAPITAL. TO
TO ENGAGE IN THE PRACTICES THAT
WE KNOW CONTAIN CARBON. SO
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL
AND I WOULD THINK THAT THE WAY
IT'S WRITTEN SHOULD GIVE YOU-
NOT TOO CONCERNED. VERSUS HAD A
WRITTEN IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
THANK YOU I THINK TO THEM JUST
TO HOLD OFF AGAIN I'M- A MONTH
75% SUPPORTIVE. SCROLL AWAY
DOES IT GOES FORWARD TO SEE
ARE. THE CHANGES THAT MIGHT BE
MADE THANK YOU. OKAY ARE. ZERO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS- FROM THE
COMMITTEE I KNOW THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR CASKEY
IT'S A DO PASS- BUT IT IT FIRST
WILL BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND WATER.
SO SO THERE WILL BE A SECOND
CRACK IT AT THE BILL THERE FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE MEMBERS
THERE- BUT WITH THAT- LOVE TO.
HAVE YOU CLOSE I THINK WE'VE
HAD A GOOD DISCUSSION AND I
THINK- GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE CRISIS IN THE NECESSITY TO
ACT QUICKLY SOME COULD ARGUE
WHY DO NIGHT WHY HAVE I WRITTEN
A BILL. THAT IS IN EFFECT SO
VOLUNTARY AND IS IN EFFECT BABY
STEPS WHEN WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
TAKE BABY STEPS RIGHT NOW BUT
I'VE DONE SO THAT WE CAN GET
COMFORT IN THIS AREA AND THAT
WE CAN HOPEFULLY MOVE MUCH MORE
QUICKLY. INTO IT. AS A REAL AS
A REALLY. SIGNIFICANT SOLUTION
TOWARDS THIS IS A CRISIS OF
CARBON BEING RELEASED INTO OUR
ATMOSPHERE WITHOUT AYE ASTRI
AYE VOTE PRESIDENT. THE WORK IN
THE SERVICE CENTER. OKAY
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TWENTY
CENTER ID TWENTY SEVEN BY
CENTER SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES ALLEN. HI ALAN HI
BATES NOT LOADING. EIGHT NOT
VOTING DALLY. DALY NOT VOTING
CONSERVE I GONZALEZ SKINNER BY
INNER ISTER. BY COUNTY BY
HOUSEKI I. THANKS FOR THANK YOU
OKAY WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
CENTERS STERN THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER- NOT MEMBERS- AYE AYE
YOU IS TYPICALLY CUSTOMERS FOR
THE CHAIR TO GO LAST- BUT
BECAUSE OF THE PHONE LINES
ACTUATION- WELL WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO STICK TO FILE OR SO I
DO APOLOGIZE THAT MEANS I MEAN
BE PRESENT A NEXT I'M GOING TO
PASSED THE GAVEL TO OUR-
ESTEEMED VICE CHAIR. I ALSO TO
SAY THAT- AS I THAT THERE WE
ALSO BEEN ASKED THIS TO PRESENT
AT OUR AT OUR- DESKS SO AS TO
NOT BE MOVING AROUND AS MUCH
SOMEONE CENTER CASKEY PRESENTS
HIS BILL. HE WILL. AT PRESENT
THERE WE GO TO REAL WITH IT.
WHEN THEY HAVE. IT A HOW YOU.
THERE'S NOBODY THERE HE SAID.
SO SENATOR ALAN WE'RE GOING
FILE ORDER DOES THAT MEAN WE
TAKE SB FORTY FOUR FIRST THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE 2%
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO THIS
BILL IS A BILL THAT THIS
COMMITTEE SEE BEFORE AND THAT
TIME EVERYBODY IS VOTED ON
BEFORE AT THAT THE IDEA THEY
WOULD ESTABLISH EXPEDITED SEEK
REVIEW FOR GREEN TRANSIT
PROJECTS AND REQUIRES THE
COURTS RESOLVE RELATED. SECRET
LAWSUITS WITHIN TWO TO SEVENTY
DAYS- THE IDEA BEING THE SOONER
THAT TRANSFORMATIVE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY. HI
TRANSIT PROJECTS CAN COMPLETE
THE SEQUEL PROCESSES AND MAY BE
BUILT THE FASTER THEY WILL BEND
DISPLACE LESS EFFICIENT AND
POLLUTION INTENSIVE. REGIONAL
TRIPS TAKEN BY PASSENGERS IN
PRIVATE VEHICLES. SO IN ORDER
TO GET EXPEDITED REVIEW UNDER
THIS BILL THE PROJECTS HAVE TO
BE CONSISTENT WITH THE REGION
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
STRATEGY TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
WE HAVE TO OPERATE OF ZERO
EMISSIONS THEY HAVE TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
WITHOUT USING OFFSETS IN AFTER
REDUCE OVERALL VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED IN THE CORRIDOR. WHERE
THE PROJECT OPERATES. AT THE
BILL'S IS SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
TO SB SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
IS A BILL THAT PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR- YOU MAY
RECALL THAT IT WAS IT WAS TIED.
WITH SOME LANGUAGE TO THE PRO
TEMS SB NINE NINETY FIVE. HI
AND SO. FORTH IN A BECAUSE THAT
BILL FAILED WHICH WE THOUGHT
WAS GOING TO PASS THAT WE ARE
BILL FAILED- SO WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
AB COMING BACK AGAIN WITH THIS
TIME IS NOT TIED TO ANOTHER
BILL'S LANGUAGE SO THAT THAT
THAT PROBLEM IS RESOLVED. AND
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFIED
SUPPORTER MICHAEL TURNER WITH
LOS ANGELES METRO. AND ALSO-
MICHAEL PIMENTEL WHOSE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION.
THE ON. OKAY PLEASE PROCEED TO
GO AHEAD FOR HIS RETURNING YOUR
MANAGER THAT MEMBERS IT'S
MICHAEL TURNER WITH- THE L. A.
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OUR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS AND SB FORTY FOUR
IS AN IMPORTANT BILL BECAUSE IT
WILL HELP ADVANCE KEY PROJECTS-
ACROSS THE STATE AND SPECIFIC
KEY POWER PROJECTS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. CENTER ALLEN
MENTIONED THE BILL IS TAILORED
TO ONLY BENEFIT THE HIGHEST
PERFORMING PROJECTS MAY HAVE TO
REDUCE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED L. A.
METRO IS IN THE PROCESS OF
ADVANCING ONE OF THE LARGEST
EXPANSIONS OF A PUBLIC TRANSIT
SYSTEM IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND THIS WILL HELP US TO-
ADVANCE SOME OF OUR KEY
PROJECTS LIKE THING SENATOR
ALAN FOR HIS AUTHORSHIP. AND
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. CAN I BRING NEXT TO
SOME BERMAN. MENTAL IF THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS MY
HOPE IN THE DELEGATION DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
TODAY TO AVOID TRANSIT INDUSTRY
SUPPORT FOR CHAIR ALLEN SB
FORTY FOUR AND TO ENCOURAGE THE
COMMUNITY BY THE LEGISLATION
YOU MAY KNOW THE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTS THE FIVE TRIBES AND
RELIGIONS YOU. STATE WHY. BY
TURNER IS AS THE CHAIR. SO WHAT
IF OUR ACTUALLY NEW STREAMING
JUDICIAL REVIEW. ANDERSON WHAT
IS YOUR MISSION EXTRA WEIGHT
TRANSFER YET. STILL RECOGNIZES
ON COMFORTABLE. THAT ALL TOO
OFTEN LARGE SCALE TRANSPARENCY
COULD BE AMOUNTS TRAVEL THE
DISTRIBUTION SECTOR MISSIONS
CASE EQUAL BASIS WITH
ADDITIONAL FLOWS PROJECT
DELIVERS. THESE PROJECTS
TRANSFORM REGIONAL ECONOMIES
CREATE GOOD PAYING JOBS
CONSTRUCTION TRENT LOTT
RATIONS. CAN HELP CATALYZE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY OUR STATE
NEEDS RIGHT NOW IT'S LOOKING
FOR COUPLES ALL OF. THE
NINETEENTH AND THEN. THAT WAS A
GOOD IDEA MISTER SHIN KONG.
DURING THEIR CAN JENNIFER IS
COME MONTHS. YEAH I WOULD SAY
THERE NOW. YOU CAN. ARE GOING.
THE WRONG PATHS AND DELIVERING
TRANCE PROJECTS ABSENCES EACH
LONG AFTER YOU SEE MY
ENVIRONMENT WE REVIEW PROCESS.
WE'RE TRYING TO FIVE INCLUDING
YEAR. NEARLY AYE DADDY ASK
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN WE'RE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT SB FOUR FOUR K.
AGAIN HER TRIAL OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS BY SUPPORT.
OF THE ROOM TO THE OFFICE. ANY
WISH TO SPEAK. IS THERE SOMEONE.
YOU HAVE TO GO TO ONE PHONE IT
IS IMPORTANT PHONE LINE SORRY
ANY. ON THE LINES THE WAY. TO
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE A
MODEL YOU MADAM TO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FOUR
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL TAKE YOU OFFLINE
AND PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FOUR.
THAT'S ONE ZERO NOW. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE THREE PEOPLE FROM
SORRY FOR PEOPLE NOW IN Q.
PLEASE REPLY NUMBER FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SHARE MEMBERS
JOSHUA SHAW WITH SHAW UNIQUE TO
EACH MOTOR LYING FOR THE SAN
MATEO COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT
CALTRAIN THE COMMUTER RAIL
AGENCY THAT SERVES THE SANTA
CLARA SAN MATEO SAN FRANCISCO
PENINSULA AND THE SOLANO
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY ALL
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
CHALLENGE BILL THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND- EVEN
SHARON MEMBERS- ANDREW ANTS WE
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI. WE THANK CENTER
ALLEN OR- DEDICATION TO THIS
ISSUE. AND WE ASK FOR MORE.
CRITICAL CARE. RIGHT THANK YOU
LINE NUMBER TWO FOUR YOU AND IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THAT THIS CHRIS WILL REP BEING
LAW THANK COUNTY COUNTY BETTER.
I THINK OF AT ACCORDING THANK.
ONE HUNDRED YOU AND CURRENT
LINEUP. BY NUMBER NINETEEN YEAR
LINE IS OLD PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING SENATOR IN COMMITTEE MY-
MY NAME IS LUCY I'M SPEAKING TO
ON BEHALF OF. TWO RESEARCH
EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY MAKES
THE BAY AREA WORKS AND THEIR IN
EQUITY JUST AND PROSPEROUS
REGION. WE STRONG SUPPORT SB
FORTY FOUR LARGE SCALE TRANSIT
PROJECTS ARE FREQUENTLY THE
TARGETS OF SHAKEN BABY HE QUIT
BASED LITIGATION CAUSING DELAYS
HIGHER COSTS AND DIMINISHING
THE USEFULNESS OF THE PROJECT
TO THE PEOPLE WHO VOTED AND
PAID FOR IT. SB FORTY FOUR
CREATE CERTAINTY FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS-
INSURING THAT COMMUNITY
CONCERNS CONTINUE TO BE HEARD
AND ADDRESSED IN A TIMELY
FASHION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
THIS MORNING AND YOUR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING DOWN
CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION. RELATED
EMISSIONS THANK YOU. AND WE
HEARD BOOK. AND I'M SURE AT
THIS TIME WAS NO ONE AND YOU.
ARE AT AND IN THE LETTER THANK
YOU I WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION. AND I'M LOOKING AT.
THE SCREEN AND I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE I DO
NOT SEE ANYBODY. HERE IN THIS
ROOM THAT WISHES TO OPPOSE.
THEN LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. THE PROGRAM THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL TAKE YOU OFFLINE
AND PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND THEN PLACE IT BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE
QUEUING UP NOW. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS KATE NEED HELP
WITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
UNFORTUNATELY IS- IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED TO REDUCE THE BURDEN ON
THE COURT. ACCORDING TO NOT
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A POLICY
ISSUE OR WHAT IS THE TYPE OF
THE PROJECT BUT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES WE- ARE IN OPPOSITION
BECAUSE OF THE BURDEN PLACED ON
THE COURT THEY DO TO BE
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW
PROVISIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR. THE WELL THANK YOU A
LINE OF SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN BATES AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RICHARD MARCUSSEN
FOR THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION. WE
DON'T OPPOSE THE ENVIRONMENT
LEADERSHIP TRANSIT PROJECTS
HOWEVER THERE IS A TROUBLING
PROVISION IN THE MEASURE THE
PUBLIC CONTRACTS CODE TWENTY
SIX HUNDRED ESTABLISHES
FINANCIAL PENALTIES IMPOSSIBLE
DEPARTMENT FOR CONTRACTORS WHO
EITHER FAILED TO REPORT OR USE
THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE IN THE APPROPRIATE
RATIOS. BUT LANGUAGE IN THE
MEASURE. GIVE CERTAIN
CONTRACTORS UNDER PRESSURE
KLEBER AGREEMENT A PASS OUT
FROM THESE PENALTIES AND FOR
THAT REASON WE ARE OPPOSED TO
IT UNLESS THE SKILLED TRAINED
WORKFORCE MANDATE. IS APPLIED
ON A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH AT THIS
TIME MADAM CHAIR THERE WAS NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH ME WHEN I. FINISH
MY COFFEE I'M- I'M ON PAGE NINE
OF THE ANALYSIS AND I HEARD
SPUR AND SOME OF THE U. S. SOME
OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE LEGISLATION INDICATE
THAT THERE'S A BIG SEQUEL
PROBLEM A BIG SEQUEL. LIT
LITIGATION PROBLEM AND WHICH IS
BRING EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION TO
THE FACTS THAT OVER FIVE YEARS
THERE'S BEEN TWENTY NINE
CHALLENGES SOME OF THOSE
DUPLICATIVE AND THAT THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THAT THE
EXPEDITED. REVIEW WOULD BE VERY
LOW SO WHAT I UNDERSTAND
PROPONENTS WANT TO BARK ABOUT
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO STREAMLINE
THIS IS THIS IS A LITTLE
INCIDENT OF RACES. OF PROJECTS
THAT WE COME TO THE DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION IT WOULD
ACTUALLY GO THROUGH JUDICIAL
REVIEW WITH THAT SAID. I WOULD
ECHO THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL I MEAN. I'M I
AM DISHEARTENED THAT SB SEVEN
AND THIS BILL HAS TAKEN OUT THE
CLARIFICATION. ABOUT THAT EXIST
IN THE COURTS WHETHER IT'S A
BUSINESS STATE OR SCORE AT
CALENDAR DAY IN AND WE'RE
HERE'S THE LEGISLATURE JUST A
PRIMARY THING THAT WE DO IN THE
LEGISLATURE IS WHEN WE HAVE TWO
STREAMS OF COURT DECISIONS. WE
MAKE IT THIS A STATUTE THAT
CLARIFIES IT WHETHER IT'S
BUSINESS DAYS REPORT DAIS IT
CAN BE IN OTHERS ARGUMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF THEM. BUT WHEN THE
COURTS HAVE THIS AMBIGUITY WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE IS
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS
PICKING AND CHOOSING ON WHAT
SHOULD BE CALCULATED DEPENDING
ON WHETHER THEY WANT TO DELAY
OR THEY WANT TO SPEED UP. IN
ONE OF THE RULES HERE'S
LEGISLATURE AND I'D I'D MENTION
THIS IN SB SEVEN DAYS THAT WE
PROVIDE THAT CLARIFICATION-
WITH SO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AND OUR COURTS. WHO WERE GOING
TO GET INUNDATED WITH CASES
FOLLOWING THE PANDEMIC OF ALL
KINDS IN FAMILY COURTS. AND NOW
THEY'RE FAST TRACKING. TRANSIT
PROJECTS AS WELL AS A HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT WE AT LEAST HELP
THEM OUT ON HOW TO COUNT THE
DAYS SO I WOULD URGE THE
AUTHOR- I DON'T KNOW WHY IT'S-
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE TO DO WITH
IT BUT I WOULD URGE THAT THAT.
FIFTY VERY. IMPORTANT REC TION
THAT THE COURTS. WOULD AYE AYE
A PUTTING BRACE SO. MAN CHAIR
THAT'S MY COMMENTS. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ALI THANK YOU- A SO I
SAID I'M A SUPPORTER BILL NO
PROBLEM I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
CLARIFY MAYBE THE QUESTION WAS
ASKED ABOUT THE ANY UNEVEN
PLAYING FIELD FOR THE FOR THE
CONTRACTORS- I THINK THAT
THAT'S A CONCERN THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED. YEAH WE SO BOTH
CASES ACTUALLY AND ONCE AGAIN
WE ARE. WE ARE WORKING. WITH
THE PRO TEM'S BILL AS THE- SORT
OF MODEL THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
FOR THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED LAST
YEAR AND IT'S HAPPENING AGAIN
THIS YEAR AND SO I THINK THAT-
WE NEED TO GET. WE NEED TO GET
BOTH ISSUES. WORKED ON WITH
WITH WITH THE PRETEND FOLKS
AND- BUT I I'M SYMPATHETIC TO
THE TO THE CALLER'S CONCERNS
AND SO LET ME LET ME CIRCLE
BACK WITH. WITH THAT SIMPLE TO
THE PROFOUND OFFICE AND OUR
STAFF AND WILL CIRCLE BACK WITH
BOTH OF YOUR OFFICES ABOUT BOTH
THIS THIS THIS ISSUE OF THE
COUNTY DAYS I DON'T I DON'T
DISAGREE THE SENATE WITH
CASKEY- AND- AND I ALSO AGREE
WITH THE IDEA THAT THERE OUGHT
TO BE. A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
ASSOCIATED- SO. PRIVATE YEAH I
THINK THIS IS PART OF A BROADER.
WAY ON EXPEDITED REVIEW AND
WE'RE TRYING TO. KEEP THE
LANGUAGE AND CONSISTENT BUT-
BUT IT DOES LEAD TO SOME
COCKINESS AND- AS A WILL BE
TIED TO THEIR OFFICE ABOUT HOW
THAT THAT NON NEGOTIATIONS
PROCEEDING. AND WHEN WELCOME
YOUR INPUT SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT- I'M ON MY EIGHT EIGHT
NINETY YEAR HERE AT THIS AND I
VOTED FOR EVERY SINGLE. SEQUEL
EXEMPTION TO. EXPEDITE THE
PROJECT. AND I THINK THERE'S IT
SHOULD BE NOTED NOT EXEMPTION
OF COURSE NOT WELL BUT WE'RE
STILL MAKING IT SO WE CAN GET
SOMETHING DONE I GUESS THAT'S
WHAT THE AYE I WOULD PUT IT IN
THAT CATEGORY- TRYING TO HELP
GET A PROJECT WITH IT WOULD BE
NO NEED FOR THIS IF WE WERE
TRYING TO GET SOMETHING DONE.
SO I JUST THINK THAT THERE'S
THAT WE NEED TO CIRCLE BACK AT
SOME POINT AND TALK ABOUT HOW
WE MAKE IT WITH. THE SYSTEM
WORK BETTER. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO GET THINGS DONE. AND
IS THIS AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT IT BECAUSE WE-
CONTINUALLY SEE. A LOT OF THIS
MEAN WE JUST DID LAST WEEK FOR.
FOR THE PRO TEM. A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION. OR EXCEED COULD
STREAMLINE LISTA SE
STREAMLINING SO WHAT DOES THAT
TELL US. I GUESS THAT'S THE
POINT I'M TRYING TO THINK WHAT
DOES THIS TELL US THAT TELLS US
THAT WE HAVE A PROBLEM. AND WE
PICK AND CHOOSE. WE PICK AND
CHOOSE WHICH ONES WE WANT TO.
HELP STREAMLINE OR THE ONES WE
DON'T BUT THERE'S A LOT OF OUT
THERE THAT DON'T GET THAT
SPECIAL EXEMPTION OR
EXPRESSIONIST REMINDING. THAT
LEGISLATION SO I JUST WANT TO
BRING IT TO KNOW THAT. YOU
KNOW. SOMETIMES WHEN YOU SEE
THIS MANY TYPES OF STREAMLINING
WE ARE STREAMLINED SOMETHING
AND MAKE IT WORK FOR EVERYBODY.
NOT JUST THE SELECT FEW SO I
JUST WANT TO GO ON RECORD.
AGAIN BECAUSE I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS FOR A LONG TIME I
TRY TO DO. SOME STREAMLINING.
PROCESSES WHEN I FIRST CAME IN
YOU KNOW I DIDN'T GET ON THE
GATE BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
INTEREST IN ON ALL SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE. WHETHER TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE. WHETHER
IT'S A CONSTRUCTION SITE.
WHETHER IT'S- BUSINESSES
COMPETING AGAINST BUSINESSES
THAT DON'T THERE'S A LOT. OF
INTEREST I SHOULD SAY MAYBE
THAT'S A GREAT WORD FOR IN THIS
AREA SO I JUST WANT TO BRING
THAT TO LIFE BECAUSE WE DO THIS
A LOT. AND THAT OUGHT TO GIVE
US INDICATION THAT MAYBE WE
SHOULD DO SOMETHING OVERALL
THAT MAKES IT WORK FOR
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU YES SIR I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
EIGHT- ONE THING I WILL SAY
CENTER TASK IS RIGHT. AND WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF
CASES IN IN IN THE IN THE- YOU
KNOW WITH THE WITH THIS BILL-
THE DID THE OTHER THING I
SUPPOSE THIS IS THAT. YOU KNOW
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ABOUT.
PUBLIC TRANSIT. PROJECTS THAT
HAVE TO MEET HIGH ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS. IT'S SUCH AN
UNEQUIVOCAL. ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFIT. AND DONE SO I THINK
THE IDEA WAS THAT. WITH WITH
PROJECTS THAT HAVE SUCH A-
FACIALLY- FIVE OF. VISUAL
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND
ESPECIALLY WITH TH STANDARDS
THAT THEY HAVE TO MEET THAT
THAT. THAT MERITS THIS THIS
APPROACH ESPECIALLY. GIVEN THE
FACT THAT WE'RE NOT REALLY
TALKING ABOUT VERY MANY. BUT
BUT THE BROADER DISCUSSION IS
CERTAINLY GET ONE AND IT'S I
THINK IT'S ONE THAT WE- HAVE
CONTINUED TO HAVE AYE YOU THIS
COMMITTEE IS CERTAINLY- SHOW
MORE FLEXIBILITY ON SECRET AND
THEN COMMITTEES IN THE PAST AND-
RIGHT BUT THEN AGAIN I YOU KNOW
I ALSO THINK THAT WE UNITED
ASSEMBLY CASKEY THIS IS PLAYING
HIS ROLE I THINK JUSTIFIABLY AS
AS A AS A GUARDIAN OF C. COULD
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A-
THERE'S A LOT OF VALUE TO IT I
THINK MY GENERAL APPROACH IS
BANNED. IF WE'RE GOING TO OFFER
FLEXIBILITY WE REALLY HAVE TO
ISSUE SHOW ADAM DEMONSTRABLE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT
ASSOCIATED- BUT THAT SAID THIS
IS A- THIS IS THIS IS THE
DISCUSSION WE'RE IN NOW AS A
COMMITTEE IN AND ON AND ON A
MACRO LEVEL AND THIS IS PART OF
THE DISCUSSION. ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE ON. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR ON THE ALL OF THEM
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ALAN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ALAN
HI ALAN BY. FATES FIVE EIGHT
FIVE DOLLARS FIVE DALY AYE
GONZALEZ TIE SALAS I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN Y. CASKEY HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI I. SIX ZERO SIX
WHEN WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR SENATOR STERN AND THEN IT
WILL BE A RE REFER TO JUDICIARY
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE. SB TWO SIXTY ONE SENATOR
ALAN. THANK YOU. MADAMS VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. PFIZER BURKE
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WE PASSED
SB ONE FIFTY WHICH IS THE PRO
TEM'S BILL YOU MAY RECALL. AND
THE CARD IN THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION RESULTING FROM
WENDY'S PLANNING DECISIONS AND
ISSUE A REPORT AFFECTIONATELY
KNOWN AS SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
AND- THE FINDINGS OF THAT
REPORT WERE CLEAR KERR NOTED
THE CALIFORNIA IS NOT ON TRACK
TO MEET GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION. EXPECTED UNDER SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WHICH WAS
SOME CENTER CYBER EXPELLED FROM
FOR QUITE SOMETIME AGO. AS OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR ACCOUNTED
FOR NEARLY HALF OF THE STATE'S
TOTAL EMISSIONS. MAN BECAUSE
THE MISSIONS AND WHILE
EMISSIONS FROM OTHER SECTORS
HAVE DECLINED THE TREND LINE
FOR TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS
CONTINUES IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION DESPITE INCREASES IN
FUEL EFFICIENCY AND DECREASES
IN THE CARBON CONTENT OF FUEL.
YET ACCORDING TO THE REPORT OF
EVERY CALIFORNIAN. DROVE ONE
POINT FIVE MILES LESS EACH DAY
BY TWENTY THIRTY OUR STATE
WOULD REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS.
EMISSIONS AND MEET CLIMATE
GOALS FOR THIS BILL IMPLEMENT
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THAT REPORT IN AN EFFORT
TO GET. OUR STATE BACK ON TRACK
AND BETTER ALIGN LOCAL LAND USE
PLANNING WITH THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION CLIMATE GOALS IT
REQUIRES. THE METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS WHICH
ARE TASKED WITH CREATING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES. DESIGNED TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS WITHIN THEIR REGIONS.
AND ALSO AND REQUIRES THAT THE
NPOS IDENTIFY STRATEGIES FOR
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
NOW IDENTIFY NICKEL DIFFICULT
MILES TRAVELED. REDUCTIONS IN
PLANNING STRATEGIES WILL ENSURE
THAT LAND USE AND
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING ARE
BETTER ALIGNED TO ADDRESS
RISING EMISSIONS FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND ALSO
HOPEFULLY YOU HAD TO HANDLE
SOME OF OUR CONGESTION
CHALLENGES AND IN THE END
CITIES LIKE MINE. WHAT TWO
SIXTY ONE CREATES A PROCESS FOR
INCREASED COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE NPOS AND CARB THE REQUIRES
THAT THE MPO SUBMIT THEIR DROPS
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGY
TO CAR. AND THE CAR PROVIDE
WRITTEN FEEDBACK WITHIN FORTY
FIVE DAYS NPOS WILL BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE HOW FEEDBACK IS
INCORPORATED INTO. THEIR FINAL
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES. THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES LIKE CITIES AND
COUNTIES REPORT TO NPOS THE
EXISTING AND PLANNED
INFRSTRUCTURE THE DENTISTS HOW
THEY'RE IMPLEMENTING THEIR
STABLE COMMITTEE STRATEGIES.
MEDIA THE FIGHT BY INCREASING.
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE NPOS
IN CARBON THIS BILL WILL
STRENGTHEN SUSTAINABLE
COMMITTEE STRATEGIES AND BRING
US CLOSER TO. MEETING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS SO HERE INTEST
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WE'VE GOT
A CARD A RIBBON ON BEHALF A
NATURIST DEFENSE COUNSEL. AND
ALSO WILLIAM BARRETT ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION. PLEASE THE BOARD.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE OUR
SUPPORTERS ONLINE. YES I'M SURE
THE LINES ARE OPEN. THANK YOU
MORNING THIS IS CARTER WRITTEN
IN THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL I'M DELIGHTED
TO BE HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS
ENTITIES TO PORT FOR SB TWO
SIXTY ONE WHICH WILL ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO
HALT CLIMATE CHANGE EXTEND TO
OUR LARGEST SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GASES. THE TERM
MENTIONED THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR CALIFORNIANS ARE ALREADY
SUFFERING FROM THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
POOR AIR QUALITY. AND DESPITE
INCREASINGLY FRIEDMAN.
DISASTERS WE CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT POURS
MORE FUEL ON THAT FIRE. OUR OWN
STATE AGENCIES EMBRACE THE
ALARM THAT OUR CURRENT
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES ARE
PUSHING MORE ROADS AND WIDER
ROADS YOU KNOW GENERATE MORE
DRIVING. SO S. B. TWO SIXTY ONE
BUILT ON THE FOUNDATIONAL WORK
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE ENSURE
ALLEN'S BILL SB ONE FIFTY.
RECOGNIZING THAT FIGHTING
CLIMATE CHANGE MEANS GIVING
CALIFORNIANS. SOMETHING THEY
CONSISTENTLY ASKED FOR THE
ABILITY TO GET AROUND WITHOUT
GETTING IN THEIR CARS. AND
THANKS TO SB ONE FIFTY WHICH
REALLY SETS THE TABLE FOR THIS
BILL WE KNOW THAT. THE PORTION
OF COMMUTERS DRIVE ALONE TO
WORK. IT WAS RISING PARTS THE
PANDEMIC. VEHICLE MISSIONS ARE
CLIMBING DESPITE OUR EFFORTS TO
CLEAN UP THE VEHICLE FLEET. AND
IMPORTANTLY CALIFORNIA STANDS
TO SPEND. OVER A TRILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE LIFE OF
CURRENT TRANSPORTATION PLANS
BUT THAT THESE PLANS ARE NOT
ALIGNED WITH OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
SO SB TWO SIXTY ONE SO TAKE THE
SHIFT- TO ALIGN OUR INVESTMENTS
WITH A CHRONICLES BY
INTEGRATING VMT INTO THE
PLANNING FRAMEWORK SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE. MAKE SURE
REGIONAL PLANNER HELPING REDUCE
DRIVING IMPROVING ALTERNATIVE
STRIVING. YEAH THIS BILL
CREATES A BETTER STRUCTURE FOR
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO
REVIEW THE REGION STRATEGIES
FOR REDUCING. THE EMPTY AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
IS PROPELLED DRINK LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE TABLE TO WORK
WITH REGION TO HARMONIZE THEIR
LOCAL LAND USE PLAN TO
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT. IS
REGIONAL PLAN THANK YOU
SHALLENBERGER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO. HI THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LIVES GO TO OUR ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE WISHING TO. TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AND FORTY TWO OR- KATHY
THE CW. TWENTY FIVE THE BLUES
WILL BEAR IT WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION ALSO SPEAKING-
YOUR CURRENT SUPPORTERS SB TWO
SIXTY ONE- WE DO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMPROVING ON THE LEGISLATION
BUT FOR TODAY WE'RE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT. BECAUSE THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR LEADING
SOURCE OF CALIFORNIANS ON
CLIMATE MOTION. WITHOUT A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
HEALTHIER MORE SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION THAT SERVES ALL
RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA WILL NOT
MEET OUR CLEANER INCLEMENT
STANDARDS. LAND USE AND
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING IS
CENTRAL TO THIS DISCUSSION WE
ARE NOT ON TRACK TO ACHIEVING
THE CLIMATE HEALTHEQUITY
CONSERVATION AND SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS OR CENTRAL. SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE. U. S. B. TO SIXTY
OF THEM OP. TO IMPROVE SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE. AND SECURE BUT-
SECURE BENEFITS OF HELP YOUR
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY OUR
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
OFTEN DEALING WITH CHRONIC
HEALTH BURDENS. DUE TO LACK OF
HEALTHY TRANSPORTATION OP AND
OPTIONS AND HIGH LEVELS OF
TRANSPORTATION POLLUTION. AS
ENVISIONED IN SB TWO SIXTY ONE
UPDATING THE TARGET TIME FRAMES
BROADENING THE FOCUS TO INCLUDE
THE EMPTY REDUCTION TARGETS. IN
THE ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS
ARE ALL IMPORTANT STEPS IN
PURSUIT OF HEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES. WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW SB TWO SIXTY ONE INVESTING
SURE BUT THE PROMISE OF SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE IS REALIZED
FOR EVERY COMMUNITY. IN TERMS
OF ADDRESSING BARRIERS TO BMG
REDUCTIONS TO THE HISTORIC
UNDER INVESTMENT OR OTHER
CHALLENGES AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. WHETHER SCS
ACTIONS REDUCE POLLUTION AND
POOR HEALTH OUTCOMES IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WE
ALSO LIKE TO DISCUSS MORE. ON
IT TO DISPLACEMENT MEASURES.
FINALLY WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE PRIORITIZING
COMMUNITY IDENTIFIED PROJECTS
TO PROVIDE MULTIPLE BENEFITS.
TO HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. INCLUDING WE THE
COMMITTEE TO PASS A SIMPLE TO.
AND FOR THE ON GOING. TO
EXPLORE UPPER. TO ENSURE THAT
THIS CRITICAL TRANSITION TO
HELP THEIR COMMUNITIES IMPROVE
THE HEALTH AND MOBILITY CHOICES
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. WITHOUT
ALSO AFFECTED CENTER ALLEN FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE AND THE COURT TO
WORKING WITH YOU GOING FORWARD.
THANK THANK YOU MR BERRA I'M
SORRY I AM. WENT TO THE ROOM
BEFORE I FINISH THOSE ON ON THE
PHONE LINE I'LL GET THIS BEFORE
OF THIS MEETINGS OVER SO NOW WE
WILL GO TO. ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE TO SEE IF ANYONE IS THERE
JUST WE CAN SUPPORT TWENTY
FORTY. FORTY TWENTY FORTY
WORKING WITH IT. THEY HAVE
FORTY TWO OF THREE WE'RE IN
FORTY I KNOW BUT THERE'S NOBODY
HERE INITIALLY THAT WANTS TO
SUPPORT US ALL GET THIS DOWN
HERE. OKAY NOW. WE WILL GO TO
TWENTY FORTY I DO KNOW. SEE
ANYONE IN THEIR RIGHT DOWN.
MAN- THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ON DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ON THE LINE MATAMATA READER
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. YES THEY LINE THEIR
OPEN BILL HIGGINS IN CASSIE
GILSON- THANK YOU- COMMITTEE
AND THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL
HIGGINS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS THE STATE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS
ALL. EIGHTEEN METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATION. AND THAT
ARE AB RESPONSIBILITY FOR
IMPLEMENTING SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE- UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
TAKING IN OPPOSE POSITION TODAY
BECAUSE- WELL WE AGREE WITH SO
MUCH OF WHAT SENATOR ALLEN SAID
AND ABSOLUTE MOST OF THE- A
PROPONENTS SAY- THIS BILL
DOESN'T THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM AND THAT IS THERE IS A
PORTION OF. BMT REDUCTION
STRATEGIES BUT ARB IDENTIFIED
AS HE INITIATED BNP REDUCTION
STRATEGIES BUT BEEN IDENTIFIED
FOR FOUR YEARS. AND THERE HAS
BEEN NOTHING DONE AND IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE THE REDUCTIONS WE
NEED IT'S UNFAIR TO SAY THAT B.
M. T. IS RISING BECAUSE SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE A COMPANY
IMPLEMENTED WHEN THE STATE THAT
HAS DONE NOTHING TO IMPLEMENT
IT. SHARE OF THE BMT REDUCTION
STRATEGIES- AND THAT'S OUR
QUESTION IS WHY IS SB TWO SIXTY
ONE JUST FOCUSED ON THE PORTION
OF BEACH REDUCTIONS FOR WHICH
WE HAVE A PLAN THAT EVERYBODY
HAS BEEN APPROVED THAT IS
BACKED BY TRIBAL MODELS HAVE
GONE THROUGH ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW AND HAVE BEEN
SCRUTINIZED WHEN THERE'S
ANOTHER SET OF MISSIONS. WHERE
NOTHING IS DONE. IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU THIS IS THE TIME FOR ACTION.
WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
COOPERATIVELY TO COMBINE AND
INTERTWINE OUR STRATEGY IS THAT
THE STATE REGIONAL LOCAL LEVEL
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE OUR GOALS
AND THAT BRINGS ME THE SECOND
POINT ALL OF OUR OPPOSITION. IS
WE BRADLEY S. B. WANTED TO
REPORT REALLY CLOSELY AND WE
DON'T THINK THAT THIS BILL
ACHIEVES WHAT THE DIRECTION WAS
ON THE BILL THE REPORT CLEARLY
SAYS. THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A
STRUCTURAL CHANGE TO THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN STATE
REGIONAL LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
WE DON'T THINK THAT THE WEEKS
TO THE DAY R. B. MPO APPROVAL
PROCESS TO ACHIEVE THAT. THERE
ARE OTHER THINGS THAT ALSO NEED
TO BE DONE LIKE AN
INTERGOVERNMENTAL WORKING
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH PUBLIC. AND
THE SHARING OF DATA IN
INCREASING THE DATA FOR US TO
DO THESE METRICS BUT THIS BILL
IS SILENT. WE ARE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
AUTHOR ALL OF THE PROPONENTS
MPO WILL BRING OUR MPO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION WHICH BRING IN A
R. B. THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
APPLE IT'S THE CALTRANS. ALL OF
THEM TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO A
PARTNERSHIP BUT RUNNING THIS
SINGLE BILL THAT SAYS NPOS YOU
SHOULD BE DOING MORE WHAT WE A.
R. P. SAYS. WELL IT'S INVISIBLE
TO ASK US TO DO MORE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY. TO
IMPOSE PRICING PURPLE OR IMPOSE
LAND USE STRUCTURES WE NEED
BETTER OR THERE ARE THINGS THAT
WE COULD BE DOING BETTER AND WE
NEED TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND SO. WE'RE
GOING TO OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOT ONLINE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CASSIE GILSON WITH AXIOM
ADVISERS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO TWO SIXTY ONE
WHICH CTIA HAS IDENTIFIED AS A
HOUSING KILLER PARTY GEAR. I
SEE I AM OPPOSED IS TWO SIXTY
ONE BECAUSE IT REQUIRES REGION
TO TAKE IN FEASIBLE ACTIONS
THAT MAY RENDER THEIR REGIONAL
LAND USE PLANS UNACHIEVABLE
WHICH PREVENTS INDIVIDUAL
HOUSING PROJECTS FROM COMPLYING
WITH THEM AND THEREFORE CREATES
NEW SEQUEL IMPACTS. COSTS FOR
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION. AND
EXISTING WALK OR GIVES WE
PLANNING. GREEN GAS REDUCTION.
THAT ARE AT THE END **** AS
POSSIBLE WHILE STILL BEING
ACHIEVABLE. AS MR HIGGINS
EXPLAINED CARDINALIS CAN
INDICATE THAT THE CUMULATIVE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS ACHIEVED
BY REGIONAL GHG PLAN LEAVE A
GAP OF ABOUT 7% TO ACHIEVE OUR
STATEWIDE SCOPING PLAN GOALS
FOR REDUCTIONS FROM THE LAND
USE SECTOR. CARBOXYL INDICATES
THAT THAT REMAINING SEVEN
PERCENT. NEEDS TO BE ACHIEVED
BY STATE WIDE SCOPE AT
STATEWIDE OFFICIATED ACTIONS
NOT REGIONAL BECAUSE THEY
INVOLVE ADOPTING MECHANISMS
LIKE ROAD PRICING WHICH THE
REGION OR THE TO DO- IN
REQUIRING THEM TO DO MORE BY
DEFINITION WOULD BE
UNACHIEVABLE. WHY IS THIS
RELEVANT TO HOME BUILDERS.
HOUSING PROJECTS HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH SEQUIN ONE SECRET
OBLIGATIONS IS THAT PROJECTS
COMPLY WITH ALL APPLICABLE LAND
USE PLANS WHICH INCLUDES. THE
FAVORABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGIES
AND A HOUSING PROJECT CAN NOT
COMPLY WITH A BEACON YES IT
WILL BE DETERMINED TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT UNDER SPEAK
WHAT THAT REQUIRES FURTHER
MITIGATION. I TWO SIXTY REQUIRE
REGION TO ADOPT TO THE END OR
PIPE GHG AND FOR. ON TOP OF THE
ALREADY. FEASIBLE GHG
REDUCTIONS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
GIVEN BY CAR AND CENTER REGION
LIKELY CAN'T COMPLY WITH THEM
APPROACH THE STATUS OF THEIR AT
THE ACT IN QUESTION. AND
THEREFORE ALSO GROWTH THIS WEEK
WITH THAT IS THAT INDIVIDUAL
HOUSING PROJECT. THAT MUST
COMPLY WITH. THOSE PLANS INTO
QUESTION AS WELL. AT BASS THIS
WILL RAISE THE- ADVANTAGE. FOR
HOUSING. EAGLE COMPLIANCE.
WHICH UNDOUBTEDLY WILL SPAWN
LITIGATION AND AT WORST IT
NEEDS THE BOTH THE PUBLICATION
INSIGNIFICANT NEW MEDICATION
COSTS FOR HOUSING PROJECTS.
THEY CAN'T COMPLY WITH AN
APPROVED PLAN. IT BEARS
MENTIONING THAT ALL OF THESE
INDIVIDUAL HOUSING PROJECTS ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED TO MITIGATE
YOUR G. H. G. AND BMP IMPACT
INDIVIDUALLY. BECAUSE AN ADDED
BURDEN ON TOP OF THAT
MEDICATION THAT THERE ARE YOU
REQUIRED TO DO UNDER C. CLASS.
YEAH A SUPPORT F. THREE SEVEN
FIVE WHEN WAS PASSED AND SIGNED
INTO LAW. IN CONTINUES TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO SUPPORT A
HOST OF OTHER BUILDING
STANDARDS THAT FURTHER REDUCE
ANY PROJECTS GHG EMISSIONS
TREMENDOUSLY. WELL CA REMAINS
OPEN TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON
REGIONAL CLIMATE AND GHG
REDUCTION STRATEGY GOING
FORWARD WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AND THE AUTHOR. GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE HOUSING CRISIS
IT MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
LEGISLATION PROJECT TO PICK THE
ONES. THAT WILL ADD SIGNIFICANT
COSTS TO DELIVER MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKYOU ON WE WILL NOW GO TO
ROOM FOR WE'RE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE ARE COMING TO THE
MICROPHONE TO OPPOSE- GOING TO
RAM TWENTY FORTY- NO ONE THERE.
ARE SOME MONEY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THEN WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AND WE NEED TO
DOUBLE BACK AND LISTEN TO THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
WHO ARE NOW ON. ON THE
TELECONFERENCE MADAME.
MODERATOR WE PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO SIXTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER IN PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF. S. B. TWO SIXTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THE NEW ZERO NOW.
THANK YOU MEDICARE WE LOOK LIKE
WE HAVE THREE PARTIES SHOWING
UP. MY NUMBER SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS LAUREN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF FAIR BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SB. TWO SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU
MY NUMBER SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING TURNS MANY MEMBERS DO
AT RANDOLPH BUT THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR WE ARE VOICING
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL- I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE SOME OF
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION. ON
THIS BILL AS WRITTEN WOULD GO
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION BY
UPDATING AND STRENGTHENING SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE BY REQUIRING
NEW TARGET CREAKING SOUND THE
BILITY WITHIN THE PLANNING
PROCESS AND ALSO IMPROVING THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN CARD IN
THE NPOS FOR THIS REASON WE ASK
THE COMMITTEE. TO PASS THIS
BILL WHILE WE CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE SENATOR TO ADD
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD BETTER
SERVE CALIFORNIA'S HISTORICALLY.
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHALLENGE ME
MEMBERS JUSTICE KELLY HAMEL ON
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTUALLY GEN I JUST CALLING
INTO VOICE SUPPORT OF THE BILL-
IN THAT WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE SENATOR TO
INCORPORATE EQUITY
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES. THANK
YOU. THE MESSAGE TOM MADAM
CHAIR WILL HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF. IN LATEST MOVE TO
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. MADAME MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO SIXTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH MY NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO SIXTY ONE. PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. THE MANAGER LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE ONE PERSON IN JUNE.
BY NUMBER SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GATHERED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION ALIGNING ARE
CONCERNED WITH ALL THE COMMENTS
PREVIOUSLY GIVEN THANK YOU. CAN
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE AT LINE
NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
CHAIR NUMBER THE COMMITTEE
AUTOMATICALLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AND AT THIS TIME AND I'M
SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
NOW ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO.
PROVIDE COMMENT. ON SB TWO
SIXTY ONE. SENATOR DOLLY. SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT- WE JUST
DID SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE A FEW
YEARS BACK AND- WE'VE TRIED TO
LOOK AT. REGIONAL PLANNING FOR
DEVELOPMENT. FOR MAKES SENSE
AND SO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU START
TALKING ABOUT VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. I THINK PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE THAT THERE'S A
VERY LARGE STATE. WITH VERY
DIVERSE AND DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES DIFFERENT THAN. A
COMMUNITY MAYBE THE CHAIRMAN
LIVES IN VERSUS A COMMUNITY I
LIVE IN WHEN YOU START TALKING
ABOUT VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. I
DROVE FOR HALF HOURS LAST NIGHT
TO GET TO SACRAMENTO. AND I
DRIVE SEVENTY FIVE MILES ONE
WAY TO GET TO WALMART NOW THANK
GOD WE HAVE AMAZON SO FIVE I
REDUCE MY CARBON FOOTPRINT
BECAUSE AMAZON'S BRING ALL
KINDS OF STUFF TO MY COMMUNITY.
WITH ONE TRIP VERSUS PEOPLE
GOING ON SINGLE TRIPS AND COST
GOING ALL OF THEM DO IT AND WE
WERE USING THOSE ABILITIES
BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY IT'S A
LOT MORE LESS EXPENSIVE. BUT
THAT DOESN'T GET CALCULATED
INTO ANY OF THESE. PROGRAMS AND
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT SOMEBODY
WHO'S REALLY DISADVANTAGED IN A
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE IS
TRYING TO MAKE A LIVING IN
THESE VERY SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN
YOU START PUTTING MORE
RESTRICTIONS ON THE COUNTIES BY
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND THEN
SEEK WERE- BURKE BURDENS OF
SEQUEL TO BE ABLE TO. DO
PLANNED COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THOSE. FOLKS
TO STAY IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
PLANNED OR UNINTENTIONAL OR
IRRITATE OR INTENTIONAL- BUT WE
SEE A LOT OF LEGISLATION COMING
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATURE WHERE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY JUST DON'T
WANT PEOPLE LIVING OUT IN OUR
AREAS I MEAN. SENATOR WIENER
TRY TO DO A BILL IF YOU WERE AN
S. R. AREA YOU COULD EVEN BUILD
LAST A FEW YEARS AGO AND THANK
GOD WE KILL THAT BILL BECAUSE A
LOT OF CALIFORNIA'S US ALREADY
AND WE NEED FOLKS OUT THERE.
TENDING TO THE LAND. AND SO I
WILL BE OPPOSING THIS BILL I
DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY NOW
I THINK WE HAVE SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE THAT LAID OUT THE
GROUNDWORK AND I DON'T WANT TO
GIVE ANY MORE POWER. TO AN
UNELECTED BODY. AT A R. B. TO
BE ABLE TO REGULATE- MY REALLY
POOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
OUT THERE WHO ARE TRYING TO
STAY IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
BE ABLE TO BUILD A HOME SUNDAY
AND IF YOU HAVE TO MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS. A WITH A HOUSING
SHORTAGE WE WON'T SEE THOSE
FOLKS BE ABLE TO. STAY OUT
THERE AND- I KNOW ALL THE
PLANNERS OF I SAID ON THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS AND I'M TONY I
SAT THROUGH MORE MEETINGS THAN
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT. LISTENING
TO THE- PLANNERS OF THE WORLD
AND LOOK WE ALL KNOW. THAT IF
YOU PUT ALL THE PEOPLE IN ONE
SPOT. THE BILL HIGHRISES AND
COMPACTUM AND- MAKE A MALL NOT
HAVE A CAR. IN YEAH THERE'S A
LESS OF A FOOTPRINT. NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT. BUT I WILL TELL YOU
THAT THAT'S NOT WHAT THE PEOPLE
WANT IT'S ABOUT FREEDOM IT'S
ABOUT CHOICE AND IT'S ABOUT
BALANCE WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
BALLOTS. THINK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS JUST DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. PEOPLE ARE FLEEING
SAN FRANCISCO IN DROVES AND
THEY'RE COMING TO SACRAMENTO
THE HOUSING MARKET HERE IS
EXPLODING I I'VE BEEN LOOKING
TO TRY TO PURCHASE ONE HERE
BECAUSE- THE RENT IS ALSO HIGH
BUT THE HOUSING TIGHTNESS
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE EXITING.
TERENCE'S COAT THE SAME PEOPLE
ARE EXITING. TWO MEYER YOU
CANNOT FIND- OF HOMER PIECE OF
PROPERTY BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE
FREAKED OUT DURING COVERT WHEN
THERE WHEN EVERYTHING SHUT DOWN
THEIR STOCK IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND THEY AND THEY FELT COOPED
UP FOR LA OR WHEREVER THEY CAME
FROM BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
EXITING. THE CITIES AND THEY
AND I THINK IT WILL COME UP TO
THE BUILDING THAT THEY HAVE NO
FREEDOM TO BE ABLE TO MOVE OR
TO BE ABLE TO DO ANYTHING IF
YOU HAVE A PANDEMIC OR YOU HAVE
SOME NATURAL DISASTER. SO I
JUST WANT TO KIND OF PAINT THE
PICTURE OF SOMEBODY WHO
REPRESENTS A LOT OF POOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AN
ABILITY BILL WILL STAY THERE SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I'LL BE
OPPOSING THIS LEGISLATION. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS YOU
HAVE A MOTION THEN. PROBABLY IF
DOUBLE REFERRED YES THE
TRANSPORTATION. IS THERE A
MOTION MCCARTY THAT IS WHY COST.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THAT WOULD
AFFECT IF YOU WANNA PULL MY
CLOTHES NO IN FACT I'M GETTING.
REALLY DID MANAGE THIS THING I
GOT. THE GOVERNMENT MAINLY TO
GIVE. TO MY CALL- I THINK YOU
BRING VERY SIR CONCERN I'M
LIVING TO THE SAME RIGHT NOW
TRYING. FIGURE OUT HOW HERE IN
SOCCER AS WELL. I'M ALL I WILL
SAY IS THAT- I HOPE FOLKS
UNDERSTAND. THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT IMPOSE THE SAME SORT OF
PLANNING- YOU KNOW REQUIREMENTS
FROM A CITY ONTO A RURAL. THIS
THE- FRAMEWORK THAT THAT THIS
FITS INTO. AND THE IDEA IS THAT
THE RURAL AREAS OF THE STATE OR
CERTAINLY NOT HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARD AS URBAN AREAS- THE-
AIR B. SETS THE STANDARDS BASED
BY REGION. AND- IT TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT. URBAN AND RURAL.
DIFFERENCES ARE HAPPY TO LOOK
AT HOW THAT. PLAYS OUT BUT BUT
I BUT I DON'T WANT ANYONE TO
LEAVE THIS DISCUSSION I HAVE
WITH THE SENSE THAT WERE
IMPOSING THE SAME VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. STANDARDS ON SANTA
MONICA IS AND BE BERMAN THIS IS
NOT THAT'S NOT WHAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE THERE'S AN
ABSOLUTE RECOGNITION OF THE
FACT THAT. PEOPLE IN RURAL
AREAS BY DEFINITION HAVE TO
DRIVE MORE TO GET TO WHERE
THEY'RE GOING. THE OTHER THING
I WILL SAY BY THE WAY IS THAT
THE AMAZON- ASPECT OF THIS IS
FACTORED IN- YOU KNOW THE FACT
THAT- THAT. YOU KNOW THE
STATE'S ON. WHARTON THE THIS
MODEL TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
DELIVERIES. AND ALL THAT AS FAR
AS I UNDERSTAND IF I'M IF I'M
MISTAKEN IN THAT LET'S GO BACK
AND TAKE A LOOK AND SEE HOW WE
CAN GET THAT- JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S ACCURACY. BECAUSE
I THINK YOUR POINT WELL TAKEN
ABOUT ME MAKING SURE THAT. HERE
WE ARE JUST OFFSITE. YOU KNOW
IF VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED BEING
OFFSET ON ONE SIDE BUT REPLACED
BY SOMETHING ELSE AND THAT HAS
TO BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT AND
THERE ARE OTHER AS WE'RE
KIDDING OURSELVES SO- SO.
THERE'S A THERE'S A VERY
DIFFERENT SET OF STANDARDS THAT
ARE APPLIED TO RURAL URBAN-
REGIONS AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WAS CLARIFIED AND-
AND IT WAS. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION AND
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN ARE
JUST OF P. OFF ON THAT I
TOTALLY AGREE THAT THAT'S THE
WAY IT SHOULD BE. UNFORTUNATELY
WHEN IT'S GIVEN THE A. R. B. IT
BECOMES. YOU KNOW VERY COOKIE
CUTTER AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE
WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
GUIDELINES. THAT IT COMES BACK
TO THIS LEGISLATURE WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE VMT IS
GOING TO BE APPLIED AND- WHO
HAS A FAITHFUL AND IT FEELS
REMORSE. CONSCRIPTED OF. ALL IN
OUR LEGISLATION SO THAT WE TAKE
THE RESPONSIBILITY. AND THE
AUTHORITY BACK FROM THE
BUREAUCRACY IS I THINK YOU MAKE
A LOT OF MORE PEOPLE HAPPY ON.
OF THESE KIND OF IMPOSED
MANDATES THAT EVENTUALLY COME
OUT OF FOR MANDATE. THE STAFF
WHAT I FEEL IS THE REAL ISSUE
OUT THERE WHEN I SPEAK TO
PEOPLE EVERYONE IS. VERY AWARE
THAT WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT. CLIMATE CHANGE AND ALL
OF THAT THAT IF THE MANNER IN
WHICH IT COMES DOWN ON THEM AND
THE REPRESENTATIVE IS KIND OF
CUT OUT OF THE DEAL. SO I JUST
AFTER GOING FORWARD YOU TAKE A
LITTLE. ROCK ACTUALLY THERE ARE
MANY WILL SEE. CHART ALL
THROUGHOUT THIS BILL THERE'S
CALLS THEIR INDIAN CREEK
REQUIREMENTS FOR INCREASED
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN AIRBNB
NPOS AND LOCALS. BECAUSE OF
THAT ISSUE ACTUALLY SENATOR
THERE'S BEEN. THERE ISN'T
ENOUGH COMMUNICATION THERE
ISN'T ENOUGH DATA. SHARING- AND
SO I YEAH. SO NOW EFFECT BE
STRENGTH LET'S LET'S TO A LOOK
AT A AND WORK ON A TOGETHER.
WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND YOU HAVE MAJOR CLOSE AND
IDEA TO PEIA FINANCE. I AM
TOTALLY OUT OF SUCH A
PROVOCATIVE THAT MOMENTUM I.
CASUAL ANYWAY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE GIVES ME THE MOTION-
MADAM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
TWO SIX ONE BY SENATOR ALAN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION ALAN. ALLEN AYE
BATES NO. BATES NO DALY NO
DALLY NO GONZALEZ HI. AND SALAS
I SKINNER. STERN Y. CASCADE
HIGH. THREE THREE THEN WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS WHO WILL BE ABA
FINING ON AND NOW I KNOW THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO OUR
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION.
WELL THE ROLE OF IT RIGHT NOW
THREE TWO. ZERO REGION IN WILL
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SB THREE
FORTY THREE SAT CORRECT YES AND
I APOLOGIZE MEMBERS FOR.
PICKING UP AT THE CHECK OF THIS
MORNING'S- THIS BILL I YOU KNOW
I THINK MOST OF YOU KNOW THAT
I'VE BEEN SPENDING A LOT OF
TIME ALONG WITH THE NUMBER OF
YOU ON. ON- TRYING TO ADDRESS
OUR- ARE. SOME OF THE GREAT.
STRUCTURAL CHALLENGES THAT
EXIST FOR THE GUARDS TO. WASTE
AND PLASTIC AND- AND THE IMPACT
OF THIS NOT HAVING NOT ONLY IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO IN OUR
CITIES. I HAD IT ONE OF THE
MANY THINGS THAT I'VE- COME
HERE. TO BE PAINFULLY AWARE OF.
IS HOW THE AND THE MARKETING
CLAIMS THAT OUR ON PRODUCTS ARE
IS GETTING SO OUT OF WHACK WITH
THE REALITY THAT PEOPLE SEE.
THE RECYCLING SYMBOL ON THEIR
PRODUCT AND THEY PUT IN THE
RECYCLING BIN. I THINK FULLY
EXPECTING THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
RECYCLED AND OF COURSE AS SO
MANY OF THOSE PRODUCTS ARE NOT.
SO A CURRENT LAW. THIS IS THE
INTERESTING THINGS MEMBERS
CURRENT LAW. PROHIBITS THE
MANUFACTURE FOR MAKING AN ENTRY
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL CLAIMS SUCH
AS- YOU KNOW. RECYCLABLE YOU
CAN'T LAKE RECYCLABLE ON. TOP
OF A PRODUCT IF IT'S NOT
RECYCLABLE IT'S NOT A TRULY
RECYCLABLE BUT- ARE THE LAW
DOES NOT COVER THE CHASING
ARROW SYMBOL SO THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THAT THAT THAT RECYCLING
SYMBOL THAT WE ALL. KNOW AND
SEE ON OUR ON OUR ON OUR
PRODUCTS. SO NOW ARE. EVERYBODY
THINKS OF THAT SYMBOL MEANS
THAT IT MEANS IS THIS IS
RECYCLABLE SO A LOT OF A LOT OF
COMPANIES WHO ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO PUT RECYCLABLE ON THEIR ON
THEIR PRODUCTS STILL GO AHEAD
AND PUT THE RECYCLE RECYCLING
SYMBOL ON THEIR PRODUCTS. AND
THEN THEY SAY OH WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO CURSE PEOPLE TO
RECYCLE AS MUCH AS THEY CAN.
WELL THE TRUTH IS THAT IT'S
INCREDIBLY DECEPTIVE. AND IT IN
BYTHE WAY THE TRUTH IS THAT
LESS THAN 15% OF OUR SINGLE USE%
PLASTICS. ARE CURRENTLY BEING
RECYCLED- AND RECYCLING COSTS
NOW EXCEED THE SCRAP VALUE OF
THE PLASTIC MATERIAL ITSELF.
CONSUMERS AS I SAY ARE
DUTIFULLY FILLING THEIR BLUE
BINS. OUT WITH ITEMS THAT THEY
BELIEVE ARE RECYCLING NOW WE
STARTED TO CALL THIS PHENOMENON
WHICH CYCLING BECAUSE- IN
PEOPLE DAVEY WATER PRODUCTS TO
BE RECYCLED AND THEY THEY DON'T
WANT TO THINK THAT ALL THE
STUFF THAT THEY'RE BUYING IS
GOING TO TREAT TO THE LANDFILL.
NOT ONLY IS SO MUCH TO GOING TO
LANDFILL BUT ACTUALLY THE
PROCESS OF WISH CYCLING IS
ACTUALLY CREATING A LOT OF
CONTAMINATION- IN THE WASTE
STREAM BECAUSE THE MORE STUFF
GOING INTO THE RECYCLING BINS
THAT ARE NOT TRULY RECYCLABLE.
THE MORE IT HAS TO GET SORTED
OUT THE MORE OF IT ENDS UP
GETTING STUCK INTO BALES OF
RECYCLABLE MATERIAL. IT'S PART
OF WHY CHINA ACTUALLY PUT THE
KIBOSH ON ALL OUR MATERIALS
BEING SENT THERE BECAUSE WE
WERE SENDING BALES OF RECYCLED
FOR PURPORTEDLY RECYCLING
MATERIAL RECYCLABLE MATERIAL
THAT WERE CONTAMINATED BY.
OTHER MATERIALS AND SO THE IDEA
IS THAT IF YOU HAVE OF MATERIAL
IS NOT ACTUALLY RECYCLABLE THEN
HAS TO BE REMOVED FROM THE
CONVEYOR BELT AT THE RECYCLING
FACILITY HAS TO BE CARTED AWAY
TO A LANDFILL THERE'S A WHOLE
PROCESS IF MEMBERS IF YOU HAVE
NOT BEEN. TO A SORTING FACILITY
RECYCLING FACILITY OR DUMP- I
CAN'T- ENCOURAGE YOU MORE TO GO.
IT'S SUCH A IT'S AN EYE OPENING
EXPERIENCE- SO. IT THE IDEA IS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS
ISSUE RESOLVED THAT WE'RE GOING
TO FINALLY- YOU KNOW. EXTEND
THE- BASICALLY THE ANTI FRAUD
LANGUAGE THAT THAT EXISTS WITH
REGARD TO PUTTING RECYCLABLE ON
YOUR BOTTLE TO THE RECYCLING
SYMBOL THAT EVERYONE THINKS OF.
AS MEANING RECYCLABLE AND SO
WITH ME ADD TO THE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT TODAY WE'VE GOT
EMILY RICH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP
OF KALBURGI ALSO MARKET PRAYER
WITH REPUBLIC SERVICES HE WORKS
IN. THE WASTE MANAGEMENT SPACE.
BY THE SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED
MA'AM THOSE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS IS EMILY
RASH- I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALPERS THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP
FOR A STATE WIDE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION FOUNDED
BY THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUAL
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. NUMEROUS
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT MOST
CONSUMERS ASSUME THAT THAT
SHAPING EUROPE AND BALL
SIGNIFIES I DIDN'T ABLE TO BE
RECYCLED. MANY OF US MYSELF
INCLUDED TAKE THE TIME TO CHECK
EVERY CONTAINER YEARS AND IF I
SEE THAT YOUR AVAILABLE
SOMEWHERE ON THE COMPUTER I
RINSED OUT THOROUGHLY AND HEARD
IN THE PRESENT. I'M
UNFORTUNATELY AFTER ALLEN
STATED EFFORT AFTER SUPPORT
CORRECT ANY THAT LESS THAN 50%
OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC. IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY RECYCLED.
MANY MANUFACTURERS USE THE T.
CARE OF NUMBER ONE THAT PART
CONTAINERS ON THE BOTTOM OF THE
CAN. REGARDLESS WHETHER THE
TAPE OF CLASS TO GET. USED IS
TYPICALLY RECYCLE OR WHETHER
ADDITIONAL PACKAGING ON TOP OF
THE PLASTIC CONTAINER LIKE A
PLASTIC SLEEVE. MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE CONTAINER TO
BE RECYCLED. AFFECTIONS ALSO
PLACE ADDITIONAL SHIPPING AND
BOTH PROMINENTLY ON THE FRONT
OR BACK OF THEIR PACKAGING.
REGARDLESS OF THE ACTUAL
RECYCLABILITY OF THE PRODUCT.
WE HAVE A PLASTIC WITH CRISIS
ON OUR HANDS. AFTER SPEAKING
INTO EVERY CORNER OF THE PLANET
FROM THE DEPTHS OF LAKE TAHOE
TO THE BOTTOM OF THE MARIANA
TRENCH. PLASTIC WASTE IS ALSO
CREATING A FINANCIAL BURDEN
ULTIMATELY BORNE BY CONSUMERS
RATE PAYERS AND TAXPAYERS TO UP
TO PAY TO GET RID OF THAT. WE
NEED COMPANIES TO START USING
RECYCLED MATERIAL TO CREATE
THEIR PRODUCTS AND ENSURE THAT
THOSE PRODUCTS ARE MADE SO THAT
THEY CAN BE RECYCLED BACK INTO
NEW PRODUCTS AT THE END OF
THEIR LIFE. IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE MARKET PLACE TO REWARD
GOOD ACTORS AND AVOID BAD.
ACTORS CONSUMERS ARE DUPED. I
THINK THREE FORTY WILL HELP. BY
CLICKING WHICH ARE ABLE TO BE
RECYCLED. AND WHICH WILL ALMOST
CERTAINLY END UP IN A LANDFILL-
I THOUGHT. THANK YOU AND I
THINK OUR NEXT SPEAKER. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARKUP PREY ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES CENTER ALLEN
THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING THIS
MEASURE THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT MEASURE DESIGNED TO
INCREASE RECYCLING EFFICIENCY.
CALIFORNIA'S RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ONE OF THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
AND EFFICIENT RECYCLING SYSTEMS
IN THE WORLD BUT IN SPITE OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BEING
INVESTED INTO A SYSTEM AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO IMPROVE
RECYCLING CONTAMINATION REMAINS
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT AND
EXPENSIVE OBSTACLES.
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS HAVE
BEEN MADE IN EXTENSIVE MANUAL
SORT LINES OPTICAL SORTERS
SCREENS AND OTHER ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES BUT THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND EQUIPMENT ARE
FAR MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
CONSUMER EDUCATION EFFECTIVE
SOURCE REDUCTION. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND THEIR LOCAL
HAULERS SPEND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY EDUCATING. OUR
CUSTOMERS ON WHAT IS RECYCLED
IT IN EFFECT IN AN EFFORT TO
IMPROVE RECYCLING RATES AND
REDUCE CONTAMINATION. BUT THESE
DOLLARS ARE WASTED IF THE
PACKAGING OR MATERIALS INCLUDE
MARKINGS THAT FALSELY CLAIM
THESE PACKAGES OR MATERIALS ARE
RECYCLABLE FALSE CLAIMS OF
RECYCLABILITY CONFUSE CUSTOMERS
WHO ALREADY STRUGGLE TO
IDENTIFY CORRECTLY WHAT SHOULD
BE PLACED IN THE RECYCLING BIN.
SB FOUR THREE FOUR THREE IS
FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT TRUTH IN
ADVERTISING I DON'T CLAIM YOUR
PACKAGING OR MATERIAL IS
RECYCLABLE UNLESS OUR ACTUAL
RECYCLING MARKETS FOR THE
MATERIAL AND IT CAN BE READILY
AND EFFICIENTLY REMOVED FROM
THE WASTE STREAM. AS AN EXAMPLE
PLASTIC FILM BAGS WHILE
OFFERING CONSUMERS ARE
RELATIVELY CHEAP PACKAGING
OPTION WEIGH VERY LITTLE FOR
RECYCLING PURPOSES AND
CONSTITUTE LESS THAN 5% OF THE
TOTAL LAKE STREET. HIT THESE
BAGS CLOG RECYCLING AND
COMPOSTING MACHINERY CREATE
LITTER PROBLEMS AT FACILITIES
AND ARE EXPENSIVE TO REMOVE
FROM THE WASTE STREAM.
CONSUMERS SHOULD NOT BE LED TO
BELIEVE THAT THESE BAGS AND
OTHER MATERIALS LIKE IT ARE
TRULY RECYCLABLE UNLESS THE
MARKET EXISTS AND THESE CAN BE-
MATERIALS CAN BE EFFECTIVELY
REMOVED FROM THE WASTE STREAM.
SB SIX THREE FORTY THREE CENTS
AN EFFECTIVE AND CLEAR STANDARD
FOR RECYCLABILITY THAT WILL
INCREASE RECYCLING EFFICIENCIES
IMPROVE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IN
RECYCLING AND WILL REDUCE
RECYCLING COSTS FOR RATEPAYERS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND
RECYCLERS. THEREFORE WE
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST THE
COMMITTEES I VOTE. THANK YOU
ONE I'D LIKE TO KNOW BEFORE I
GO TO THE- BILL'S
TELECONFERENCING AND I'D LIKE
TO LOOK IN THE ROOMS AND I
DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE AND FORTY
TWO OR THREE. WISHES TO ADD TO
THEIR SUPPORT. OF LOOKING AT.
LOOKING AT THE SCREEN OVER
THERE TWENTY FORTY I WE DO NOT
I DO NOT SEE ANYONE AND THEY'RE
WISHING TO COME FORWARD TO
SUPPORT SO WE WILL GO. BY NOW
TO THOSE ARE ONLINE MATAMATA
MODERATOR WILL YOU PLEASE ARE.
LINED UP THE CUE FOR THOSE
WISHING TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR BUT IF YOU DON'T
MIND IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH MY NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q.ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY FORTY
THREE. PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
MADAM CHAIR LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT ELEVEN SHOWING UP AT THE
MOMENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I NUMBER EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TURN NUMBERS
NIKITA CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
CALLING IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SURE MEMBERS PROPOSED OFF ON
BEHALF OF NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL CO FOUNDER THAT
SB THREE FOR THREE AND FOUR AND
I'M ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS DIVISION.
WERE OFFSET IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AYE NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. PRIME NUMBER
SIXTY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER FEARING HEARING COULD
PORT SB THREE FORTY THREE FOR
THE OCEAN CONSERVANCY THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU THE MORNING CALL ME OUT OF
HERE COULD CALIFORNIA GOING TO
JUMP ABOARD. SLIDE NUMBER
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANKS GOOD MORNING
THIS IS BONNIE THEN ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE WE
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AT THE
THREE FORTY THREE TODAY AND
THINKCENTRE ALLEN FIRST YOU CAN
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JOHN MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF WASTE
MANAGEMENT IN SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TIM GUNN SURE ALL STAND
CRUZ COUNTY INTO. NUMBER TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS A
RESPOND DIRECT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER EIGHTY ONE GOOD LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
JANET ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WASTE INTO PART THANK
YOU. NUMBER THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION SUPPORT OF
THE THREE FOUR THREE YOU. MY
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS THAT NEED
MORE WHILE ON BEHALF OF ECOLOGY
AND MORE AT THE BILL. MY NUMBER
EIGHTY THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS- GENEVIEVE AVEDON
ON BEHALF OF HEAL THE BAY
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RECYCLING
ASSOCIATION PLASTIC POLLUTION
COALITION SAVE OUR SHORES
SEVENTH GENERATION ADVISORS THE
FIVE GYRES INSTITUTE AND
UPSTREAM IN SUPPORT OF THE
STOCK. AT THIS TIME AND I'M
SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO THE
OPPOSITION AND THOSE WHO WERE
ON THE LINE ON TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. LEADS SPEAKERS. THE
PEOPLE. KEVIN CRAWFORD IN
WARREN AGUILAR'S THE LINES ARE
OPEN. WARRANTY ONE OF OUR- YEAH
SURE- GOOD MORNING CHALLEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LORN AGAR AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING AMERICAN THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE FOR
PACKAGING AND THE ENVIRONMENT
WE ARE THE ONLY MATERIAL
NEUTRAL PACKAGING ASSOCIATION
AND THE UNITED STATES. WE HAVE
SEVERAL MEMBERS WITH THE
QUALITY OF THE CALIFORNIA AND
MANY MORE MANY MORE IMPORT
TACKING MATERIALS AND PRODUCTS
INTO THE STATE. I AM BUYING
TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
FORTY THREE THAT IS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED IT WOULD RESTRICT THE
USE OF THE CHASING ERA SYMBOL
BY ITSELF OR SURROUNDING A RED
MAGNIFICATION CODE. OR ANY
OTHER SYMBOL OR STATEMENT
INDICATING A PRODUCT IS
RECYCLABLE IF THE PRODUCT IS
NOT DEEMED TO BE RECYCLABLE BY
TWO HOURS AGO. SRI ARE MUCH
REPAIRABLE- AROUND READ MY
DEATH. CODE IS THAT MANY STATES
REQUIRE IT BY LAW. INDIVIDUAL
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA ARE
REMOVING THE MANDATE FOR
PACKAGING THE HABIT YOU THINK
ARROWS AND- THE RANK. BUT AMONG
A MAJORITY ARE STILL REQUIRING
THEM. ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF WHERE
PROHIBITION THAT YOU THINK.
WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC. FOR
COMPANIES THAT USE THE
NATIONAL- HOW TO RECYCLE LABEL
ON THEIR PACKAGING WHICH FOR
THE MOST PART HAS BEEN CHASING
A- PICTURE ON IT. THE GOAL OF
THE HOW TWO RECYCLE LABEL TO
REDUCE CONSUMER CONFUSION WITH
A CLEAR AND CONSISTENT
RECYCLING LABEL AND
CORRESPONDING INFORMATIONAL
WEBSITE. THIS IS SO CONSUMERS
CAN PROPERLY RECYCLE THE
PACKAGE WITH RB BY TELLING THEM
TO CHECK LOCALLY OR TO REMEMBER
SHRINK LABEL ON A BOTTLE OF
MAIL. BEFORE RECYCLING THE
BOTTLES. MANY AMERICANS ARE
WERE TO AND THE SIZE AND USE OF
THEIR PACKAGING. WE ALSO
BELIEVE CONSUMER SHOULD BEGIN
ACTOR IN. ABOUT THE RISKS. OF
THE PRODUCTS IN THE PACKAGES
THAT THEY ARE PURCHASING. WE
BELIEVE THAT ADOPTING NATIONAL
STANDARDS FOR LABELS AND
PACKAGING WILL BE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN MAKING SURE MORE
MATERIAL IS MORE CHILL GETTING
RECYCLED AND WILL STOP CONSUMER
CONFUSION. STE CONSUMERS SHOULD
BE ENCOURAGED TO RECYCLE
PACKAGING THAT IS RECYCLABLE
AND MANUFACTURE MANY FACTORS
MANUFACTURERS SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGED TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION. THAT WILL HELP
CONSUMERS DO SO. THREE THE
COMIC THAT WE HAD WITH THE
CHAIRED OFFICE AND WE BELIEVE
THAT BY WORKING TOGETHER WE CAN
CREATE A SOLUTION WITH ALL
CONTAMINATION IN THE CURBSIDE
BINS. AND HELP MORE MATERIAL
GET. IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED CONVERSATION AROUND
THE SOLDIER ON. THANK YOU. IS
MS CRAWFORD AVAILABLE ONLINE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SHANNON CROCKER AND I'M
WITH THE INDUSTRY EDUCATION
REPRESENTS THE ENTIRE SUPPLY
CHAIN MANUFACTURING IN THE
UNITED STATES WHICH INCLUDES
OVER SIXTY ONE THOUSAND WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA I'M JUST TRYING
TO EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS SB
THREE TWENTY THREE BECAUSE
ASPIRIN OR WITHOUT MUCH
RECYCLING. PLANT FONG. IN
ABILITY THE PRIMARY FOCUS OF
OUR MEMBERS ARE. BOB CERTAINLY
SUPPORT EFFORTS DURING
CONTAMINATION IN THE RECYCLING
BIN WHEN FORTUNATELY CANNOT
SUPPORT SB THREE FORTY THREE IS
THAT. PEOPLE WANT TO RECYCLE
THAT MUCH RICHER THE MAKING IT
HARDER WITH THAT. CHIEF THE
CRITERIA OUTLINED IN SB THREE
FORTY THREE TO DETERMINE
RECYCLABILITY. YEAH THE
STATEWIDE COMMISSION RECYCLING
MARKET. THE TERM ONLY P.
EIGHTEEN H. T. BOTTLE COULD BE
AS Y. PROTECT THE STATE. NOT
ONLY WOULD HIGHLY RECOMMEND THE
YOU'RE A LABEL NOT ACCEPTABLE
BUT THERE ARE NO SUCH. FOR
CAPABILITY PROVIDE BY THE
RECYCLABLE. ALTERED OFF MORE
MODERATE. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WON'T SHORTAGE AND MARK
EMISSIONS. UNDER THE INTEREST.
BUT DOUBLE. IMPOSING SEVERELY
FOR LABELING ON TAKE OWNERSHIP
FOR TOGETHER TO ADVANCE MY
MODERATE IMPACT CAPTURE RECYCLE
MATURE. THE SYSTEM CAN ONLY BE
BY A SECOND AN MARKET
TRANSPORTATION MATERIAL. I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT YOUR PROJECT
BACK IN THE G. THE WORLD GOLD
FELL ARE NEW AND UP. ON PROGRAM
CURRENTLY ADVANCE SEVERAL
PROJECTS USING RECYCLED HE
FOUND A POLYMER ADDITIVES AND
BOB. OBJECTS MODEL. IS FOUR
THOUSAND POUNDS RECYCLED
PHAETHON ANOTHER PROJECT IN THE
WORKS RIGHT CALIFORNIANS.
ACCORDING TO THAT NOTHING FIFTY
THOUSAND HUNGRY OF WITH ON THE
COULD BE REQUIRED AN ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT THE POINT SHORTAGE OF
THE CHARACTER CREATION FOR
MARKET BY. ALL MORE MATURE
ARAMBULA HOWEVER WE CAN LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING THE SENATE
AROUND STAFFING SOLUTIONS MAKE
THE BILL WORKABLE HELP IMPROVE
OUT AND HIT IT ASIDE FROM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU HI NOW WE WILL LOOK TO ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION NOR DO I SEE ANYONE
IN TWENTY FORTY. WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SO WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES AND
MADAME MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND OTTOMAN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE FORTY THREE. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR ONLINE
NUMBER EMPLATE YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FORTY
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT MADAM
CHAIR THE THINK WE HAVE TO
PEOPLE TO NOT AT THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU. MY MOM WENT OVER THE
LINE NUMBERS MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU LINE NUMBER. BY NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
THE COOKING OUT ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
THE PET FOOD INSTITUTE WE ARE
ALSO OPPOSED TO BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
EIGHTY FOUR IN LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE PAST
MATTER BY SHARING SENATORS
ANTHONY MOLINA ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER BRANDS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AT
THIS TIME TO SB THREE FORTY
THREE THANK YOU. YEAH AT THIS
TIME MANAGER WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE FORTY THREE. THANK YOU
MADAM ODERATOR WE WILL NOW
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY- COMMENTS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO MAKE OR
ANY QUESTIONS. SENATOR DONNELLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR RIGHT
HERE OKAY SO I JUST HAVE A
QUICK COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR- I HEARD IN THE
TESTIMONY. MR A PRAYER THAT.
INDICATED ABOUT MARKET DEMAND
SO. I UNDERSTAND FIRST OF ALL I
GO BACK A LONG WAYS. IN THE
RECYCLING WORLD IN PLASTICS
SENATOR GORDON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GORDON I WORKED ON A- LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT ISSUES BUT- BUT
WHAT WAS NEEDLES YET WAS
RELEASED THE- ANYWAY THERE IT
IS COMPLEX IT IS FRUSTRATING
AND SO I WANT TO APPLAUD YOU
FOR THAT BUT I SO THERE'S A 75%
RECYCLE. RIGHT NOW MANDATE THAT
WE HAVE ON. PLASTICS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
CONTAMINATION AND THAT CAUSES
US NOT TO BE ABLE TO. THE I
GUESS MARKET THE PRODUCT AND SO
WHAT HAPPENS IF. WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE POWER TO CARRY CYCLE TO
EVALUATE SYMBOLS. I'M A LITTLE
NERVOUS ABOUT GIVING THEM THE
POWER NUMBER ONE I DON'T MIND
US PICKING AND CHOOSING WHICH
ONES WE THINK WITH GOOD
TESTIMONY AND- AND UNDERSTAND
THE MARKETABILITY AND ALL THOSE
THINGS BUT TO JUST GIVE THEM
THE POWER IF THEY DON'T MEET TO
SEVENTY SO LET'S JUST TAKE FOR
EXAMPLE. THEY BANNED SOME OF
THESE PRODUCTS THAT AREN'T. I
GUESS. LEGIT I GUESS SOME
PEOPLE FRAUD IN THE SYSTEM BUT
I HEAR YOU SAYING IS THAT AND
I'M NOT I'M NOT AWARE THAT
THAT'S WHAT I USED TO MEET WITH
THE WIND BAND THE PRODUCTS-
THEY WOULD JUST SAY THAT YOU
CAN'T CLAIM THAT IT. YOUR ITEMS
RECYCLABLE WHEN IT'S NOT.
RECYCLABLE IN THE END OF THE
DAY WHEN IT'S NOT BEING
RECYCLED. OKAY SO THAT'S THE-
THAT'S THE KEY WORD YOU JUST
SAID THEY'RE NOT BEING IS IT
RECYCLABLE OR IS IT NOT
RECYCLABLE. THIS IS THE TIRES
OR RECYCLE BUT YOU CAN'T GET
RID OF THEM AND NOW SO THIS IS
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT.
ABSOLUTELY SENATORS. THIS IS
THIS IS THIS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS IN IN IN OUR
SYSTEM. AND THAT IS THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF PRODUCTS THAT ARE
TECHNICALLY RECYCLABLE UNDER
PERFECT CONDITIONS YOU CAN. PUT
IT IN A LAB ENVIRONMENT BUT A
THOUSAND DEGREES AND THAT
INCREDIBLE EXPENSE. TURN IT
INTO SOMETHING NEW. AND THAT IS
TECHNICALLY RECYCLABLE. BUT IN
IN IN THE REAL WORLD IN REAL
DAY LIFE EVERYDAY LIFE THESE
ITEMS ARE GARCIA. THERE'S JUST
SIMPLY NO MARKET THERE WHETHER
BE WHETHER BE FOR WHAT THE BE
THE SORTING PROCESS OR WITH THE
BE THE MARKET. WHETHER BE THE
AS THE COST OF THAT BUT THE
ENERGY EXPENDITURE ASSOCIATED
WITH WITH TURN THESE THINGS
INTO SOMETHING NEW. FOR
WHATEVER REASON THESE ITEMS
DON'T END UP GETTING RECYCLED
IN THE DAY NOW. THIS IS A WORK
TO GET SOME TRUTH IN
ADVERTISING TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC WHO DOESN'T REALIZE THAT
THESE TEMS ARE NOT GETTING
RECYCLED. HAS A BETTER SENSE
NOW HERE'S THE THING. IF WE CAN
CREATE AN INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THESE ITEMS TO BE RECYCLED
THIS. THIS BILL ACTUALLY
PROVIDES A PATH. FOR THOSE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE THAT ARE NOT
BEING RECYCLED NOW. TO GET. YOU
KNOW TO GET INTO THE RECYCLABLE
CATEGORY- AND THEN I CAN TALK
ABOUT IF YOU LIKE. BUT I
BELIEVE THE WHAT WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO DO IS TO CONTINUE TO.
IN A PUT THESE CHASING ARROW
SYMBOLS ON TO THEIR PRODUCTS
WHEN IN ACTUALITY THESE ITEMS
ARE NOT BEING RECYCLED. SO BUT
WE BUT IN TERMS OF
INCENTIVIZING I'M I'M I'M HAPPY
TO YOU KNOW TO CHAT WITH YOU
ABOUT THIS BUT- YOU KNOW LIKE
ALL ALL TAKE A- THERE'S AN ON
RAMP THAT WE HAVE IN THE BILL
THAT WOULD ALLOW MANUFACTURERS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENCOURAGE
CONSUMERS TO RECYCLE THE
PRODUCT WHILE THEY MAKE. THE
NECESSARY INVESTMENTS TO
COLLECT IN STORE AND THEN WE
PROCESS IT AND THEN THEY CAN IF
THEY'RE ABLE TO CREATE A
MECHANISM WHERE THEIR ITEMS
ACTUALLY STARTING TO GET
RECYCLED AND THEY CAN. THEN
THEY CAN PUT THE CHASING
ARSENAL'S BACK ON. SO THE- I
THINK THEY HAVE THAT
CLARIFICATION I THINK THAT
NEEDS TO BE REALLY DELIGHTED
OUT THAT THIS BILL S NOT ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE RECYCLED
THIS BILL IS ABOUT IT'S JUST
NOT GETTING RECYCLED BECAUSE
THERE'S NO MARKET FOR THAT'S
REALLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
THERE'S NO ARE THERE OR THE
COST IS TOO HIGH SO. WHEN I
WHEN I LOT OF FACTORS YEAH
THERE IS REALLY SO IT'S WHEN
YOU SAY IT'S CONTAMINATING THE
BAIL. SO THIS I DON'T I DON'T
HAVE A PRODUCT. AND I DID I
COULD. FEEL MY NEWSPAPER BACK
LIKE A FILM THAT I THAT'S OF
BROKEN DAMAGED. IT IS
RECYCLABLE TECHNICALLY BUT THE
WAYS PEOPLE HATE IT BECAUSE IT
BASICALLY JUST MESSES UP THE
BALES IT'S NEVER ALTERNATELY
RECYCLED GETS RIPPED UP. SO
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE FOR EXAMPLE.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO RE
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ON THAT
PIECE IS THAT THAT SAYING IT'S
JUST DOESN'T MEET THE STANDARD.
OFOR ITS RECYCLE BUT WE JUST
CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT IT IS TOO
COSTLY OR WHATEVER SO YOU'RE
YOU'RE GONNA YOU'RE GONNA
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN THIS IS.
I'M TRYING TO. I JUST WEST OF
THE BETTER SOLUTIONS WHAT I'M
TRYING TO SAY IN THIS YEAH I
KNOW I KNOW THIS IS THIS IS
GOING TO PUT IT OFF ON THE-
IT'S GOING TO PUT IT OFF ON THE
MANUFACTURE. IS GONNA GET POWER
MORE POWER TO CAL RECYCLE WHICH-
AT. THAT'S THE LAST THING I
WANT. I MEAN. THE BETTER
SOLUTION IS SB FIFTY FOUR RIGHT
I MEAN ARE YOU OF THE FACT THAT
WE WOULD HAVE A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH. TO
THIS. WHERE WHERE WHERE THAT WE
WOULD BASICALLY BE ASKING THE
PRODUCERS IN GENERAL TO START.
MOVING TOWARD MORE SUSTAINABLE
PACKAGING. RIGHT WE WENT TO I
WAS ON THE COMMITTEE WHAT'S
REAL BILL IDEA TO HOLD BACK A
MONTH HERE AND THERE'S THIS ONE
REACHES ONE DOESN'T IN THE-
COMING BACK WE'RE COMING BACK
WITH A BILL. PLUS IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN SECOND SYMBOL. THAT
YOU'RE SAYING. SO WHAT I'M SO
WHAT'S GOING TO. IF YOU TAKE.
JUST TAKE FOR EXAMPLE WE TAKE
DECEMBER OFF. THE CARRY CYCLE
TAKES IS OFF OF THESE PRODUCTS
THAT. DON'T MEET SOME CERTAIN
CRITERIA BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST
NOT GETTING RECYCLED. THOSE ARE
GOING TO GOING TO A LANDFILL
NOW. WHICH IS WHERE THE GOING
OUT ANYWAY BY THE WAY. RIGHT SO
WE HAVE A. 75% REDUCTION. IS
CALDERON CARISSA ACKLES GOAL
475% SO IF THAT GOES UP WHAT
HAPPENS IN. WHATEVER WE CAN'T
MEET THAT BECAUSE WE'RE DUMPING
ALL THESE RECYCLABLES AND YOU
ARE MAKING THE CASE FOR SB
FIFTY FOUR AND I HOPE TO
CONVINCE YOU TO BE A CO AUTHOR.
WELL IT I FIND IT HARD TO IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT TO VOTE FOR
SOMETHING THAT IS- FOR GIVING
MORE POWER TO THE COUNTY
CYCLING ALSO IT'S CONFUSING
THAT THIS COULD CONFUSE FIVE
AND THESE BRING THESE BRANDS
ARE NATIONAL BRANDS THEY'RE
THEY'RE WHAT ARE OTHER STATES.
I MEAN I KNOW WE'RE PROBABLY
WAY FURTHER AHEAD IN MANDATING
THAT OTHER STATES ARE THERE
OTHER STATES THAT ARE DOING THE
SAME THING SO ACTUALLY
WASHINGTON AND OREGON- ALL
THREE STATES HAVE HAVE
ANNOUNCED SIMILAR LEGISLATION.
SO THE IDEA IS THAT- THAT- THAT
THAT DID YOU KNOW WHAT BUT
HOPEFULLY HUMAN AND THEN THEY
LOOK TO HAVE A DECENT CHANCE OF
PASSAGE THAT WILL THIS IS GOING
TO HELP THE PUSH JUST LIKE WITH
THE NC DOUBLE A MEMBER. MEMBER
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN THE NC
DOUBLE A SAID THERE'S NO WAY AN
ANTI SKINNER HAD A BILL ON ON
THE ATHLETES RIGHT A
COMPENSATING THEM AND THEY SAID
THAT THE CALIFORNIA CAN'T GO
OUT ON ITS OWN. THIS IS THIS IS
OUTRAGEOUS WE'RE GONNA CUT THE
PAC TEN OUT OF THE NC DOUBLE A
WELL SHE SAID THIS IS UNFAIR
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THIS ANYWAY AND IN FACT DAN THE
NC DOUBLE A ENDED UP ADOPTING
WITHIN ABOUT A. YEAR THE
ADOPTED CALIFORNIA STANDARDS.
SO- IT'S TRUE THE COUNTRY. HAS
NOT. MOVED ENOUGH ON THIS ISSUE
BUT I THINK PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AND- I WAS ON A
CONFERENCE CALL OF LEGISLATION
OF THE COUNTRY THEY KNOW THIS
IS A PROBLEM EVERYWHERE. AND SO
YOU SEE MORE MORE STATES TRY TO
STICK TO STAND I THINK THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US IN
CONJUNCTION WITH. OREGON
WASHINGTON TO JUST RESET THE
CONVERSATION NATIONALLY BECAUSE
WE'RE BASICALLY LYING TO
OURSELVES RIGHT NOW. YOUR I
MEAN I CENTER FRUSTRATION IS A
REAL FRUSTRATION. BUT THE TRUTH
IS THAT THE STUFF NOT BEING
RECYCLED. AND ALL IT'S DOING IS
COMING UP THE SYSTEM. YOU KNOW
THAT AT THE VERY LEAST UNTIL WE
CREATE A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO THIS PROBLEM. ARE
WE WE'RE WE'RE LYING TO
OURSELVES IF WE IF WE CONTINUE
TO. CLAIM THAT THESE ITEMS ARE
BEING RECYCLED WHEN THEY'RE NOT.
I'M IT. FIRST OF ALL I'M A LAY
OFF YOUR BILL I WANT I WANT TO
GET TERE. BECAUSE I GET WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO BUT I JUST
DON'T KNOW IF THE PATHWAYS AND-
BUT I WANTED TO MAKE A
STATEMENT SO. I WAS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WHEN THEY- DID
FIFTY PERCENT. OUT OF LANDFILLS
WE ACTUALLY HAD LENTILS BEFORE.
THIS IS IN THE NINETIES. WHEN
WE STARTED. IN YOU KNOW THERE'S
A DON JUAN IS TALK ABOUT TIRES
FOR ME BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY
FRUSTRATING TO ME AND- SOMEBODY
WHO. OWNS TRUCKS AND USES.
TIRES A LOT OF THEM. I PAY THE
FEE. AND IT'S SUPPOSED TO GET
IT GO BACK AND TAKE IT BACK TO
THE- DEALER THAT I BOUGHT TE
TIRE FROM WHEN I GET MY FOUR
BUCKS OR I GET IT WHATEVER. IT
GETS RECYCLED. BUT I ALSO HAVE
A CONCRETE COMPANY IN MY
DISTRICT THAT CAN USE THOSE
TIRES THEY ACTUALLY CAN TURN UP
TO IT WHATEVER DEGREES I GOTTA
BURN AND MAKE CONCRETE
SOMETHING WE NEED IN CALIFORNIA.
SO BUT THAT BUT THEIR BOARD IS
IN CONFLICT WITH MY- CONCRETE
SUPPLIER AND PUTTING
REGULATIONS ON THEM BECAUSE OF
THE AIR QUALITY STANDARDS THERE
SO HE DOESN'T REALLY GET WRIST
YOU DON'T EAT IT WE SHIP THEM-TO CHINA. AND THEY BURN THE
HECK OUT OF I'M NOT EVEN IN A
CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT LIKE WE
UP. AND IT WAS ABOUT
FRUSTRATING IS LIKE WHAT WOULD
AND WE FEEL GOOD WE FEEL ALL
GOOD BECAUSE WE CHARGE THE-
MONEY TO THE- BUSINESS. OF
TIRED THE TIRE GOT. RECYCLE BUT
I GOT SENT TO CHINA. IN A BOOK
GOT PUT A BOILER ISSUE CANNOT
SMOKE THAT I'M READING. WHAT WE
DO WE REALLY SAW THE AIR
QUALITY PROBLEM TO BE SOLVED WE
SAID NO WE DIDN'T WE SHOULD
LOOK INCENTIVES TO USE THOSE
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE'RE LEADING THE WAY. THE
NATION IN. THE STRATEGY BUT IT
DIDN'T DAVEY IF WE CAN'T GO
FULL CYCLE. AND MAKE IT HAPPEN
HERE NO JUST SHOVING IT OFF TO
SOME OTHER STATE OR SOME OTHER
COUNTRY WHERE THEY'RE- NOT
MEETING THE STANDARD WHAT GOOD
ARE WE DOING TO SAME THING
YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT. JUST
THROWN IN THE LANDFILL AND
FEELING GOOD ABOUT IT YEAH SO
THE ONLY OFF YOUR BILL I. BUT
I'LL BE BACK THERE ON FIFTY
FOUR LOOK AT THAT ONE TOO BUT
DO THEY KNOW AT SOME POINT YOU
HAVE TO. BE HONEST WITH THE
PEOPLE. YEP THAT WE'RE NOT
REALLY DOING WHAT YOU SAY
YOU'RE DOING IT BUT WE'RE
CHARGING YOU. YEAH AND WE'RE
ALSO. NOT ALLOW YOU TO RECYCLE
SO. IT DOESN'T IT ALL. TWO
COMES OUT IS HEY YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING WAY. WE DO
ALL THESE THINGS FEEL. BUT
REALLY. IF YOU. DOWN DEEP GET
AND WE- IT DOESN'T DO WHAT WE-
WE'RE DOING. I THINK
DEMóCRATAS. GUYS DO MAKE. A
CASE FIFTY. YOU'RE MAKING THE
CASE FOR HER TO- BUT- BUT DID
NOT. FALLING UP IN WITH. PANEL
WHO GETS PENALIZED IT COULD. IT
MANY EITHER PAYS MORE AT THE
END THEY GO PAY MORE IT SOME
GOT TO DO SO TO CHANGE THE
ORDER SUCKED COUNTY DISTRICT
RATES TEND A MONTH- I DON'T I'M
LIVING HERE TRUST ME YEAH MY
WELL BILL WILL UP TO THE SO.
WHO IS THE WHO DID THEY AND DO.
WE ENDS UP. IS THE CONSUMER.
YEAH YOU CAN AFFORD TO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE OF ALL
THESE THERE'S THIS IS JUST ONE
OF THOUSANDS OF PROGRAMS INCOME
IF YOU WANT TO GET FIRED UP
ABOUT THE AIRPORT I WILL. BUT
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT RIGHT NOW.
MY POINT IS THAT THE CONSUMER
PAYS. EVERYBODY FEELS GOOD
ABOUT IT AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT DIDN'T DO ANYTHING BUT
JUST RUN THE RATE UP SO. ALL
THE SOLVE THE PROBLEM LET'S
FIGURE OUT HOW WAYS WE CAN KEEP
THESE. PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND MAKE THE MAKE THE FOR LOOP.
HERE'S THE THING A SENATOR. ON
THERE ARE SOME ITEMS THAT ARE
VERY FOR RECYCLABLE SOME
PLASTIC ITEMS THE ONES AND THE
TWOS RATES THE P. T. AND THEN
YOU HAVE THE THREE TWO SEVENS
WHICH ARE NOT. RIGHT THE LADIES
AREN'T THERE THAT YOU KNOW FOR
ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES
THEY'RE NOT RECYCLABLE
TECHNICALLY THEY ARE BUT BY THE
SYSTEM IT'S SO DIFFICULT TO
MAKE A PENCIL OUT. THE TRUTH
THE MATTER IS. YOU KNOW WHAT
THE PLASTIC MANUFACTURES THE
ONE TO HOLD THE CONTROLS HERE
THEY CAN AB CAN DECIDE WHETHER
THEY'RE GOING TO MARKET THAT
THE CAT FOOD. YOU KNOW BOTTLE
IN A IN A IN A IN A IN A NUMBER
THREE OR NUMBER TWO. AND IF
THEY GIVE ME PUT IN THE ONE OR
TWO IT'S MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
RECYCLE THAN THE NUMBER THREE
AND YET RIGHT NOW. THEY HAVE NO
SKIN IN THE GAME. THEY TO PUT
WHATEVER PRODUCT THEY WANT AND
THERE'S REALLY NO
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND AS YOU SAY
IT'S ULTIMATELY TO CONSUMERS
WHO ARE PAYING THE PRICE
BECAUSE THEY EXISTED ON PUTTING
OUT THE NON RECYCLABLE STUFF
WHEN THEY ACTUALLY COULD PUT
OUT THE RECYCLABLE STUFF. AND
AS A RESULT OUR WHOLE SYSTEM IS
BREAKING DOWN BECAUSE WE HAVE
SO MUCH OF THE NON RECYCLABLE
STUFF GOING TO THE STREAM AS
OPPOSED TO THE RECYCLABLE STUFF
APART- WE WANT TO DO HERE. IS
PUSHED AGAINST THE PUSH THE
PRODUCERS. TOWARD THE MORE
RECYCLABLE STUFF. THAT'S ALL.
THE GOAL HERE. AND IF WE DO
THAT THAT WILL ACTUALLY HELP
THE CONSUMERS ON THE- IN IN A
VERY TANGIBLE WAY. THIS CAN
HELP THE WHOLE SYSTEM WORK
BETTER. IT'S GOING TO MAKE IT
MUCH LESS LIKELY. THAT DID YOU
KNOW THE HOLLER CAN CONTINUE TO
ASK FOR RATE INCREASES IN THE
COUNTIES ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO PASS THESE RATE INCREASES ON
PEOPLE. TO BASICALLY BANDAID
OVER THIS BROKEN SYSTEM THAT IS
CURRENTLY. YOU THE CONSUMERS
ARE PAYING THE COST FOR
DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE BY THE
PRODUCERS ULTIMATELY SO WE NEED
TO START HOLDING THOSE
PRODUCERS ACCOUNTABLE TO
PROTECTIVE AND PUSH THEM IN IN
A MORE IN A IN A IN A MORE
COHERENT SUSTAINABLE DIRECTION
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE GOAL HERE
AT WITH THIS BILL IT'S A GOAL
WITH FIFTY FOUR IT'S ALSO A
GOAL OF LEARNING IT'S ALWAYS A
BILLS DOING DRESSING YOU SHOULD
YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT WHICH IS
THE BASIC SO YOU CAN'T TAKE
CREDIT FOR DIVERSION WHEN
YOU'RE SENDING STUFF OUT OF
STATE AND IT'S GETTING BURNED.
THE IT'S ALL ABOUT. CREATING
MORE ACCOUNTABILITY MORE TRUTH.
AND PROVIDING OUR CONSUMERS
WITH WITH. WITH WITH WITH WITH
THE WITH THE TRUTH AS TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING. BECAUSE RIGHTNOW
THEY JUST THINK THEY THROW
THEIR STUFF IN A BLUE BIN AND
EVERYTHING GOES OFTEN. IS TAKEN
CARE OF AND OF COURSE IT'S NOT.
AND THEY'RE AND THEY'RE PAYING
THE PRICE NOW BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASING DYSFUNCTION OF OUR
SYSTEM. I WANTED PER SE. I LOVE
THIS COMMUNITY THIS IS MY
FAVORITE COMMITTEE. BECAUSE I
LOVE THE PEOPLE ON THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE YOU GUYS ARE
ALL ALL OF YOU ARE THOUGHTFUL
AND- AND IT ALLOWS US TO GET IN
THE WEEDS APPRECIATE THAT. BUT
WE TALK ABOUT TRUTH THE REAL
TRUTH IS THAT. THAT HAS TO BE
TO THE DOESN'T GET TOLD. IS
THAT. YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA WE DO EVERYTHING
THAT A- THAT WE LEAD THE WORLD
IN EVERYTHING AND WE ALSO LEAD
THE WORLD IN POVERTY WE THE
LITTLE WORLD AND- HIGHEST
TAXES. HIGHEST ENERGY COST.
BACK OUR HOUSES ARE BUILT DON'T
DON'T KNOW I MEAN NOW THEIR
STANDARDS ARE ARE OUTSTANDING
WELL WHAT. THERE'S NO PLACE
THAT WE DO DO IT ANY BETTER BUT
THE COST. AT SOME POINT WE HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE KEEP
PEOPLE HERE. EXPORTING
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE ALL THESE
THINGS ADD LAYERS. TO THE COSTS
AND THAT'S JUST WHAT YOU JUST
READ WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT. YOU
KNOW MY BILL WENT UP TEN BUCKS
AN AYE AND TRUST ME- I RECYCLED
I GOT THE BLUE BINS MY DAUGHTER
NINE FIGURE TRYING TO DO YOU
KNOW THIS THE FIRST. BE LIVING
SECOND ACTUALLY OF THE HOME.
WE'RE RENTING A HOME WHERE WE
ACTUALLY DO IT WE HAVE TO GO TO
OUR LANDFILL. IT IN LASSEN
COUNTY TO THE TRANSFER STATION.
AND PUT IT IN THE EACH BEEN
THERE. SO WE RECYCLE AT HOME IT
DOESN'T GET SO IT'S GOES TUMOR
FORGET STAND HAND RECYCLED. ARE
YOU FOLLOWING ME. BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE CURBSIDE WHEN YOUR-
HOUSES ARE. TWENTY MILES APART.
OKAY SO. I GUESS MY POINT IS
THAT THE- I'M ONLY OFF YOUR
BILL APPRECIATE THE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE APPRECIATE THE
PEOPLE ON THE COMMITTEE AND I
WANT THE STORY TO BE TOLD THAT
YOU KNOW. THAT'S SOMETHING WE
HAVE TO FACTOR IN. THIS
CALIFORNIA CAN HAVE ANY PEOPLE
LEFT OR JUST HAVING A EAK
BUNCH OF PEOPLE. AND WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO HAVE THESE
LOWER AND WE TALK ABOUT.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THIS THIS ALL IMPACTS OF THE-
SINGLE MOM WHO'S GOING TO THE
STORE AND TRYING TO BUY.
DISINFECTANT WIPES RIGHT NOW TO
KEEP THEIR FAMILY SAFE. ALL SAY
IS THAT THERE ARE SOME BILLS WE
PASS HERE THAT THEY DO RAISE
COSTS ON PEOPLE THIS ULTIMATELY
IS ABOUT TRYING TO LOWER COSTS
AND PEOPLE RIGHTS ALTERNATELY
ABOUT RECOGNIZING THE COST
DRIVERS THAT ARE DRIVING OUR
OUR WASTE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
DOWN. AND TRYING TO COME UP
WITH SOME SOME SOLUTIONS THAT
WILL MAKE THE SYSTEM MORE
COHERENT AND ULTIMATELY LESS
EXPENSIVE FOR REGULAR FOLKS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. I JUST.
VENTURA COUNTY DID YOU HAVE
SOMETHING NO NO AFTER THAT. I
THINK I THINK THEY COVERED ALL
EXCEPT I DO ARE JUST THAT IT
OPPOSE SCRIPTED FIGHT NIGHT
LIVE OF ALL ABOUT THE CONSUMER
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THE
CONSUMERS LOOK AT THE PACKAGE
AND LOOK FOR THE FINE RIGHT NOW
THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY CAN
RECYCLE BECAUSE IT'S BEEN FULL
STANDARDIZED EDUCATION SENSE
WHAT WAS THAT. AB EIGHTY NINE
OR SB EIGHTY NINE MANY MANY
YEARS AGO SO CONSUMER EDUCATION
IS PROBABLY FUNDAMENTAL BEFORE
ANY OF THESE WORKING YOU DON'T
HAVE A COMPONENT IN HERE FOR
THAT I THINK YOU KNOW IF YOU
ADVERTISE IN THE LA TIMES MAYES
THE MAJOR NEWSPAPERS FOR ABOUT
A MONTH FULL PAGE THIS IS NO
LONGER RECYCLABLE THEY FINALLY
GET IT BUT THEY DON'T NOW.
BECAUSE I NEVER LOOK I'M STILL
OPERATING ON WHAT MIGHT LOCAL
WE NOW HAVE THE I. ORGANIC
WASTES LITTLE LITTLE BANDS IT
WAS DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND
INITIALLY WHAT TO DO WITH THOSE
BECAUSE THE EDUCATION ARM WAS A
LITTLE LACKING SO I THINK OUR
OUR WAY FATHERS WHO HAVE BEEN
VERY INVOLVED IN GREAT PARTNERS
UP WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WANT
TO DO IT RIGHT IN THE WATER YOU
KNOW OFF CONSUMERS YOU KNOW
NEIGHBORHOOD FOLKS WITH A BLUE
AND BLACK AND GREEN DOWN TO DO
IT RIGHT BUT THAT'S QUITE
LACKING HIS SOUL LOOKING FOR A
SIGN THAT'S GOT THAT LITTLE
THING ON IT I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE DO THAT EVEN IF IT'S- AN
ON AND CATCHING THE PEOPLE WHO
WILL NOT A DAY. THIS NEW LAW IS
GOING TO BE A HUGE ENFORCEMENT
MORE EMPLOYEES MARKOFF SO I
JUST THINK TAKING A LOOK AT AN
EDUCATION COMPONENT TO ALL THIS
IS REALLY VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT WITHOUT I'M JUST GOING TO
LAUGH BECAUSE I DO AGREE DOWN I
THINK WE NEED TO WE NEED TO GET
THERE ABSOLUTELY BACK. ON THIS
IS A STEP IN A KIND OF THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT IT LACKS
WITHIN PEOPLE KNOW YOU JUST
LEADING INDUSTRY NO AND THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME AND
PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BETTER OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND I'VE LEARNED JUST
BEING HERE. OF IN FIVE STARTED
CHANGING MY AT HOME MYSELF
TAKING A CLOSER LOOK AT WHAT
I'M THROWING IN YOU KNOW THE
GREEN BAN IN THE BLUE. BAND
FELT I'M JUST. DECEMBER
POSTSCRIPT BET. WITH THE FOR MY
CLOTHES I GUESS I WOULD SAY IS-
THIS IS SO TO MEET HIM YOU KNOW.
ONE COULD ARGUE THAT FIFTY IS
MORE OF A- LEADING INDUSTRY NOW.
THIS IS TRUE ABOUT EDUCATIN
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THIS IS
ABOUT WHAT THE PRODUCERS PUT ON
THEIR PRODUCTS TO BE SENT OUT
TO THE TO THE CONSUMERS. THE
CONSUMER BRANDS WITH A FOCUS IN
EVERY ONE OF US IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY PLAYERS IN THE SPACE
DID A POLL AND SO IN NEARLY
THREE QUARTERS OF ALL CONSUMERS.
THANK YOU THAT RECYCLING SYMBOL
MEANS THAT THE ITEMS FULLY
RECYCLABLE AND IT MEANS IT
SHOULD BE PUT IN THE IN THE
BLUE BIN. FIVE SO THAT YOU TOO
SO LEAVE THE DATA WE HAVE
LISTED THE SURVEY DATA WE HAVE
SUGGESTS THAT THAT THE USE OF
THAT SYMBOL IS A POWERFUL
SYMBOL AND IT REALLY DOES
DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEONE
DECIDES TO PUT IN THE BLUE BIN
OR NOT AND SO- TO THIS DISPUTE
WITH IT IF YOU IF ANYTHING IF
YOU IS ONE THING TO TAKE OUT
ADS IN THE L. A. TIMES BUT YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES YOU THINK AND
ALWAYS THIS ITEM RECYCLABLES
AND NOT IF YOU GOT IT THERE ON
ON THE ITEM RIGHT THERE SMACK
DAB ON THE ITEMS THAT'S GOING
TO BE WHAT WILL ULTIMATELY
OVERRIDES- IN THE CONSUMER'S
MINE IN THERE. IT'S GOING TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THROWN IN OR
NOT AND SO THIS IS ULTIMATELY
ABOUT. SIGNALING THE CONSUMERS.
AT THE- RATE. BILL OF AN ITEM.
AT AND JUST TRUTH IN
ADVERTISING- ITSELF. ANYWAY WE
HAD A VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION
HAPPY TO TALK TO EVERYBODY IN
AND I DO WANT TO THANK THE
OPPOSITION SPEAKERS THE EFFORT
FOR TALK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
WORKING TOGETHER. LET'S TRY TO
FIGURE OUT A MUTUALLY AGREEABLE
WAY OF LETTING THIS PLANE I
MEAN ULTIMATELY YEAH THIS IS
NOT DOING AWAY WITH PLASTIC-
PRODUCTS ARE PACKAGING IT'S
ABOUT TRYING TO BE TRUTHFUL TO
CONSUMERS AS TO THE TYPES OF
PLASTICS THAT ARE TRULY
RECYCLABLE NOT THOSE THAT ARE
JUST NOT. UNDER OUR SYSTEM AND
WE DO NEED MORE COMPREHENSIVE
REFORM THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT AND THAT'S WHAT
ULTIMATELY SB FIFTY FOUR IS
ABOUT IT'S ALSO WITH SOME OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURAL PLAYS ARE
ABOUT THEY WERE WORKING ON- BUT
IN THE MEANTIME OUR CONSUMERS
DESERVE TO KNOW. AND THIS IS
WHAT SB THIRTY THREE FORTY
THREE PROVIDE SOME WITH THAT
DIED AT INFORMATION ABOUT
RECYCLABILITY. SERVE WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
DISCUSSION. OF SENATOR ALLEN
ARE YOU TAKING THE COMMITTEE
DOESN'T WITH ME THE MOMENT I
SHOULD MENTION THAT. YES IN THE
MOTION AS TO DO PASS SAW RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
WITH SOFT COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
PHAM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I AM
NUMBER FOUR SB THREE FOUR THREE
BY SENATOR ALAN THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ALLEN.
AYE ALLEN AYE BATES. DALLY
PROBLEM. DELHI NOT VOTING
GONZALEZ HI. DOLLARS ICE
SKINNER. STERN Y. CASKEY.
HOUSEKI I'D- THE THREE BILLS
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN ON FOR
OUR MEMBERS TO RETURN AND THEN
IT WILL BE- HELLO I'M SURE IT
WILL BE APPROVED BY THEM YEAH.
THE NEXT ITEM- IS SB FIVE OH
TWO IS THAT CORRECT BUT I THINK
WE'RE TO GO TO CENTER GONZALEZ
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO THE BASKET.
THE NEW GET THE PLEASURE
DEFERENCE YOU HAVE THIS ONE YES
I'VE GOT THAT ONE OKAY THANK
YOU THE AT LEAST THE LONG.
COMMITTEE NIGHTMARE IS OVER NO
MORE ALLEN BILLS AT LEAST UNTIL
THE END- SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
FORBEARANCE BECAUSE LET'S NOT
TURN TO ARE PROBABLY GONNA
GONZALEZ IS GOING TO PRESENT SB
FOUR OH THREE ITEM FIVE IN YOUR
CHEN IS MEMBERS THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- I'M
PRESENTING TODAY S. B. FOUR OH
THREE WHICH WILL PROVIDE STATE
WATER AUTHORITIES WITH AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS GET CLOSER TO
REALIZING SAFE RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW THE LEGISLATURE PASSED SB
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH PROVIDED THE
STATE WATER BOARD WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO ORDER MANDATORY
CONSOLIDATIONS FOR WATER
SYSTEMS THAT SERVE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
CONSISTENTLY FAIL TO PROVIDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER WELL
THERE'S A THIRTY IS IMPORTANT
IT'S THE STATE IN THE STATES S.
H. AGAIN WATER EFFORTS IT CAN
ONLY BE USED IN SITUATIONS
WHERE THE DAMAGE IS ALREADY
BEEN DONE TO THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND THE SYSTEM IS ALREADY
PROVIDING AND SAFE WATER
WAITING UNTIL IT STRUGGLING
WATER SYSTEM FAILS BEFORE
TAKINGACTION DOESN'T REALLY
MAKE ANY SENSE TO US BEFORE-
THREE PROVIDES A PROACTIVE
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM BY
EXPANDING THE SB EIGHTY EIGHT
CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY TO
APPLY TO WATER SYSTEMS THAT
SERVE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND THAT ARE AT RISK OF FAILING
AND PLANNING AHEAD. FOR THAT OF
FOR THAT CONSOLIDATION IS AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL IN PROVIDING
ACCESS TO SAFE WATER BECAUSE
LARGER CONSOLIDATED SYSTEMS ARE
GENERALLY MORE RELIABLE SAFE
AND EFFICIENT AND THIS IS
EVIDENCED BY THE FACT THAT 90%
OF ALL DRINKING WATER
VIOLATIONS IN CALIFORNIA OCCUR
IN SMALL WATER SYSTEMS. MEMBERS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN OVERBURDENED
WITH THE IMPACTS OF WATER
CONTAMINATION IN CALIFORNIA I
CERTAINLY KNOW THESE
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE AND- IN
SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES PAY SKY
HIGH BILLS IN SOME CASES FOR
BROWN WATER AND CAN NO LONGER
ABIDE BY THE IN ACTION BY THE
STATE WE MUST ACT NOW
TESTIFYING AND IN SUPPORT
TODAY. AND AS BEFORE- THREE
THREE I HAVE MICHAEL CLAIBORNE
THE DIRECTING ATTORNEY FOR
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND MUDDY
YET LEAVE IT. UP AND BOARD
MEMBER OF THE TOOL AVAILABLE TO
ME JEWEL MANTRA WATER. CONSIDER
YOUR WITNESSES THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING TO THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M MICHAEL CLAIBORNE
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION BASED IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY ANY
COACHELLA VALLEY. AT THE CORE
OF PRE BUILT ON AT THE EIGHTY
EIGHT AND TWENTY FIFTEEN AT
EIGHT IN THE STRUGGLE TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER. AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUE
WITH THE BURDEN OF CONTAMINATED
TAP WATER DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE STATE
BOARD WOULD NOT HAVE ANY
EFFECTIVE TOOLS TO GET
STAKEHOLDERS AMPLE ROOM TO TALK
ABOUT CONSOLIDATION IF THE
SYSTEM HAS YET NOT YET FAILED.
EVEN IF IT'S ENTIRELY
PREDICTABLE THAT IT WILL FAIL.
EVERY DAY I SEE FIRSTHAND THE
CHALLENGES THAT SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS CASE TO KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON AND CLEAN WATER GLOWING.
STRUCTURAL CHALLENGES INCLUDE
DIFFICULTY WITH CANING IT AN
ACTIVE FORD AND CERTIFIED
OPERATOR INTERMITTENT WATER
QUALITY VIOLATIONS LACK OF
BACKUP WATER SOURCES AND COURT
COUNTY THE SCALE IN A LIMITED
GREAT CARE BEARS. IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO WAIT FOR A WATER
IN THE FAILED CAUSING FAMILIES
TO LOSE ACCESS TO WATER AND THE
STATE TO INEFFICIENTLY EXPEND
PUBLIC FUNDS TO DELIVER BOTTLED
WATER. INSTEAD THE STATE TO
WORK PROACTIVELY ALONG FACT
UNITY IDENTIFY AND IMPLEMENT
SOLUTIONS FOR WATER SYSTEMS
THAT ARE AT RISK AND ON THE
CUSP OF FAILURE THIS BILL
IMPORTANTLY REQUIRED MINIMUM
MEANINGFUL CONSULTATION AND
CONSIDERATION OF INPUT FROM
THOSE SERVED BY THE AVERAGE
WATER SYSTEM. WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE- AND I'LL TURN THE TIME
OVER TO MARIA TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHO WE BILL AND-
HILLARY COUNTY. AND HOW BURKE
ME COULD BENEFIT FROM AS PEOPLE.
FOUR OH THREE. AT SOME QUICK
FACTS TO EXCEL AT THE DATA.
COMMUNITY WITH SIX SEVEN SIX-
HOMES. SURVIVED IRATE WATERS
THE AND- BY. NITRATE VIOLATION.
THANK THE MAILING FROM
CONTAMINATION AND FINANCIAL AND
GOVERNANCE CHALLENGES. DESPITE
AVAILABLE STATE FUNDING IN
YEARS A VOLUNTARY TALK THE CITY
OF ACTOR CUT ABOVE
CONSOLIDATION. IN. TWENTY GOOD
MORNING. THE ONLY DATA ARE A
BORE EIGHT BOARD MEMBER WITH
THE OLD LOCAL NUMBER UP AND
WHAT. I AM HERE TO GET. SUPPORT
OF SB. FOUR THREE. THE FALCONS
HEARING BUT STARTED SEVEN FALL.
ERIC COUNTY WE ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR WATER SYSTEM. GOING FOR OUR
COULD BE CONNECTED TO THE MEDIA.
EXTRUDER WHICH IS ELEVEN MILES
IT HARPER THANK THE MALL WILL
MEAN. TAKE CARE OF- EVERYTHING
THAT NEEDS TO BE. SHOULD KEEP
OUR WATER RUNNING. WE NEED HELP
TO THE TV ON CALL. I KNOW THAT
THEY- DON'T THEY SO MUCH MONEY
MONEY FOR BY WATER. AND SEWER
WE HAVE STATE INCOME. AND WITH
THEM BOTH IT IS ALMOST A
THOUSAND. THE PUMP OR ARE WHERE.
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND LONGER AND
WE- THAT THERE WILL TIMES WITH
A TWO YEARS WELL NEED TO PUT A
METER. THE PEOPLE USE THE TERM
WATER OVER THE SUMMER BUT AGAIN
WE FOR SUPPORT FOR THE FOR MANY-
WE DON'T EITHER COME. IN THE IN
THE SAME. CENTURY. LARRY COUNTY
THANK YOU. ALL OF RIGHT OKAY.
YOUR A TO THE TUNES OKAY FROM
THE THANK YOU CENTER OKAY LET'S
SOME I DON'T SEE ANYONE- HERE
TO TELL IN FOR TWO A- I HAVE
SEEN THE PICTURES OF TWENTY FOR
DANCING THERE EITHER SO LET'S.
WHAT THE PHONE LINE SEE IF
ANYONE WAS TO WIN. PLEASE JUST
GIVE NAME AND- ALL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB. ZERO PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR ZERO THREE. PRESS ONE AND
THEIR- NOW. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE FOUR PEOPLE IN Q. FIVE
PEOPLE IN Q. THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MESSAGE AT
LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN I COULD GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU TURN NUMBERS INTO A CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF IT BEFORE IT THREE
AND ALSO CALLING TO REGISTER
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF CLEAN
WATER ACTION. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT OF ATHLETES FOR
THEIR THREE THANK YOU. FOR
FLIGHT NUMBER NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JIM WEINBERGER ON
BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR ZERO THREE
THANK YOU. WHAT LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF YOUR CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR THREE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
TERM MEMBERS THIS WOULD HAVE TO
LEAVE IT WITH THE COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER CALLING IN SRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR THREE THANK
YOU FOR CHECK FOR YOUR TIME AND
ENERGY AND ALL THREE LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE. THE MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. FOUR AS BEFORE. ZERO THREE
SUPPORT. OKAY ARE LET'S GO TO-
OPPOSITION I CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL. TIME HI I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE ANYONE WAS REGISTERED TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AND I
DON'T SEE ONE HERE IN THE ROOM
BUT IT MAYBE THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES.WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR ZERO
THREE. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL TAKE YOUR NAME
WILL TAKE YOUR FLIGHT NUMBER
AND YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE. TO
GET IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR ZERO
THREE. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. FOR
METASOMATISM WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION BUT WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE ELSE FOR SUPPORT. OKAY.
ALL THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
NINETY THREE LINE IS OPEN. I
THINK THAT THE ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. FOR A
THREE. THANK YOU. ALRIGHT WE
ARE MOVING IN THERE IS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL YOU CAN SEE THAT THE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION ANALYSIS SO
LET'S BRING THE- WHAT'S BEING
ADDED BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTION STOTTS- CENTER CASKEY.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY THE NATURAL
NEXT STEP THAT WE TAKE IN
REQUIRING ENFORCING THESE
FEELING WATER DISTRICTS I DID
TAKE A LOOK SECTION OF ONE OF
YOUR WITNESSES. SAYING IT WAS
AN EASY ISSUE AND IT WAS THE
STATE CONTROL PROBLEM THIS IS
THE PROBLEM SHOULD BE PUT AT
THE FOOT. OF THE CULPRIT IN THE
CITY'S LOCAL FEELING WATER
DISTRICTS TO CONTINUE TO
COLLECT FEES CONTINUE TO PUSH
BACK ON NOT DOING VOLUNTARY
CONSOLIDATIONS AND THIS IS WAS
FORCED US TO COME UP WITH THIS
MAN. I MEAN THE STATE HAS. KERN
AS MUCH AS THEY COULD
ENCOURAGING CONSOLIDATIONS
HELPING OUT WHAT RESOURCES
HELPING OUT WITH EDUCATING SOME
OF THE FOLKS IT'S NOT YOUR
FATHER'S WATER DISTRICT ANYMORE
WHERE YOU COULD USE- ED. SELL
WATER BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT THE
HOOK UPS SO THAT'S THE FIRST
THING THAT ARE JUST CLEAR UP IN
IN THE SECOND IS SAID WHO IS
NOT COVERED THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE FIFTEEN UNITS FOR
LESS ARE NOT CONTROLLED BY THE
STATE AND I THINK. A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE ADVOCATES THAT
ARE ON THE LINE I THINK THAT
WE'RE GOING TO DELIVER SAFE
DRINKING WATER TO EVERYBODY WE
DON'T HAVE ANY JURISDICTION
OVER THEM SOME OF THE WORST
FEELING- SITUATIONS OR PEOPLE
THAT RUN. WINTER TWELVE THE
ROLE ON A WELL THEY THINK
THEIR- DAD OR GRANDPA GERALD
WELL WHAT ONCE UPON A TIME IN
THE THESE NITRATES AND SOME
NATURALLY OCCURRING
CONTAMINANTS IS NOT NOBODY NO
HUMAN BEING IS DONE ANYTHING
SO. I APPLAUD. I MISS GONZALEZ
BRINGING THIS INTO SITTING OKAY
WE'VE BEEN NICE ON VOLUNTARY
CONSOLIDATIONS NOW WE'RE GOING
TO FORCE THESE CONSOLIDATIONS
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE FEEL
FEELING AND WE HAD. A LOVELY
CONVERSATION BY. THE OTHER
MEMBERS HERE ABOUT TRUTH. IT IS
BEING SENT OUT TO THE PUBLIC
AND I THINK THIS IS ONE OF
THESE- OF CONTINUING PROBLEMS
WERE THE STATE HAS TO BE TOWED
WE'VE DONE THE BEST WE CAN AND
THIS IS THE- CONSEQUENCE WOULD
TELL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
THIRTY DOLLARS. THE AIM IS TO
RENT TOTALLY GET PROBLEM
UNDERSTAND IT. M. TOO FAMILIAR
WITH ACTUALLY COUPLE QUESTIONS
THOUGH SO. WHO'S GONNA PAY SO
WE DID. THE STATE PASSED SB
EIGHTY EIGHT THEN WE SAW. THE
THOSE TWO BOYS A PORTER BILL
PORTER VILLE IN THE IN THE
VALLEY THERE'S A HUGE
DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITIES WHERE
WE HAD- SYSTEMS FAILING IN.
CONTAMINATED WATER AND NO
FUNDING NO A WEEK NUMBER ONE
YOU HAVE PROP TO EIGHTEEN THAT
DOESN'T DOESN'T THEY DON'T PASS
FEES ON THEMSELVES TYPICALLY-
SO THAT'S A BARRIER YUP LASKO
CONCERNS ABOUT FORCING THEM
INTO CONSOLIDATION. AND SO WHAT
WE SAW WAS WE DID THE MONNING
BILL. THE WAS IT LAST YEAR AND
I KNOW THAT TO CENTER BY CAL
SKI LOVED THAT BILL BECAUSE IT
TOOK GREENHOUSE GAS MONIES IN
FIXED A WATER PROBLEM. SO MY
QUESTION IS A- IT IS HOW HOW I
MEAN I UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXES
OF THIS ISSUE. AND WHAT WHAT
WHAT'S A MECHANISM TO ACTUALLY
WHEN YOU FOR SOMEBODY TO DO
SOMETHING YOU'RE EXPECTING THAT
TO GET DONE AND CONSOLIDATE BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY YOU HAVE
MAYBE ONE SYSTEM THAT IS. CAN
IN CAN I READ I READ THROUGH
THE ANALYSIS THAT WE HAVE ABOUT-
YOU KNOW YOU BASICALLY ARE NOT
ASKING THEM TO PUT UP ANY MORE
MONEY YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE A
MERGE WITHOUT PUTTING MONEY UP
BUT THERE'S A- HUGE DISCONNECT
THERE BECAUSE- SOME OF THE
SYSTEMS. NEED SUCH A LOT OF-
FINANCES INVESTED IN THEM AND
THEN YOU PUT A BURDEN ON A
SYSTEM THAT IS IN IT SO YOU'RE
TAXING SOMEBODY WHO IS. NOT
GETTING THE BENEFIT FROM THE
WHICH THEN BECOMES A LOT OF
QUESTIONS SO I JUST WANTED IT
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS WERE ON. HOW
THIS WOULD ACTUALLY PLAY OUT
AND B. B. BURKE. AT THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY AND I THINK- THIS
IS THESE ARE THE FEW STEPS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE BEFORE
CONSOLIDATION AND AS MENTIONED
BY SENATOR MAKOWSKI THERE'S A
VOLUNTARY. CALLED CONSOLIDATION
THAT COULD BE AN OPTION.
PARTIAL MERGERS IT'S NOT A FULL
MERGER YOU KNOW. THERE'S
DIFFERENT OPTIONS THAT COULD BE
DONE BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY
THESE FOLKS ARE NOT RECEIVING.
AS YOU MENTIONED. CLEAN WATER
FOR THE AMOUNT THAT THEY'RE
PAYING AN ESPECIALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- THAT
AREN'T GETTING THAT I MEAN TO
BE ABLE TO. PRINT POTENTIALLY
MERGE WITHOUT THE STATE OR EVEN
JUST GETTING A LETTER FROM THE
STATE OR- YOU KNOW BY SAYING
THIS IS A SUGGESTION FOR YOU TO
CONSOLIDATE- AND YOUR WITHIN
THREE MILES OF. A GOAL GOOD
PERFORMING- THAT COMPANY I
THINK WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR AGAIN THE BETTERMENT OF
THE- OF THE CONSTITUENTS THAT
WE ALL SIR- AND WE DON'T. ALSO
WANT TO TAP INTO THE SB TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS IF YOU DON'T
NEED TO. IT AND THAT'S A
HUNDRED A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS I THINK PER
YEAR. SO I'M YOU KNOW IF WE
DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO THAT
WE- WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO JUST
PROVIDE THESE PREVENTION
MECHANISMS IS HARM PREVENTION
MECHANISMS TO BE ABLE TO. ALLOW
FOLKS TO AGAIN. COME UP WITH
THEIR OWN PLAN- BEFORE WE GET
INVOLVED BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE
STATE WATER BOARD IS ALSO
FOCUSED ON THOSE THAT ARE
ALREADY FAILING. AND SO THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE YOU KNOW I
MEAN THIS IS JUST GOING TO BE
ON OUR RADAR BUT- ONE OTHER
THING THAT WE CAN DO TO JUST AT
LEAST PUT ON OUR RADAR AND-
HOPEFULLY. GET THOSE FOLKS TO
DO IT ON ON THEIR OWN. WELL WE
HAVE IT UNDER SB EIGHTY EIGHT
WE HAVEN'T BEEN. SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING THEM TO DO IT ON THEIR
OWN AND BECAUSE IT BOILS DOWN
TO THOSE THREE THINGS I TALKED
ABOUT WHICH IS. UP TO EIGHTEEN
LASKO AND THEN FINANCING AND
THOSE ARE THE TO THE- TRUST ME
THESE PEOPLE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
DO IT BUT THEY CAN'T. THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO DO IT. N. A. IT
WE CAN WE CAN PASS A MANDATE ON
TO THEM BUT A MANDATE IS SIMPLY
SOMETHING THAT SAYS YOU HAVE TO
DO THIS AND THEN THERE'S NO.
THERE'S NO VEHICLE. FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO RAISE THE RATE. TO
BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL.
YEAH IT'S JUST A CONSIDERATION
IT'S NOT A MANDATE AND WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS RIGHT NOW I MEAN
WE NEED THE DATA AT LEAST TO BE
ABLE TO SEE. WHERE THESE AT
RISK FAILING SYSTEMS ARE. BUT I
WILL TELL YOU I MEAN IT I MEAN
THEY'RE ON THE CUSP OF FEELING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE VARIOUS
INDICATORS. WHICH ARE BEING
ASSESSED RIGHT NOW BY THE WATER
BOARD. AS YOU KNOW POOR
GOVERNANCE LACK OF FINANCIAL
RESERVES FAILURE TO MAINTAIN
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
PRESENCE OF PRIMARY AND
SECONDARY CONTAMINANTS I MEAN
IS A REALLY SEVERE ISSUES THAT
WE CAN'T WAIT YOU KNOW TO JUST
ONE DAY. FIGURE OUT WE HAVE TO
ACT AT LEAST HAVE THE MONEY ON
OUR RADAR- SO LEAVE IT AT THAT
BUT I JUST. YOU KNOW WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ENGAGING IS
THERE. IS THERE CAPITAL. SIZE
OF WATER SYSTEMS. NO THERE IS
NO CAP IT JUST IT FALLS IN LINE
WITH SB EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY AT THE CENTER
AND. FIVE CETERA CASKEY
OVERLOOK THE MOVE THE BILL I.
WITH THE BILL AND- GIVE A
CLOSER JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR ENGAGING AND I JUST
HOPE THAT WE CAN DO- COULD WORK
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT NEED SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND I THINK YOU-
ALL THE- STAKEHOLDERS WHO
CALLED IN TODAY. THANK YOU AS
WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER CALCULATES- CONSULT
WITH FEDERAL. I DON'T NUMBER
FIVE SB FOUR ORDER THREE BY
ENATOR GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE ALLEN. BY ALLEN AYE
BATES NOT VOTING. IT'S NOT
VOTING DALY NOPE DALLY NO
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ IF YOU MIKE
ON TIE LAWS HI SKINNER STERN BY
CASKEY BY AYE CASKEY AYE. OKAY
SO THAT IS WE'RE GONNA LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR CENTER STERN TO FINISH
TURNS GOING TO SKINNER THAT ON.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
LET'S NOW GO TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
THE SENATE RECOUNT SKIS. SB
THIRTY EIGHT VERY- NO SIMPLE
BILL. AFTER ALL THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND TRUTHFULNESS IN
TAKING POWER AWAY FROM CAL
RECYCLE AND CONSUMER KNOWLEDGE
AND ALL THESE IN A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD I DO I.
AM DELIGHTED TO BE HERE TO
PERCENT- SB THIRTY EIGHT AND
FIRST I WANT EXCEPT START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS IS
OUTLINED IN THE- IN THE STAFF
REPORT AND THEN TO CONSULTANT
FOR HER WORK- WITH MY OFFICE ON
THE ANALYSIS THIS YEAR. TWO
YEARS AGO AND FOUR YEARS AGO-
SB THIRTY EIGHT IS AS THE STAFF
REPORT INDICATES A
COMPREHENSIVE BOTTLE BILL
REFORM THE CALIFORNIA HAS
NEEDED FOR YEARS AND IT FIXES
ARE ANTIQUATED BEVERAGE
CONTAINER REDEMPTION RECYCLING
PROGRAM. THE BILL ESTABLISHES A
NEW STREAMLINED STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM THE PLACE IS REDEMPTION
AND RECYCLING RESPONSIBILITIES
ON THOSE. WHO DISTRIBUTE THE
BEVERAGES INSIDE CALIFORNIA
IT'S A PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
YOU CREATE THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER YOU'RE GOING TO RUN
THE ROGRAM WE'RE GOING TO
SHRINK DOWN CAL RECYCLE IS
THINK THE STAFF REPORT
INDICATES THE- STATE OF OREGON
HAS ONE PERSON WORKING FOR THE
GOVERNMENT THAT DOES READ-
RECYCLING. THIS BILL IS SIMILAR
TO LEGISLATION THAT I'VE
INTRODUCED BEFORE AND I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS AS IT GOES
FORWARD AS I HAVE FOR FOUR
YEARS. PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO.
PROPOSE TO. REDUCE BACK IN.
RESEARCH EFFICIENCIES AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE
INTERESTED REDUCING
CONTAMINATION- UNLIKE MY
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION THOUGH S.
B- THIRTY EIGHT DOES NOT EXPAND
THE CONTAINERS COVERED IN THE
PROGRAM I'VE LISTENED TO MANY
MEMBERS THAT WERE UNWILLING TO
VOTE FOR A BILL THAT DIDN'T
EXPANSION SO WE HAVE WE'RE NOT.
AT THIS TIME SEEKING TO EXPAND
THE COVERAGE IT IS MODELED AS I
INDICATED QUITE A BIT AFTER THE
OREGON PROGRAM IT'S A PROGRAM
THAT I AND OTHER MEMBERS HAD
VISITED MEETING WITH THEIR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP LEADERS
THE PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS AND
SEEING HOW THE RETENTION THEIR
BOTTLE. DEPOSIT A BILL WORKS
HERE DECADES AGO OR ONCE UPON A
TIME I GUESS IS MORE
APPROPRIATE THE BOTTLE BILL WAS
THE IMPETUS OF CALIFORNIA'S
NATIONAL LEADERSHIP RECYCLING
THAT IS NO LONGER THE CASE- I
KNOW. CONSUMER WATCHDOG WHO
WERE GOING TO BE HEARING FROM
HAS PRODUCED A REPORT ENTITLED
TRASH THE CAME OUT LAST YEAR
HOW CALIFORNIA'S RECYCLING
FAILED AND HOW TO FIX IT- YOU
KNOW WE- WHAT WE HAD. SIX IN
PREVENTING BILLIONS OF BOTTLES
AND CANS FROM BEING- TURNED IN
INTO LITTER OR TO GO TO
LANDFILLS BUT- SAID I'M HERE
MISTER CHURCH WITH YOU AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SAY WE CAN
DO MUCH BETTER. MANY OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BILLIONS OF
BOTTLES AND CANS HAVE SAVED
ENERGY HAVE SAFE WATER
RESOURCES. BUT AFTER STE THIRTY
YEARS AND OVER SEVENTY FIVE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL THE
STRUCTURE NO LONGER REFLECTS
OUR NEED TO MEET OUR GOAL. AS
INSURE THE CHEER- HERE'S OUR
GIRL GOAL FOR CIRCULAR ECONOMY.
THE REFORMS LAID OUT IN SB
THIRTY EIGHT OR BASED ON THREE
SIMPLE PRINCIPLES. ONE IS
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY WE'RE
GOING TO THE PRODUCERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE- THERE AT THE
TABLE AS WELL AS ALL THE OTHER
PARTNERS. SECOND CONSUMER.
CONFIDENCE AND CONSUMER
CONVENIENCE THAT WE HAVE AND
THIRD IMPROVING THE RECYCLING
WRITTEN. REMANUFACTURING
CAPABILITIES. SB THIRTY TO
CREATE A THIRTY EIGHT. ANOTHER
THIRTY TWO DOES FOR THIRTY
EIGHT CREATES A STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM RUN BY THE DISTRIBUTORS
AND LARGE PRODUCERS THAT
DISTRIBUTOR ON PRODUCTS. THEY
WOULD CRAFTED PROGRAM STRUCTURE
WITH INPUT FROM OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WE'RE LETTING THE
PRIVATE BUSINESS CREATE THE
PROGRAM. THIS TRANSITION TO A
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM IN SB
THIRTY EIGHT DOES LIMIT CAL
RECYCLES. ROLE BUT IT DOES NOT.
IT EVENT LIVE TO OVERSIGHT AND
IF OF. THIS IS A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION TO COMPLEX PROBLEMS
TOOK AS MANY YEARS TO GET HERE
THE SOLUTION OTHER STATES AND
OTHER NATIONS. I HAVE- HAVE
TAKEN HAVE OF MUCH HIGHER
RETENTION RATES THE
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED IN
CALIFORNIA CAN DO BETTER I HAVE
WITNESSES IN LINE TO TESTIFIED
IN SUPPORT MISTER I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. MY WITH MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOUR
WITNESSES ARE JAMIE COURT FROM
CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND JEFF DUNN
JEFF DONLEVY FROM- MING'S
RECYCLING CORPORATION
SACRAMENTO. AT LEAST THOSE TWO
AND ALSO ST PETERS FROM THE
SEVEN YEAH SORT OF SURPRISING
OKAY SO LET'S LET'S TURN TO DO
YOUR YOUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO. A MODERATOR DO WE HAVE-
WE HAVE THOSE FOLKS READY ON
THE ON THE LINE SO WHATEVER G.
ME W. IN ALL THE LAND OPENNESS.
I'M SO SORRY TO HEAR YOU. ALL
THE LINES ARE OPEN THERE. MR
MAKE ME LEAVE ME WITH THEIR
CONSUMER WATCHDOG GREAT YEAH
THIS IS JAMIE FROM CONSUMER
WATCHDOG CAN YOU HEAR ME
STATURE WE HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR. OKAY GREAT THANKS SO
MUCH THANK DECEMBER WHITE HOUSE
YOU FOR SUPPORTING SB THIRTY
EIGHT AND- INTRODUCING IT. YOU
KNOW COULD BE CALIFORNIA'S-
REDEMPTION RIGHT THIS IS THE
RATE AT WHICH CONSUMERS GET
THEIR DEPOSIT BACK IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE HAVE THE NUMBERS.
FROM POWER CYCLE IT IS A 50%
REDEMPTION RATE. THAT IS- BUT
IF YOU TAKE THE RECYCLING RATE
IS 60% TAKE UP 210% CLICK GOES
TO CURBSIDE OUR RETENTION RATE
IS 58% AND THAT IS THE THIRD
WORST. AMONG BOTTLE DEPOSITS IN
THE- AMERICA WE ARE PROMISED AN
80% RETENTION RATE WE HAVE A
58% RETENTION RATE IT'S NOT
GETTING BETTER. THE REASON IS
REDEMPTION CENTERS OF CLOSE IN
RECORD NUMBERS RETAILERS
GROCERS THEY'RE NOT TAKING BACK
AND SEEMS. MORE GROCERS ARE
OPTING OUT THEY CAN PAY A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A DAY AN OPT
OUT 75% OF WHOLE FOOD SOURCES
OF THE GREEN GROCER WHOLE FOODS
HAVE OPTED OUT OF RECEIVING
BOTTLES AND CANS. AND SO WITH
NO PLACE LEFT TO TURN COAL
TUMORS STROKE THE CANS AND-
BOTTLES IN THE KERBSIDE AND AT
LEAST ONE IN FOUR OF THOSE. END
UP IN LANDFILL BECAUSE THEY'RE
CONTAMINATED BY THE SINGLE
STREAM LOANS. SB THIRTY EIGHT
RINGS CALIFORNIA INTO LINE WITH.
EVERY OTHER SUCCESSFUL BOTTLE
DEPOSIT PROGRAM AMERICAN THE
WORLD. AND CHARGING INDUSTRY.
AS OPERATOR. AND POPPING THE
PODS. UP UPPING THE- FIVE TEN
CENTS. YOU HAVE AN ANSWER TO
HAVE A HIGHER REDEMPTION RATES
THIS IS WHAT YOU EVERY ELSE WE
CAN MAKE. YEAH BOTTLE DEPOSIT
PROGRAM IN A- POSSIBLE IN AB
PER RETENTION RATE WHICH IS A
THE GOAL IN THIS THIRTY IS YOU
LOOK AT THE OTHER STATES. WITH
SIMILAR- X. PRODUCERS. OFFICE
THEY HAVE THESE RATES MISTER IN
PER ARE AGAIN EIGHTY SIX
PERCENT. MILLION 84% PER MONTH
SEVENTY ONE PERCENT. WE JUST
NEED THE COURAGE TO TAKE ON THE
SPECIAL INTERESTS THAT HAVE
TAKEN THIS PROGRAM FOR RIDE FOR
TOO LONG AND TO MAKE THIS
PROGRAM INTO. ONE THAT IS GOOD
FOR THE CONSUMER. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. BY ENDING. CURBING
CRIME CHANGE AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE CO V. ONE WE IT. IT'S
NOT A TAX BECAUSE THERE IS YOU
CAN. WAY TO IT BACK. AND AND
THEIR- NO GOING BACK NOW
BECAUSE OF THE- DECIMATING THE
RID. SENT AND THE- NOT WILL TO
STEP UP BUT THEY DO THE LEGAL
RESPONSE. WE NEED TO WE NEED AN
OVERHAUL AND SB THIRTY EIGHT IS
THAT OVERALL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER COURT. THE MORNING
CHAIRMAN ALAN MY NAME IS JEFF
DONLEVY GENERAL MANAGER OF
MEANS RESOURCES THE SPECS HERE
TO SUPPORT SB THIRTY EIGHT THE
MAJOR REFORM THE CONSUMERS
DISCOVER CREATES JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU STRATEGICAL
CREEKS IN THE BOTTLE BILL WILL
NOT HELP US THINGS WILL ONLY
GET WORSE WE CAN DEFINITELY DO
BETTER THINGS WILL SOUND
BINDING LONG WHO CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES FROM VIETNAM IN
THE OPEN WHAT IS TODAY THE
OLDEST. CERTIFIED RECYCLING
CENTER IN SACRAMENTO. FOR WE
SEEM TOO MANY YEARS. CENTERS
CLOSE. IN OTHER RECYCLING
CENTERS WILL SUPPORT
LEGISLATION. THAT HELPS IMPROVE
THE PROGRAM FOR CONSUMERS AND
SUPPORTS. OLD MINERS HIKING
CENTERS. BEING INSISTENCE
DISAPPEARED FROM MANY
COMMUNITIES THE GROWING
CONTAMINATION CURBSIDE MATERIAL
AS A RESULT OF THE MATERIAL
BEING SHIPPED OUT OF STATE AND
TAKING OBS WITH IT. YOUR
EQUALITY FROM RECYCLING CENTERS
CREATES INVESTMENT IN THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND CREATE
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA. HAVING A
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION LED BY
THE DISTRIBUTORS WILL BRING
THEIR EXPERTISE IN LOGISTICS TO
HELP SOLVE MANY OF THE PROBLEMS
FACING THE PROGRAM. WE BELIEVE
THE NEW ORGANIZATION BRINGS
TOGETHER THE SUPERTEAM OF
DISTRIBUTORS MANUFACTURERS
GROCERS AND RECYCLING CENTERS.
TO MODERNIZE OUR SYSTEM EXPAND
ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
REDEEM THEIR C. R. V. DEPOSIT.
I LIKE TO THANK SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
MOTION FORWARD. AND FOR THESE
REASONS I URGE A YES VOTE ON SB
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY THANK YOU
I THINK FINALLY WE'VE GOT SAM
PIERCE. HI GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN ALAN- COME MORNING
SENATORS ON INCENTIVES- I'M
HELD A HEALTHY DISCHARGED A
PROJECT. BY MENTAL CONDITION
BASED IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
AND THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS IN
CHRONIC DECLINE- WE STAY IN THE
CULTURE STRETCHING HUNDRED
REDUCTION CONSISTENT STEP IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN- UNDERSUPPLY HE
DIDN'T. OTHER WITHOUT INCIDENT
ON IT NOT WITHOUT. COSTS SHE A
STUDY FROM THE CA TO UNITE
MICHELLE OF STAB AFTER PERCENT
THE REMAINING RECYCLING CENTERS.
WITH AN ADDITIONAL NOW FOUR
FILE TONS OF CONTENT LAND SILVA
AND- THAT WOULD GENERATE THE
EQUIVALENT OF I COULDN'T I'M-
OF MORE THAN TWO. SEVEN
THOUSAND COLLEGE ON BECAUSE
WERE AND PER YEAR. SB THIRTY
EIGHT WITH. OF MANY THE BEST.
DEPOSITS OUT WHICH MANUFACTURES
JUST FOR FUNDING AND- TO THE
PROGRAM. IS THE DEPOSIT VALUE
LEYVA TO ACHIEVE HIGH YOU COULD
RIGHT. AND SHE WAS ACCEPTABLE
INCOME. FOR US TO AFRICAN. ONE
I WOULD POLL BY TWO SENATE-ROOM
FUND UNDER SIXTY. A COUPLE TOLD
WOULD BE MORE LIKELY TO RETURN
ABOUT WHICH CAN IT THERE WERE
MORE. FINALLY INCOMES OF THE
CAN AT THE TO COST. THE SAME
MEANING YOU KNOW YES BUT SHOWED
A BEST IN CLASS BECAUSE IT'S-
SERVICE WON THOSE STRUCTURE TO
SB YET MATCHING. NINETY RETURN
RIGHT WHICH DOSH PASSED HE
ELECT. BY 51% FOR CURRENT LAST
FROM CURRENT- I'M SIXTY SIX
MILLION PAGES CONTENT AGREES
SINGLE YEAR- MUST STICK TO WE
ARE HOW TO DO. IMPACT. HOW DO
YOU PROPOSE TO TURN UP AND NOT
BUMP WHICH SPENT A CLEAR
PICTURE OF BREAKING VARMINTS
COSTA ON DACA BECAUSE FOR NEW
BEST IN CLASS SYSTEM LIKE. THE.
OFFLINE AND PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER PLACE YOU BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIRMAN AS PEOPLE QUEUE UP. IT
WAS LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
TO NOT MISTER CHAIRMAN. THERE
FOR A MOMENT THERE ARE THREE
OTHER LINE NUMBER. HOLDEN THANK
YOU AND LINE NUMBER. MY NUMBER
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS CHUCK KRIEGEL
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT WITH
COMMERCE SYSTEMS AMERICANS WE
SUPPORT SENATE BILL THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. ANOTHER SOME
OF THE GERMAN WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
LET'S GO TO THE OPPOSITION NOW-
THIS. DO WE HAVE SO I DON'T
HAVE ANY. I KNOW THERE IS SOME
RECORD OPPOSITION BUT I DON'T
HAVE IT ON MY CHART HERE FOR
THE DESERVES. SENATOR THERE'S
NOBODY TESTIFYING BUT LET'S
LET'S AND- I DON'T SEE ON HERE
OR IN TWENTY FORTY. LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINE SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO'S CALLED IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
THIRTY EIGHT. ONE WOMAN
OFFICIALS SAID WE HAVE ABOUT
FOUR PEOPLE QUEUING UP. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT SIR MY NUMBER
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. PLEASE PROCEED BY- STEVEN
MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN
OPPOSITION MAN THAT. RATHER
THAN PUTTING BEVERAGE
DISTRIBUTORS IN CHARGE OF
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING WE
BELIEVE THE BETTER PATH FORWARD
IS TO MAKE A SMALL NUMBER OF
SPECIFIC UPDATES TO THE
PROGRAM. INCLUDING GIVING POWER
CYCLE MORE AUTHORITY TO ALLOW
FLEXIBLE RECYCLING
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE
ACCESS FOR CONSUMERS. THE LOCAL
COURTS STAND READY TO ASSIST IN
DESIGNING AND IMPLEMENTING
PROGRAMS THAT MAKE RECYCLING
MORE CONVENIENT FOR CONSUMERS
ACROSS THE STATE. THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS AND THE LOCAL COURTS
PARTICIPATION IN THE PROGRAM IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WOULD HAVE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS ON OUR
OPERATIONS. SO WE ARE EAGER TO
CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATION WITH
THE AUTHOR TO FIND A RESOLUTION
THAT PROTECTS THE CORE. AND
INCREASES RECYCLING
OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MARK MURRAY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE- WE
ARE IT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTY EIGHT- CERTAINLY THE
BOTTLE AND CAN RECYCLING LAWS
IN NEED OF ATTENTION BUT THE
ATTENTION THAT IS NEEDED IT'S A
VERY SPECIFIC. IS VERY WELL
UNDERSTOOD AND IT'S VERY
AFFORDABLE WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF THE EXISTING PROGRAM- OR OF
S. THIRTY EIGHT IS NOT A
COMPREHENSIVE FIX IT SIMPLY
SHIFTING WHO IS RESPONSIBLE IT
SHIFTING RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OPERATING IN OVERSEEING THE
PROGRAM FROM CAL RECYCLE WHO
HANDLES ALL OF THE RECYCLING
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA TO THE
BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS THERE ARE
MORE THAN TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTOR IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TODAY WE
THINK BUT THEY WERE POORLY
EQUIPPED TO RUN A COMPREHENSIVE
RECYCLING PROGRAM AND THERE'S
NOTHING. IN SB THIRTY EIGHT BUT
DEFINES WHAT THAT PROGRAM WOULD
LOOK LIKE- THERE IS- THAT THE
SUPPORTERS HAVE MADE REFERENCE
TO THE OREGON BOTTLE AND CAN
RECYCLING PROGRAM. BUT UNTIL OR
INCREASE THEIR REAP VALUE.
CONTENT CALIFORNIA HAD A BETTER
RECYCLING RATES IN OREGON FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE CALIFORNIA
HAS HAD A BETTER RECYCLING
RATES IN OREGON AND EVEN TODAY
RIGHT NOW TODAY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AND THE ENTIRE- SAM
JOAQUIN VALLEY HAS A BETTER
RECYCLING RATE FOR BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS IN OREGON. SO. BY
NUMBER FORTY FOUR DEADLINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
DENNIS- CALIFORNIA BEER AND
BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS WE ARE
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION I'D LIKE
TO. SAY THAT MR MURRAY'S
COMMENTS ARE VERY. CORRECT
CORRECT AND IT ALSO STUDENTS
AND ALLEN'S MAXWELL MORE SENSE
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA. OKAY MY
NUMBER ONE ONE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN GEORGE NO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY BEER
DISTRIBUTORS- CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT FAMILY OWNED
DISTRIBUTORS HAVE BEEN
OPERATING IN LOCAL MARKETS FOR
UP TO A HUNDRED YEARS. REMEMBER
SPACE TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES IN
TODAY'S MARKET PLACE AND SB
THIRTY EIGHT WOULD JUST FURTHER
EXACERBATE THE LONG TERM
VIABILITY. OF CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT FAMILY OWNED
DISTRIBUTORS BY ADDING.RATHER
BURN SOME ADDITIONAL COSTS AND
LIABILITY TO THEIR ALREADY
STRAINED- SURE AS SUCH WE MUST.
BE A PROCESS THE THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. OKAY APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS AND IF I CAN
JUST ASK THE M. THE FOLLOWING
AND THEN THE NEXT FOLKS CALLING
IN OPPOSITION TO THE STATE
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION
BECAUSE WE'VE NOW HEARD FROM.
WE'VE HEARD SOMETHING OF COMMON
FOR DIFFERENT ACT COUPON IT'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LINE
NUMBER ONE OH TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO. AHEAD. MORNING
MR MEMBERS DAVID KRIEGER ON
BEHALF OF WASTE CONNECTIONS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR SURE MEMBERS STEVE CARLSON
FOR ATHENS SERVICES A FAMILY
OWNED- SOLID WASTE RECYCLING
COMPANY IN LOS ANGELES FOR THE
REASONS STATED WERE IN
OPPOSITION RESPECTFUL. BY
NUMBER NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF WASTE
MANAGEMENT ALSO AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. PRITCHETT OF OTHERS
BUT AT THIS TIME IS IT. AT THE
TIME OF THE TIME AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- SO WHAT'S
NOW BRING THE ITEM BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- I TURNED OR
LOQUACIOUS FRIEND- CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU SO I JUST STARTED A
COUPLE OF WHAT. CAN YOU EXPLAIN
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IN THE SO
FIRST OF ALL I THAT WE SAW THIS
WE TALK WE TALK ABOUT THIS A
LOT STRAIGHT. BETTER THAN WHERE
YOU'RE TRYING TO GO- THAT'S
WHAT THE PROBLEM IS HOW WE GET
THERE- SO THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO POINT FOUR. THE
FOLKS WHO WORK FOR CAL RECYCLE.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED THERE WAS.
THERE'S TWO I'VE I'VE THE
THERE'S TWO IN OREGON WITH A
POPULATION ABOUT FOUR MILLION
SO WHAT WHAT HOW THE TRANSITION
THAT WOULD DO. IF HE IF THIS
WAS ACTUALLY TO GET SIGNED INTO
LAW WITH THE TRANSITION OF LIKE
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE- EXISTING.
THE F. T. E.'S IT EKOW RECYCLE.
IN THE MONEY FLOW. ALL ALL THE
MONEY WOULD GO TO THE- THE
DISTRIBUTORS AND THE BEVERAGE
CONSISTS SYSTEM RICHER PROGRAM
THAT'S THAT SET UP SO THEY THEY
COLLECTED CALIFORNIA'S WOULD
WOULD HAVE TO RETOOL R. I. CAL
RECYCLE THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO CAL RECYCLE DOES FOR LIKE
WILDFIRES WHEN THEY COME UP AND
WE GET TO COURT PROGRAM AND
THINGS LIKE THAT BUT THOSE
PEOPLE WOULD NOT BE RUNNING THE
PROGRAM THE PROGRAM WILL BE RUN
BY IT'S AN INDEPENDENT
STEWARDSHIP CAMILLUS BE FRANK.
DISTRIBUTOR AND WASTE HAULERS
ARE NOT GONNA BE RUNNING THIS
PROGRAM IS COULD BE AN
INDEPENDENT- PROGRAM THIS COULD
BE. DESIGNED BY THEM AND WE'RE
LETTING PRIVATE INDUSTRY TO
DESIGN IT SO I SEE THOSE
PEOPLE. MOVING TO DIFFERENT
TASK WITHI CAL RECYCLES OR
EARLY RETIREMENT SHOULD THINGS
THINGS LIKE THAT BUT BUT THE
IDEA IS THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE A REPORT AND THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE PROGRAM. IS
GOING TO BE THE LIMITED ROLE
THAT CAL RECYCLE WILL PLAY AT
LEAST IN THE BOTTLE. INDUSTRY
THERE HAVE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT THIS IS IN
THE BOTTLE. SECOND QUESTION
WOULD BE HOW DOES THE
TRANSITION TO THE NEW DISTRICT
STE DISTRIBUTOR RUN BOTTLE BILL
PROGRAM. HELP CONSTITUENTS AND
THEN ROLL DISTRICTS LIKE MINE-
AND HOW ARE THEY GONNA GET THE
RESEARCH DATA OR THEIR MONEY
BACK AND WHAT WHAT WOULD THAT
LOOK LIKE WE'RE HAVING
DIFFICULTIES AS IT IS. HAVING
PLACES TO TAKE KERR SAID SO
WHAT WHAT WE ENVISION IS THAT
THIS THIS PROGRAM WOULD COME
WOULD GO LIVE IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR SO THERE'S A
COUPLE. COUPLE OF SECTIONS THAT
GO ON IS SAID HE SAID ASSUMING
THE BILL GETS ENACTED GETS
APPROVED. THERE'S GOING TO BE A
DEMAND THAT. THE BUDGETS
SUBCOMMITTEE WHO'S IN CHARGE OF
RECYCLING IS GOING TO HAVE TO
PUT SOME MONEY OUT FOR THESE
HAULERS AND FOR THE- THIRD. I
RECYCLER SAID WE'VE HAD SOME IN.
WILL REMAIN BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURES
IMPLODING WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IS THAT THERE'S PROBABLY
WILL BE SOMEBODY'S REVERSE
VENDING MACHINES WHICH WILL GO
OUT FOR EARLY ADOPTERS THAT.
DID I WOULD IMAGINE GROCERY
STORES AND OTHER AREAS. FOR THE
RURAL CALIFORNIA I THINK WHICH
GET WHAT WE'RE GONNA SEE IS
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO. FRONT LOAD
SOMEBODY'S- THE DEPOSIT SITES
THIS COULD BE A DROP OF. AT A
DROP FORTUNE THAT. I'M SURE
WILL. BECOME FULL FLEDGED IN
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR BUT
IN THE INTERIM. I THINK THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE YOU KNOW
I'M I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING.
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY COLLECTING- RECYCLED
MATERIALS NOW SO THAT THEY CAN
STAY THEY CAN STAY IN BUSINESS
AND THEN AGAIN I. I'M NOT
MAKING THE DECISIONS HERE IS
GOING TO BE THE- THE
COOPERATIVE THAT'S PUT
TOGETHER- FOR WHO WHO THEY'RE
GONNA HIRE BUT I WANT TO HAVE
AS MANY PLAYERS. AVAILABLE THAT
THE BETTER PART OF THE-
ECOSYSTEM THAT WE KNOW IS
RECYCLING. IN MY LAST QUESTION
WOULD BE WHY VOTE TO MORE
ACTUALLY THE SO LAST YEAR WE
DID AB SEVENTY NINE THREE TEAM
WHICH- WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
CREATED THE WORLD'S HIGHEST
MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT RATE
FOR BEVERAGE CONTAINERS. WHICH
IS 50% BY TWENTY THIRTY HOW
DOES THIS BILL INTERACT WOULD
INTERACT WITH THOSE PENALTIES.
THAT WOULD BE ASSIGNED TO THE
MEETING THOSE OBLIGATIONS OF
SEVEN NINE THREE. WELL THIS
WILL HOPEFULLY WILL HELP TO
BECAUSE THE WEATHER YOU'RE A
GLASS BURBANK. REMANUFACTURING
OR PLASTIC REMANUFACTURING THEY
NEED SOME PRODUCT MEAN THAT THE
CHALLENGE IS GOING TO BE WITH
THE BLUES PEOPLE AND APPLYING
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT PART
OF THE SYSTEM SO THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO TRY TO SCRAPE
TOGETHER THE RAW MATERIAL TO
COLLECT IT IS BEING RECYCLED
AND I'M CONTINUING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH THOSE
FOLKS SO. IT'S AMERICA'S ME YOU
REMEMBER SB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
THAT I HAD TO FOUR YEARS AGO
THAT THAT WAS THE PRECURSOR
THAT THAT WAS APPROVED BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE THE ONE
OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY GET BECAME
A CONTENT BILL THE ASSEMBLY
pSTAFF REPORT. THEY REJECTED IT
AND MISTER KING TOOK IT IN A
CAN INCORPORATE INTO AN
ASSEMBLY BILL HAS THAT IS OFTEN
HAPPENS IN THIS AREA- SO THAT
WILL. BE THE MANUFACTURERS WILL
BE ABLE TO MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO BE HAVING MORE CLEAN
PRODUCT ANY IDEA WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT CONTAMINATION NO ONE OF
THE CAN CONTAMINATION BE
MAYONNAISE THE CONTAMINATION OF
PEACHES. OTHER TYPES OF GLASS
PRODUCTS IN THIS REALLY TAKES
OUT ALTER REALLY VALUABLE
PRODUCTS THAT WE USE FOR-
SPORTS BOTTLES AND WHATEVER AND
PUTS HIM SEPARATES. THEM INTO
A- STREAMED CAN BE RE. AND
MAKES THAT APPEAL TO THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TO MEET THE- MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT THROUGHOUT THE
DECADE. OKAY MY LAST QUESTION
WOULD BE DOES SB THIRTY EIGHT
HAVE ANY. MECHANISM TO PREVENT
AND ADDRESS POTENTIAL FOR FRAUD
FROM OTHER STATES COMING IN
ABSOLUTELY SEE WHAT HAPPENS
RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE DO BUT WE
MEASURE- THE RE DEPOSIT BY
WEIGHT AND YOU KNOW WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S GONNA HAVE TO
LEARN NOT TO SMASH THEIR
PLASTIC BOTTLES AND SMASH THE
CANS. BUT WE COULD HAVE A BAR
COURT CODE ON IT SO WHEN IT
GOES TO THE SMITH THESE MACHINE
THAT READS IT WHETHER IT'S A
REVERSE VENDING MACHINE- IS TO
SAY. YOU KNOW WHAT THE WHAT THE
ONE OF THE- OF FACILITIES TO
TAKE IT IT WILL READ THAT BAR
CODES WILL KNOW EXACTLY. WHO'S
WHO'S- BOTTLES AND CANS AND
CONTAINERS ARE BEING RECYCLED
WHO ARE TOO SO THERE'S GONNA BE
NO FRAUD ISN'T THIS THIS GUY-
COOPERATIVE ONCE IT'S SET UP
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SHUT THAT DOWN BECAUSE THE
MACHINES GET REJECTED IT'S NOT
GONNA TAKE IT. IS ARCHITECTED
THE BIT SO THIS IDEA OF
TRUCKLOADS OF CANS FROM
COLORADO COMING IN HERE IS
GOING TO BE DONE BECAUSE WE'RE
ONE YOU CAN'T SMASH IT YOU GOT
TO READ THAT BAR CODE AND TWO
TICKET YOU KNOW IT'S WHATEVER.
I'M NOT A TECH GUY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT TO SAY WITH THE BAR
CODE BUT THEY KNOW THAT THEY
CAN DO THAT SO THEY SAY OH THIS
IS PART OF THE THEN IN
CALIFORNIA SO. IT'S ONE OF. THE
EXTRA BENEFITS OF THIS PROGRAM.
THIRTY DOLLARS. S. THANK YOU
CENTER CASKET NOW YOU'VE WORKED
ON THIS FOR FAR TOO LONG SO I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED WORK BUT- IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IT MENTIONS
ELECTRONIC PAYMENTS- WITH.
EIGHTY ONE I'M SORRY I'M PAID
FOR ON PAGE TWENTY. ON WHETHER
THEY WOULD BE PERMITTED AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND THEN
ALSO WHAT TYPES OF PAYMENTS ARE
CONSIDERED IMMEDIATE. THE FIRST
TWO BULLET POINTS- WELL I MEAN
I ANTICIPATE THAT MOST OF THIS
IS GONNA BE ELECTRONIC-
TRANSFER IS WHEN WE SEE
IMMEDIATE THIS IS GOING TO MAKE
A CALCULATION AND YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE AN ACCOUNT THAT'S GONNA
BE SIX SET UP THROUGH YOUR BANK
OR THROUGH YOUR CHURCH OR
THROUGH YOUR SCHOOL OR AND YOU
COULD GET. AN AUTOMATIC I MEAN
I SEE IMMEDIATE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AND I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY
HOW HOW QUICKLY HE'S GONNA GET
IN BUT BUT- IT'S GOING TO BE A
CALCULATION THAT'S GOING TO BE
GONE AT ELECTRONICALLY THROUGH
OUR- BACK. ALL THAT ONE CASH.
AND THOSE THINGS THAT THAT CASH
IS STILL GOING TO BE AVAILABLE
I THINK THAT AGAIN WE'RE GONNA
LET THE STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM RUN
IT AND SET IT UP. BUT I THINK
THAT THAT THAT CASH IS STILL
KING IN CALIFORNIA. SO SOME
PEOPLE ARE GONNA WANT IT. WAS
DEFINITELY THANK YOU. OKAY.
ZERO BUT WE SHOULD ALL DO WITH
THE COMMITTEE TRIP UP THROUGH
CENTER DOLLARS DISTRICT AND- OF
IT GO OVER THE BORDER AND
OREGON AND SEE THE PROGRAM
THERE I'VE I'VE GOT A CHANCE TO
SEE IT IN THEM. AND YOU KNOW UP
IN PORTLAND WITH A PORTION OF
THE STATEMENTS IT'S VERY
INTERESTING TO SEE SO- NO
YOU'RE YOU'RE A COURSE. T. SAID
THAT WE CAN COORDINATE A LITTLE
HELP ON THE ON THE OTHER PEOPLE
TRYING TO GAME. THE SYSTEM BY
TRACK YOU ACROSS THE BORDER. IT
WAS WE'LL SEE WHERE THIS GOES
BUT- THE THIRD THIS TURNER WITH
THOUSAND ISLAND MOVIE ADAM OKAY
GREAT SO THE MOVED SEVENTY
DOLLARS IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
CENTER CASKEY. IT'S I'D LIKE TO
BORROW FROM THE CONSUMER
WATCHDOG'S EXECUTIVE SUMMARY-
THAT THEY CAME UP WITH WHAT
TRAVIS AND YOU KNOW RETENTION
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
CLOSING AND OF ALARMING RATE WE
KNOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN CUT IN
HALF THE CABINET. AND HAVE BEEN
BASICALLY CONSUMERS TODAY ARE
GETTING ABOUT HALF OF THE
NICKELS AND DIMES IS DEPOSIT
THE TICKET FEE THEY PAY ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION AND THEY GET
BACK ABOUT HALF OF THAT IN
UNDER THIS BILL IT WILL CHANGE.
AND THAT THE TAPE HE PAID TIME
YOU COULD GET THAT TIME BACK IN
THE AND THE PD PEOPLE TO
PRODUCE THE BOTTLES ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO MAKE UP THAT
DIFFERENCE. AND THEN WE KNOW
THAT CAL RECYCLE HAZARD A LOT
OF UNCLAIMED DEPOSITS RIGHT NOW
THAT THEY CAN USE AND WILL WORK
OUT WITH THAT ON THE BUDGET
SIDE BUT ONCE WE NEED A SYSTEM.
SET UP SENATE SOMETHING THE
CALIFORNIA BE PROUD ABOUT AND
WILL READ CAME OUR LEADERSHIP
ROLE IN RECYCLING THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD. AND AYE KHORCHIN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR KADAMBAS COLOR. I
THE NUMBERS SIX SB THIRTY BY
SENATOR WERE CAST THE MOTION IS
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALAN HI ALAN I BATES. DALLY
WROTE DALY NO GONZALEZ HI.
DOLLARS BY D. RESPECTFULLY
KNOWING I HAVE MORE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU. THOSE BATES SNOW
RESPECTFUL RECKLESS PLEASE NOTE
SKINNER STERN Y. CASKEY HI
CASKEY I. PART YEAH WE'RE GONNA
WE'RE GONNA HOLD IT OPEN- THANK
YOU MEMBERS OKAY LET'S NOW TURN
TO THE LONG. THE LONG
SUFFERING- CENTER PORTANTINO.
TO PRESENT HIS BILL THIS IS A
SB TWO THIRTY FIVE AND SEVEN
YEAR JANICE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I RESPECTFULLY
PRESENTING SB TWO THIRTY TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY THE
STATE WIDE CONSTITUENTS OF
EMERGING CONCERN DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM. WOULD REQUIRE THE
STATE RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
TO ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN AN
ONGOING DEDICATED CVC PROGRAM
TO IMPROVE THE UNDERSTANDING OF
THE OCCURRENCE IN DRINKING
WATER SOURCES CONSTITUENTS OF
EMERGING CONCERN OR CEC'S ARE
THEY AS THEY ARE KNOWN. OUR
DIVERSE GROUP OF SYNTHETIC OR
NATURALLY OCCURRING CHEMICALS
OR MICRO ORGANISMS THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY REGULATED IN DRINKING
WATER SCIENTISTS HAVE
DISCOVERED NEW WAYS TO DETECT
CECE'S IN VERY SMALL AMOUNTS IT
USED TO BE THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT MEASURING CHEMICALS IN
PARTS PER MILLION THAN PARTS
PER BILLION AND NOW WE CAN TO
DETECT DOWN TO PARTS PER
TRILLION. GIVEN THIS CAPABILITY
SCIENTISTS WILL CONTINUE TO
DETECT NEW UNREGULATED CC'S
THAT COULD INCLUDE
PHARMACEUTICALS PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS OUR INVESTOR CALL
INDUSTRIAL CHEMICALS IN TRACE
AMOUNTS. SB TWO THIRTY IS
DESIGNED TO HELP THE STATE
WATER BOARD GATHER INFORMATION
UNDERSTAND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
RISK OF THE CDC'S AND THEIR
OCCURRENCE IN DRINKING WATER
SUPPLIES THIS INFORMATION WOULD
HELP THE STATE WATER BOARD MAKE
INFORMED SCIENCE BASED
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO
PRIORITIZE THEM FOR REGULATION.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE STATE
WATER BOARD TO CREATE A SCIENCE
ADVISORY PANEL MADE UP OF
EXPERTS TO ADVISE THEM ON CEC'S
AND CREATES IN THE STATE
TREASURY SEC ACTION FUND. WHICH
UPON APPROPRIATION WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO SUPPORT PROGRAM I
UNDERSTAND THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL NGOS
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL FOR
SEVERAL SEVERAL MONTHS BUT THE
NGO STILL HAVE SOME OUTSTANDING
ISSUES. THOSE THOSE ARE IN NEED
THOSE ARE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
WHAT IS BEING PROPOSED WON'T
SLOW DOWN THE REGULATORY
PROCESS THAT THE BILL WOULD
EXCLUDE THE PAPHOS CHEMICAL
FROM THE DEFINITION OF CEC'S
BECAUSE OF THE COMPREHENSIVE
EFFORTS ALREADY UNDERWAY AT THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO STUDY AND
MAKE DECISIONS ON HOW TO
REGULATE. THOSE CHEMICALS I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF FOR MEETING WITH THE
WATER AGENCIES THIS WE EIGHT
MILE. IS TO SEE IF WE COULD
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS I'VE BEEN
ENCOURAGED TO LEARN THAT THE
AGENCIES HAVE AGREED TO EXCLUDE
P. FOX FROM THE BILL. AND THEY
PLAN TO KEEP WORKING WITH THE
NGOS ON LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT DELAYS IN
REGULATING SPECIES THAT POSE A
PUBLIC HEALTH RISK. SO I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THINGS WORK OUT
I'M- I THINK REMOVING P. FOSSE
WAS A GOOD STEP FORWARD I KNOW
THE CHAIR CONCURS WITH THAT
ANALYSIS. AND HOPEFULLY THAT
SHOULD SINCE WE'VE PRETTY MUCH
ADDRESSED MOST OF THE CONCERNS
HOPEFULLY- WITHDRAW SOME OF THE
CONCERNS FROM. THOSE WHO ARE
CONCERNED. ON THE PHONE TDAY
WE HAVE DANIELLE BLASTED HAYDEN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATIONS AND
KATHY. BATALHA WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I JUST AND
JUST TO CLARIFY IT SO IT'S
MINES SO THERE'S THE P. FUSS. I
EXCLUSION THE ISSUE OF LANGUAGE
TO LIMIT UNNECESSARY DELAYS AND
THEN THE OTHER THE OTHER BIG
ISSUE OF COURSE WAS INCLUDING
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ENSURE THE
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL. ARE TRULY
INDEPENDENT AND FREE FROM
CONFLICTS AND I THINK THAT
THEY'RE- THEY'RE WORKING ON ON
THE ISLAND ON A TWO YEAR OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHáVEZ. MR
AND CENTER PORTANTINO SO LET'S
LET'S NOW GO TO YOUR- THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I'M GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK YES. OKAY GREAT-
MY NAME IS DANIELLE BLASTED
HAYDN AND I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PLEASED TO
COSPONSOR SB TWO THIRTY AND
THANK SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THE SENATOR NOTED DETECTION
METHOD RECEIVE THESE CONTINUE
JUNKER AND SCIENTISTS CAN NOW
IDENTIFY THOUSANDS OF THEM AND
BRING WATER SOURCES IN THE
PARTS PER TRILLION. IT'S HARD
TO WHAT TO TACKLE FOR AND RIGHT
NOW. THE REGULATORY PROCESS TO
ESTABLISH DRINKING WATER
STANDARD CONSIDERED
CONTAMINANTS ONE BY ONE.
INSTEAD OF CONTINUING WITH WITH
A SCATTERSHOT APPROACH TO
IDENTIFY THE MOST APPROPRIATE
CT YOUR DIRECTOR REGULATE SB
TWO THIRTY WOULD CREATE A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM RECEIVED
THESE AND DRINKING WATER AT THE
STATE WATER BOARD. THIS PROGRAM
INCLUDING THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE SCIENCE
ADVISORY PANEL WHAT IDENTIFY
EVALUATE AND PRIORITIZE FOR
ACTION HE'D BE THE DRINKING
WATER SOURCES. AND IF NEEDED
PROACTIVELY FILL INFORMATION
GAPS. THE INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION IN THE PROGRAM IS
TO MORE EFFECTIVELY COORDINATE
EFFORTS ON FECES AND PROVIDE
MORE CERTAINTY TO CALIFORNIANS
THAT WATER AGENCIES. IT IS NOT
INTENDED TO DELAY OR OTHERWISE
CIRCUMVENT THE REGULATORY
PROCESS FOR ANY ACTION ON DEC.
WATER AGENCIES UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF DRINKING WATER
THAT IS SAFE AND RELIABLE AND
ARE COMMITTED. TO ENSURING
CALIFORNIANS. COMP IN THEIR
WATER SUPPLY. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING THE STATE THAT CANCER
THAT ARE. THEIR AFTER AND THE
OF THIS COMMITTEE. AND THE
CHAIR WE WILL OUR IN
CENTERPOINT COMMITMENT YOU
COULD IF YOU FAST CLASS OF
CHEMICALS FROM THE BILL AND ADD
LANGUAGE RELATED TO CONFLICT OF
INTEREST IS THAT GOOD FIRST
STEP. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR DISCUSSION. WE
ARE YOUR AYE VOTE. WE LOST OUR
CHAIR FOR REMAIN HERE GOOD
MORNING GOOD FOR THE NEXT ONE.
YEAH THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS KATHY
BEALE CAN'T BE A TELECOMMUTING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME KATHY INTEL
AND THE LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE SUPPLY WATER TO
TWENTY SEVEN MEMBER AGENCIES
WHICH IN TURN DIRECTLY OR
THROUGH THEIR STEP AGENCIES
PROVIDE WATER TO APPROXIMATELY
NINETEEN MILLION PEOPLE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND WE'VE
BEEN A PROVIDER OF HIGH QUALITY
RELIABLE DRINKING WATER THAT
MEETS OR EXCEEDS ALL FEDERAL
AND STATE STANDARDS FOR MORE
THAN EIGHTY YEARS. STAFF AT OUR
WATER QUALITY LAB AND TRY
DRINKING WATER TREATMENT PLANTS
WORK DILIGENTLY TO PROTECT
WATER QUALITY DELIVERED TO THE
CUSTOMERS. I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR TAKING
UP THIS ISSUE ON EMERGING
QUALITY CONCERNS IN CALIFORNIA
AT THE TOPIC THE METROPOLITAN'S
BOARD AND URBAN WATER AGENCIES
ARE FOCUSED ON FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE SENATOR. THE
APPROACH AND SB TWO THIRTY AT
THE WATER COMMUNITY SOLUTION TO
HELP THE STATE'S MOST FASTER TO
ADDRESS NEW. EMERGING
CONTAMINANTS THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY REGULATED. THE
LEGISLATION IS MEANT TO PROVIDE
THE STATE WATER BOARD ACCESS TO
INDEPENDENT SCIENTIFIC EXPERTS
HE'S TO HELP THEM PRIORITIZE. A
PROACTIVELY DEAL WITH G. EAZY
THAT THEY ARE DETECTED. THAT
WOULD SUPPORT SCIENTIFIC
STUDIES ON THE RISKS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AND OCCURRENCE. WHEN THE
NEW THESES ARE DETECTED THE
STATE CAN MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ABOUT WHICH ONES TO
PRIORITIZE FOR FURTHER ACTION.
I WANT TO THANK YOU CHAIR AND
STAFF AND SENATOR PORTANTINO
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
FOR MEETING WITH US AND TALKING
THROUGH THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL AS DESCRIBED. BY
SENATOR ALLEN EARLIER OF MY
COLLEAGUE POINTED OUT WE ARE
PREPARED TO MAKE CHANGES TO THE
LEGISLATION AND COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING OUR DISCUSSIONS.
ABOUT HOW BEST TO ADDRESS THESE
EMERGING DRINKING WATER QUALITY
ISSUES IN OUR STATE. THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR TIME AND I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR I.
TODAY. THANK YOU. ARE LET'S GO
TO. THE STAFF LINES I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN THE TWENTY FOUR YEAR
HERE WANT TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DOES MANY SUPPORT. OF FOLKS YOU
WANT TO ADD ON THEIR SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINES FOR SB. TWO
THIRTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO THIRTY THREE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO THIRTY. THREE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO NOW. THE
MESSAGE WE HAVE ABOUT TEN
PEOPLE IN Q. MY NUMBER FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL ARNOLD-
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MUCH NEEDED LEGISLATION ON
BEHALF OF THE THREE VALLEYS
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
FOR MY NUMBER ONE OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS RANG
AGAIN I CAN WITH COMPACT ON OUR
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MUCH NEEDED.
LEGISLATION TO HELP MAKE
PROGRESS ON RESTRUCTURING
AMERICAN CONCERNING WATER
THANKS. MY NUMBER ONE OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MINOR ON
BEHALF OF SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT AND EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT ALSO IN SUPPORT
FOR THAT REASON BY-
METROPOLITAN REPRESENTATIVE
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
BURKE THIS IS BEST- ALSO ON
BEHALF OF WATER REUSE
CALIFORNIA INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY AND CUCAMONGA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THOMAS CARS ON THE BLOCK GROUP
ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT LONG
BEACH WATER DEPARTMENT IT'S
PART OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER FORTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR ALLEN MEMBERS
SORRY IVERSON A PRESENT IN THE
LAS VIRGENES MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT NAY TRAMPLE SANITATION
DISTRICT HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE OH SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS STEVE BAKER WAS
APPARENTLY TO ASSOCIATES FOR
THE UPPER SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER AGENCY IN
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER ONE TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ADAM KIANA SOME BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
REPRESENTING- OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER FIFTY ONE THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS GREG MORRISON WITH ELSE ARE
VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE TWELVE ONE IS OPENED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIGHT BILL IN
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
LET COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO THIRTY OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO- FOLKS WHO
WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS
OPPOSITION I THINK NIKITAS-
HERE WITHIN OUR DC IN AND THEN
ENTER VENTURA FROM A CLEAN
WATER ACTION. HI THERE THIS IS
ACTUALLY OUT OF THE CAR FROM RV
OKAY- I'M DOING THE SPEAKING
YES THANK YOU. I COULD AGAIN
THOUSAND STARTED TOP GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS AVINASH KAR
I'M A SENIOR. AND DIRECTOR FOR
STATE HEALTH POLICY WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. HE HAS A LONG HISTORY
OF WORKING ON TOPICS AND TOXINS
IN YOUR WATER. I WANT TO START
BY TAKING THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR PORTANTINO
AND THE SPONSORS FOR ENGAGING
WITH OUR CONCERNS. WE
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING DIALOGUE
AND A COMMITMENT TO EXCLUDE THE
CLASS OF BEHALF CHEMICALS IN
THE AND THAT OF SAID SB TWO
THIRTY. AND TO ENSURE THAT
ANYBODY CONVENE AND THIS BILL
IS TRULY INDEPENDENT. AND
CREATE A CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
WELL WE REMAIN FORMALLY OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. WE ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE BILL
MOVING. FORWARD WILL BE
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. LANGUAGE TO. THAT
WE CAN COMMITMENTS MADE BY THE
SPONSORS AND AUTHOR. AS WELL AS
CONTINUING PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT TIMELINE TO
ENSURE THAT ONE BUT BILL TO
THEM FOR THE SLOW DOWN THE
ALREADY SLOW PROCESS. OF
REGULATING HARMFUL CHEMICALS IN
DRINKING WATER IN CALIFORNIA.
AND TO THAT ANY SCIENTIFIC
PANEL CAN BE INTO STRUCTURED TO
BEST HELP THE WATER BOARD- YES
OUR TECHNICAL AND SCIENTIFIC
QUESTIONS THAT IS NOT ALREADY
HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
ASSISTANCE TO ADDRESS. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. YOU. LET'S GO TO
ANDREA. MODERATORS ENTER THEIR-
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MA'AM. I'M
SORRY CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES
WE CAN WE CAN HEAR YOU LANDLER.
OKAY I'M SORRY MIGHT MY PROP MY
FAULT ON MY PHONE PHOTO- GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ANDREA EVAN TURNER I FIND THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND I ALSO HAD OUR
TOXICS PROGRAM. AND ARE YOU
ALSO WANT TO START BY
APPLAUDING THE DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICES AND SPONSORS- OVER THIS
BILL. FOR THE PAST YEAR IN THE
HOPE OF COMING TO AGREEMENT WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
EFFORTS IN RECENT DAYS ON THE
P. FATS ISSUE. WHICH WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT TO US- HOWEVER I HAVE
WORKED ON DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS. AND BASED
ON THAT LONG EXPERIENCE- WE ARE
NOT IN A POSITION RIGHT NOW AT
THIS TIME TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
DESPITE WHAT WE BELIEVE ARE IN
FACT ITS GOOD INTENTIONS. BUT
TWENTY WATER. PROGRAM I'M IN
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
SCIENTIFICALLY ROBUST IN THE
NATION. IN ADDITION THE STATE
BOARD ALREADY HAS THE
CONTAMINANTS OF EMERGING
CONCERN. PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
RECYCLED WATER PROGRAM. AND
THAT ALREADY IS LOOKING AT
DRINKING WATER GIVEN THE
STATE'S GOALS AROUND USING
RECYCLED WATER FOR POTABLE
PURPOSES. NO CLEAN WATER ACTION
HAS ALWAYS SUPPORTED THE
SCIENTIFIC BASIS OF OUR
REGULATORY PROCESS. DESPITE THE
FACT THAT IT DOES SLOW DOWN
REGULATIONS WHILE CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUE TO. DRINK CONTAMINATED
WATER. BUT IT'S BEEN OUR
EXPERIENCE THAT REGULATIONS CAN
OFTEN TAKE OVER A DECADE TO
FINALIZE. AND THAT IS PARTIALLY
DUE TO THE MONITORING FOR
CONTAMINANTS OF EMERGING
CONCERN. THE HELP ANALYSIS DONE
BY A WE HA THE ECONOMIC
ANALYSES DONE BY THE STATE
WATER BOARD THE PEER REVIEWS
AND THE PUBLIC COMMENT THAT
INFORM ALL OF OUR DECISION
MAKING. GIVEN THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE SUCH A STRONG PROGRAM TO
IDENTIFY. DRINKING WATER
CONTAMINANTS AND TO ULTIMATELY
IF NECESSARY REGULATE THEM. WE
FEEL THIS PROGRAM WOULD SERVE
TO IN FACT. THOUGH
UNINTENTIONALLY- THERE'S A SLOW
DOWN NEEDED PROTECTIONS FOR THE
PUBLIC AND IT WOULD ALSO STREAM
RESOURCES BOTH FINANCIAL AND IN
TERMS OF STAFF TIME AND ENERGY
CASH NOW WE DID SUBMIT A LETTER
ON THIS BILL. WITH AN IMPACT
WITH THE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. BECAUSE OF OUR
RESPECT FOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
FOR THE SPONSORS AND FOR THE
DIALOGUE THAT'S BEEN GOING ON.
WE COULD PERHAPS SUPPORT A
PROGRAM THAT EXPANDS THE
CURRENT STATE BOARDS EASY
PROGRAM TO LOOK AT NON DRINKING
WATER ISSUES. THAT ARE NOT AS
WELL SUPPORTED SCIENTIFICALLY
AS IS THE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM- AS IT IS CONCEIVED AS
PART OF THE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM THOUGH- RIGHT NOW WE DO.
AT BILL IS SOMEWHAT. AND IN. OF
ON AND DELAY AND- I THIS MOMENT
WE CAN THE- WE WILL. TO
DIALOGUE- GET THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RICHARD AND I AND I DO ALSO
WANT TO I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY INVOLVED FOR- FOR YOU
KNOW FIRST I DO WANT TO I WANT
TO GENERALLY THINK DEPOSITION
FOR BRINGING UP WHAT I THOUGHT
WERE SOME VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS
I'M I'VE BEEN DEEPLY INVOLVED
WITH THE PEACE PROCESS US FOLKS
NOW WE DID A BILL LAST YEAR ON.
FIREFIGHTER FOAM AND- YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS WILLINGNESS TO. TO
TAKE. BECAUSE OF THE BILL
BECAUSE THE UNIDADE DEFIANCE IS
NOT AN EMERGING AREA OF CONCERN
IS AN ESTABLISHED AND PRETTY
WELL KNOWN AREA OF CONCERN. AND
THE CONTAMINANTS SIDE AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I
WORK SO CLOSELY WITH THE
SPONSORS LAST YEAR TO TRY TO.
HELP PRODUCE. AN IMPORTANT
SOURCE OF P. FOR US IN OUR IN
OUR GROUND WATER SYSTEM. HAVE
BEENOBVIOUSLY VERY MUCH ALSO I
HEAR THE CONCERNS ABOUT. ABOUT
DELAYING ABOUT CONFLICTS AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE- MANY REASONS
WHY WE ALSO ARE WORKING ON.
LANGUAGE IN THOSE TWO AREAS TOO
SO ANYWAY- OTHER FOLKS WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
PEOPLE ON ON THE CALLS I. IT'S
NOT MY UNDERSTANDING THERE IS
ANYONE BUT- DESIRE TO ENSURE
THAT. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO THIRTY PRESS ONE ZERO.
WE WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. LET COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN LOOK LIKE NO ONE IS
SHOWING UP. AND OKAY GREAT-
LET'S NOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
DISCUSSION AND A THIRTY DOLLAR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO. ASK A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHORIZED THIS IS AN AREA I
DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND SO I
JUST NEED SOME CLARIFICATION ON.
UNTIL HOW DOES THAT. THE CC
BOARD. WHAT'S THE THAT PROCESS
I GUESS FOR QUALIFYING TO BE
SOMEBODY WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO
SIT ON THIS. I'M ASSUMING IT'S
A BOARD IT'S A PANEL. YEAH
THAT'S WHAT IT IS WHAT MY IT'S
A COMMITTEE OF EXPERTS
SCIENTIFIQUES SCIENTISTS AND
EXPERTS I THINK THE ANALYSIS
THAT OUTLINES. THE SELECTION
PROCESS AND I THINK THAT THE
OPPOSITION'S BIGGEST CONCERN IS
THAT THEY- ARE FREE OF
CONFLICTS AND OF COURSE I
SUPPORT THAT SO IT'S- IT'S
BASICALLY EMPOWERING SCIENTISTS
TO GET AHEAD OF. THESE EMERGING
CONCERNS AND CREATING A PROCESS
WITH A FUNDING SOURCE TO DO
THAT. OKAY THANK YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS FROM THE COMMITTEE NO
OKAY- FOR YEP WE GOT CLOSER
YEAH I JUST APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS. IMPORT YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY FROM THE AND RDCS
PERSPECTIVE WE TOOK THEIR
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS WERE
WORKING ON IT- I'M PLEASED THAT
THEY'RE ENCOURAGING THE BILL TO
MOVE FORWARD I HOPE AS THEY SEE
THE AMENDMENTS IN PRINT THEY'LL
FORMALLY WITHDRAW THEIR
OPPOSITION BECAUSE I. I THINK
WE ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT THEY
RAISED- YOU KNOWWE'VE ALL
MARCH FOR SCIENCE WE'VE ALL
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING SCIENCE INTEGRATE WITH
PUBLIC POLICY. AND HERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT TO GET
AHEAD OF CONTAMINANTS AS WE GET
BETTER AT DETECTING THEM AND SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. YOU HAVE
MISTER MOTION FOR THE CASE AND
WOOD COUNTY. OF THAT AREA OF
THE CITY PROCEED YOU AND
SENATOR AND- YOU KNOW WE
OBVIOUSLY IN THE END OF THE DAY.
THERE A THERE'S A STRUGGLE- YOU
KNOW THE WATER AGENCIES
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO. PROVIDE SAFE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER THEY ALSO
HAVE A- YOU KNOW VESTED
INTEREST IN IN MAKING SURE THAT
HAPPENS AT THE SAME TIME THERE
ALSO ARE REGULATED ENTITY AND
NOBODY LOVES TO BE REGULATED AS
WE'VE HEARD MANY TASKS. CENTER
DOLLY IN OTHERS AND SO AND THE
OTHER QUESTION HERE IS HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE REALLY ARE
KEEPING THE PUBLIC SAFE AND-
THAT THIS DOESN'T BECOME SOME
SORT OF MECHANISM FOR SLOWING
DOWN. I REGULATIONS THAT'S
NEEDED TO PROTECT PEOPLE- HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T
END UP ON SENDING BACK ARE ARE
ARE. ARE VERY INTENSE EFFORTS
TO TRY TO IMPROVE DRINKING
WATER YOU KNOW FOLKS LIKE CLEAN
WATER ACTION ENERGY SEEN OTHERS
OF WORKS OF ART ON SO. THAT'S
THE KEY THING HERE BUT YES IF I
MAY WE'RE ALL CONSUMERS. YEP
YOU KNOW AND SO I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THAT WE WANT SAFE
DRINKING WATER NOT JUST FOR
OURSELVES BUT FOR OUR CHILDREN
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND YEAH. I
THINK WE ALL SHARE THAT GOAL-
AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
THEIR- KIDS. SHOULD THAT CENTER.
THE SUPERVISOR CARE. A
SECRETARY I. CAN WITH CARL. I
NUMBER SO. S. B. TWO THIRD BY
SO. PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN. HI ALLEN
AYE BATES FIVE EIGHT FIVE
DOLLY. DALI I AND SALAS HI
SALAS HI SKINNER STERN BY
CASKEY BY. BY AYE THE- AND
WE'RE HOLD THAT OPEN FOR THE
OTHER MEMBERS AND BUT THANK YOU
SENATOR. I APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AS WELL AS WE GET
THROUGH OUR AGENDA HERE OKAY
AND I SEE CENTER RUBIO HERE TO
PRESENT ITEM. NUMBER. EIGHTY TO
SEVENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READING CENTER.
THE MEASURE. GOOD MORNING
MORNING SEVEN BUCKS NOT EVEN
MORNING ANYMORE AND IF CITY
GOOD AFTERNOON YES SAID SITE
RUN A LITTLE LONG BUT THANK YOU
MISTER TERRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AT TODAY I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT SB FOUR TWENTY SIX-
LIKE THE CHAIR AND I HAVE BEEN
IN CONVERSATION AND HE'S ASKED
ME TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDER FOR TOP FULLY
COMMITTED TO DOING SO THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT BILL BECAUSE SB
FOUR TWENTY SIX WILL DIRECT THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO PRODUCE
AND RELEASE FINANCIAL
CAPABILITY ASSESSMENT
GUIDELINES FOR MS FOUR PERMIT
EASE. BY JULY TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY TWO THE STATE GUIDELINES
WOULD BE MODELED AFTER THE U.
S. EPA GUIDELINES DEVELOPED
OVERLAPPED THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS WRITTEN GUIDELINES ARE
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURING EQUITY
AND TRANSPARENCY PARTICULARLY
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WHICH ARE AFFORDED THE BENEFIT
OF AN OPEN PROCESS AND OTHER
STATES SMALL DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN OUR DISTRICTS
HAPPEN FINANCIALLY STRESSED
WITH THE M. S. FOR PERMITTING
COMPLIANCE COST AND MANY CITIES
DO NOT HAVE A DEDICATED
REVENUE. TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO MANAGE THIS WHAT THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN OF THE
PANDEMIC THE SMALL CITIES ARE
EVEN. MORE STRESS AND NEED OUR
HELP. THIS BILL HOW NOT MADE IT
TO THE FOR LINE IN PAST YEARS
DUE TO THE ASSURANCES BY THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO GET THEM
DONE. HOWEVER IT'S BEEN THREE
YEARS AND CITIES ARE STILL
WAITING FOR THESE GUIDELINES TO
BE HELPFUL TO THEM. SB FOUR
TWENTY SIX IS ESSENTIAL TO
ASSIST CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
COMPLYING WITH THE CLEAN WATER
ACT. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE- MIGHT MY WITNESS IF
I MAY. I'D IS DIANE I'M NOT
MOVED MAYOR OF SOUTH PASADENA
AND VICE CHAIR OF THE WATER
COMMITTEE THE SANK YOU'RE A
VALLEY COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR RUBIO GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS I AM
SOUTH PASADENA MERIT DIANA
MAHMUD REPRESENTING THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS. AT THE SPONSOR OF
SB FOUR TWENTY SIX. THIS BILL
WOULD DIRECT THE STATE WATER
BOARD AS THE ADMINISTRATOR OF
STORMWATER PERMIT IN
CALIFORNIA. UNDER THE FEDERAL
CLEAN WATER ACT. TO ADOPT
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY ASSESSMENT
GUIDELINES BY JULY TWENTY
TWENTY Q. THE STATE GUIDELINES
WOULD BE MODELED ON U. S. EPA
GUIDELINES DEVELOPED OVER THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS. AN UPDATED
LAST YEAR. THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES PROVIDED TRANSPARENT
METHODOLOGY FOR ASSESSING LOCAL
AGENCY FINANCIAL CAPABILITY.
SUPPORT THE COST OF CLEAN WATER
ACT COMPLIANT. IN DETERMINING
AFFORDABILITY THE GUIDELINES
ALSO REQUIRE STORMWATER PERMIT
ISSUING AUTHORITY. TO CONSIDER
THE COST OF COMPLIANCE WITH
WASTE WATER AND DRINKING WATER
REQUIREMENTS. SO THAT THE TOTAL
COST OF WATER RELATED SERVICES.
CAN BE CONSIDERED IN A
COMPREHENSIVE MANNER. IT'S A
FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR STORMWATER.
PERMIT COMPLIANCE RIGHT. OR TO
BILITY TRUST THE GUIDE ARE. THE
PERMIT AGENT TO ESTABLISH
REASON TIME FRAMES FOR PERMIT
COMPLY. IS SPORTS LOCAL EIGHT
TIME TO SECURE OR OTHER FUNDING
BUT- SALUTE PRODUCTION- AND-
THE FEDERAL. DO NOT A CALLOUSED.
SB FOUR TWENTY SIX MONTHLY
CALLS THE STATE BOARD ISSUE AS-
FACTOR. THE CALIFORNIA. ARE
FORGET THE SAME AS JIMMY MAGEE.
IMPORTANT S. B. TWENTY DOES NOT
ALTER EMPLOYEE COMPLY WITH
NATIONAL OR STATE CLEAN WATER
QUALITY. COMPLIANT COSTS ARE
SIGNIFICANT FOR. COMMUNITY IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN U. S.
CONFERENCE OF MAYORS THE CLAIM
WATER ACT AFFORDABILITY EXTRA
OF MORE THAN THIRTY HOURS STATE.
THOSE STATE. PERCENT OR MORE
HOUSE. SIXTY THE- COST
THRESHOLD INDICATES AND IT'S-
BURDEN WHICH FALLS. HARD OUR
DISTRICT COMMUNITIES NOTABLY IN
MARCH TWENTY. THIS AUDITOR A-
HI TO SPEAK AND READ WATER
BOARDS THEY MUST DO MORE. TO
ENSURE THAT LOOK JURORS COST
REDUCE POLLUTION ARE NECESSARY
AND APPROPRIATE AMONG OTHER
THINGS IT RECOMMENDED THE STATE
WATER BOARD DEVELOP GUIDANCE BY
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
DOCUMENT ESTIMATES OF THE COST
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WANT HER TO
COMPLY WITH THEIR STORMWATER
PERMITS. WE HAVE YET TO RECEIVE
SUCH GUIDELINES. SB FOUR TWENTY
SIX WILL PROVIDE A RATIONAL AND
UNIFORMED ACTED FOR CALCULATING
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY TO ACHIEVE
CLEAN WATER ACT COMPLIANCE
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING WATER
QUALITY WE APPRECIATE SENATOR
RUBIO'S LEADERSHIP IN
INTRODUCING SB FOUR TWENTY SIX.
AND RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR. I
THOUGHT. AMOR ALRIGHT LET'S NOW
GO TO- I I'M NOT A ON DOES THE
IN THAT OR SUPPORT OR SO FOR
THIS ON PHYSICALLY SO LET'S GO
TO THE FOR LINES ANYONE WANTS
TO ADD ONS OF FOR THIS BILL. I
BEFORE TWENTY. ON THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR TWENTY SIX PRESS ONE ZERO.
RIGHT WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
EVEN MY NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR TWENTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE IN THEIR- NOW. ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIRMAN LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ABOUT TWO PEOPLE QUEUING
UP. LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL ARNOLD REPRESENTING THE
THREE VALLEYS MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. MY
NUMBER FORTY ONE ONE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRY MEMBERS THIS IS JULIE
ALL OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
APOLOGIES FOR BEING UNABLE TO
SUBMIT OUR LETTER IN TIME TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AT THIS TIME OF THE TERM
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU MA'AM HONOR OKAY
LET'S NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
ANYONE ONE INVOICE. OPPOSITION
ON THE FRONT LINES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR TWENTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER AND
PUT YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR TWENTY
SIX PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO NOW.
MOMENT IS THE CHAIR. AT THE
MOMENT THE CHIRLA TECHNO WANTED
TO END UP IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR TWENTY SIX. OKAY ARE LET'S
NOW MOVE TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND DISCUSSION. UNDER
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANYTHING
THEY WANT TO RAISE OUR ISSUES.
YES CENTER CASKEY I'LL GO ASK
THE QUESTION I'M ON PAGE TEN OF
THE ANALYSIS AND THEY'RE SAYING
THAT THE- STATE BOARD ALREADY
HAS THE ABILITY TO ADJUST THE
COMPLIANCE TIME FRAMES NOW AND
IF THEY DO IT. A BILL THIS
THERE IS ALREADY AN ESTABLISHED
TIME FRAME AND THAT THIS.
ADDITIONAL ASSESSMENTS WOULD
ADD LITTLE TO THE VALUE TO
THIS- CAN YOU. ELIMINATE ON
THAT THANK YOU FOR ASKING THE
QUESTION AT THIS TIME IF I MAY
I WILL TURN OVER TO MY- MIGHT
WITNESS A DIANA MACLEOD TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION FOR YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS NO
METRICS- FOR THE STATE WATER
BOARD AND THIS IS A REAL
PROBLEM THERE ARE VERY SPECIFIC.
TRANSLUNAR CANONIC METRIX'S BY
INDICATED- THE EPA THE USEPA
GUIDELINES. ALSO CONSIDERED THE
COST OF DRINKING WATER QUALITY
COMPLIANCE AS WELL AS
WASTEWATER QUALITY COMPLIANCE
CURRENTLY THERE'S NOTHING THAT
I AM AWARE OF IN THE STATE
WATER- BOARD REGULATIONS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE FOR THAT. BUT
METRICS ARE ESTABLISHED THAT
LOOK AT FOR EXAMPLE. WHAT ARE
THE DEMOGRAPHICS WHAT ARE THEIR
INCOME LEVELS IT PROVIDES
SPECIFICITY TO GUIDE. THE STATE
WATER BOARD SHOWS THAT THERE
CAN BE UNITS FORMED. THAT THERE
WOULD BE A UNIFORM AND RATIONAL
BASIS FOR DETERMINING- WHAT IS
IN FACT A REASONABLE TIME FRAME
FOR COMPLIANCE. AND THE
COMPLIANCE COSTS ARE QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY IN CALIFORNIA ARE
LOS ANGELES REGIONAL WATER
QUALITY BOARD- THE LAST PERMIT.
THAT WAS ISSUED WITHIN TWENTY
TWELVE. L. A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC WORKS AT THAT TIME
ESTIMATED THAT THE COST OF
COMPLIANCE- THE TOTAL COST OF
COMPLIANCE WHEREAS ESTIMATED AT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS- DENTURE
BREATH TESTAMENT WHICH IS WHY I
DIDN'T INCLUDE IT IN MY
TESTIMONY BUT IT GIVES YOU.
SOME IDEA OF THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE COSTS THAT WE'RE SPEAKING
OUT. AND PARTICULARLY AS MANY
COMMUNITIES ARE FINANCIALLY
CHALLENGED IN THE WAKE. OF- OF
PANDEMIC AND ECONOMIC I'M
DISTRESSED HAS BEEN SUFFERED BY
OUR COMMUNITIES WERE ANXIOUSLY
AWAITING THE ISSUANCE OF THE
NEW PERMIT BY THE REGIONAL
WATER QUALITY BOARD WHICH WILL
BE ISSUED WE BELIEVE SOMETIME
BY. MID YEAR TO ASCERTAIN JUST.
WHAT ADDITIONAL. I'M CLIENTS
REQUIREMENTS WERE BASED. THE
REASON I ASK IS YOU KNOW IN THE
BAY AREA I KNOW THE THERE ARE
YOU KNOW ARMY. HAVE ECONOMICS
IS STILL HUNTERS OUT WHAT THE
PANDEMIC AND THEY'VE GOT A TO
COMPLY WITH THEM THEIR BY THAT
THE REGIONAL BOARD THE NICO.
THE REASONABLE TAPPED IN THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO EXTEND THAT
THAT PERIOD OF TIME SO AGAIN
THE STAFF ANALYSIS IS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ONE SIZE FITS ALL IN
OTHER THREE M. THAT IS IN FOR A-
IS. BUT WE STILL HAVE THESE YOU
KNOW THESE PERMITS THAT WE WANT
TO HAVE ISSUE ONE HAVE TO
DELIVERY RIGHT. WHETHER IT'S
TIME SO- IT I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN SOME DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN
THE CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR ON
THIS AND THIS THING BUT YOU
KNOW WE WILL FIGHT. I'M
CONCERNED THAT WE GET IT RIGHT
AND WE AND WE AND WE DO THE
ADJUSTMENTS WERE- WE GIVE THE
GUIDANCE THE REGIONAL BOARD
THAT IS. I GUESS WANTING IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT I
HAVEN'T HEARD IT FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO JUST WANT TO
RESET POINT. NO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONCERN AND IT'S VALID AND
I HAVE THE SAME CONVERSATION
WITH THE CHAIR AND- AND WE ALL
WANT THIS TO BE DONE AND A FAIR
EQUITABLE WAIT WAIT WAIT AND IF
THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO
CIRCUMVENT COMPLIANCE SAID
THESE ARE. COMMUNITIES I WANT
TO COMPLY THEY JUST NEED A
LITTLE BIT OF HELP. BUT AS I
COMMITTED TO THE TO THE CHAIR I
WILL CONTINUE TO. TALK TO
STAKEHOLDERS AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING IT IN AN
APPROPRIATE WAY. THANK YOU.
WE'RE IN CAN I ASK- WELL ON
THOSE LINES THAT YOU. THE YOU
INCLUDED SOME ATROCITIES. THE
OFFICE IN THOSE. IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AS WELL BECAUSE I
YOU KNOW I KNOW I KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO SOME EXTENT YOU'RE
ENGAGING IN A- CONVERSATION
WITH YOU KNOW SOME FOLKS TO THE
BOARD OF THE MINISTRATION OVER
THE OVER THE DM. YEAH THE PACE
OF THEIR WORK AND- THE
RESPONSIVENESS AND- AND THAT'S
THAT'S A WITH YOU KNOW THAT'S A
THAT'S A PART OF MOTIVATION
BEHIND THE BILL SO I SEE YOU
CAN GAUGE- CENTER CASKETS
WELLNESS DISCUSSIONS ABSOLUTELY
I WELL AND JUST TO ADD TO THAT
I HAVE YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID
TOPIC YEAH WE- DID THAT CITIES
KEEP CALLING ME IN TERMS OF
JUST THE STRESS THAT THIS IS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO. ENSURE THAT IT GETS
DONE AND SO I'LL TAKE BOTH OF
YOUR KIND CONCERNS INTO
CONSIDERATION AND I WILL UPDATE
YOU ALSO AS WELL AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THE PROCESS. OKAY OKAY
THE- REMOVED CENTER DOLLY-
CONTROL PLEASE CALLER I WOULD
CLOSER SO SORRY. WE'VE YOUR RBG.
OUTFIT BUT AS I SAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO RBG THAT'S WHY
WE'RE WEARING THE COLLAR AND
HER HONOR BOB I THINK YOU AND
JUST WITH THAT JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU THANK YOU I
THINK BY THE WAY I THINK CENTER
SKINNER. RBG MASK WHICH YOU
KNOW THE LEASE. OF GREAT ALL
RIGHT SO AT THE CONCERT WITH
CHOLERA ON THIS IS OUR SB FOUR
TWENTY SIX ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
FOUR TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR
RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN. HI ALLEN AYE BATES BATES
AYE DOLLY AYE DALY AYE GONZALEZ
HI SALAS I SKINNER STERN. WHY
CASTING. HI HOUSE I'D- FIVE
WILL THAT OPEN FOR THE OTHER.
THANK YOU THAT ON PARTY
MEMBERS- WE'RE GOING TURN IT
BACK TO OUR CHAIR OF FOR ME TO.
WHAT IS THE LAST BILL THE DAY.
SO WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE ALMOST
MADE IT. TWO MINUTES OKAY AND
THIS ONE I WILL SAY HOPEFULLY
IF I WERE TO BE RESENTING IT
LAST YEAR THEY WERE THE MORE
DISCUSSION HOPEFULLY WITH THE
WEED WE GOT SO MANY OF THE
ISSUES RESOLVED LAST YEAR- WE
NEGOTIATED THIS BILL AND IN THE
IN THE OPPOSITION MOVE TO
NEUTRAL- AND SO. BOB RECEIVED
IT WOULD COVER THE REST WE USED
IN MOVIES LAST YEAR BUT HERE WE
ARE. SO THIS IS THIS IS FIVE OH
TWO SERVICER THIS IS A MESSAGE
OF THE GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM.
AND THERE WAS A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME OUT
FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE ADDRESSING WEAKNESSES
IN THE CURRENT GREEN CHEMISTRY
PROGRAM. IN ORDER TO ADD TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM THE
TOXIC CHEMICALS IN THEIR DAILY
LIVES AND HISTORY CHEMISTRY
PROGRAM. WHAT'S START UP A LONG
TIME AGO TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT- AND I RECOGNIZE THAT
SOMETIMES CALIFORNIANS ARE
UNKNOWINGLY EXPOSED TO.
HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS IN THE
PRODUCTS THAT THEY USE AND THE
YOU KNOW THE IDEA WAS THAT THE
PROGRAM IS GOING TO USE THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND
CLEAR TRANSPARENT. REGULATORY
PROCESSES OF A START UP THIS
PROGRAM SAID FOR CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM. AND THE
PROGRAM IDENTIFIES. ARE
CHEMICALS OF CONCERN. AND THEN-
FINDS PRODUCTS WHERE THE USE OF
THOSE CHEMICALS COULD BE
AFFECTING CONSUMERS AND THEN
CALLS UPON THE MANUFACTURERS TO
PERFORM. WHAT'S CALLED AN
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS. TO FIND
SUBSTITUTES. SOUTHEND'S
ANALYSIS ALLOWS BUSINESSES TO
TAKE THE FIRST CUT AT
DETERMINING THE BEST WAY TO
ADDRESS THE HAZARDS PRODUCED-
BE OPPOSED BY THE KENNEDY
CHEMICALS IN THEIR PRODUCTS AND
THEN- THERE'S A THERE'S A
REGULATORY RESPONSE FROM FROM
THE DEPARTED TALKS SUB'S TO SEE
WHICH ON INCLUDES OPTIONS SUCH
AS LIMITING THE USE OF THE
CHEMICAL OR REQUIRING GREATER
DISCLOSURE. AND THE REGULATORY
RESPONSE ULTIMATELY BASED ON
HOW FAR A MANUFACTURER GOES IN
REDESIGNING OR RE FORMULATING A
PRODUCT TO BE SAFER. NOW HERE'S
THE PROBLEM SO SOUNDS GREAT
RIGHT. AFTER TWELVE YEARS.
THURMOND NOW THIRTEEN YEARS OF-
IN IN IN IN PLACE NOT A SINGLE
CHEMICAL NORD OR NOT A PRODUCT
COMPANIES IN HAS EVER BEEN
SUBJECT TO THE REGULATORY
RESPONSE. UNDER THE FRAMEWORK.
SO THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY SLOW AND IT'S PARTLY
DUE TO DATA GAPS THAT HINDER
INFORMED DECISION MAKING. AND
THE INABILITY OF THE DEPARTMENT
TO IDENTIFY CHEMICALS IN
PRODUCTS WITHOUT DIRECTLY
TESTING THEM OR DOING VERY TIME
CONSUMING SEARCHES OR REQUESTS.
FOR DATA SO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE LOOKED AT THIS
QUESTION WHY IS IT THAT YOU HAD
TEN YEARS AND NOW IT'S TWELVE
THIRTEEN YEARS AND THERE'S SO
LITTLE TO SHOW. FOR WHAT
PROMISED TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND THEY CAME OUT WITH
THESE THESE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY STREAMLINED
PROCESS THESE GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT THE AUTHORITY TO
COLLECT ESSENTIAL. PRODUCT
INGREDIENT DATA SO WHAT IS THE
BILL DOING GRANTS THE
DEPARTMENT CLEAR AUTHORITY TO
OBTAIN PRODUCT INGREDIENT DATA
FROM MANUFACTURERS AND IF
NEEDED FROM THE CHEMICAL
SUPPLIERS. IT REQUIRES DGSE TO
ADOPT A SEVEN YEAR TIMELINE TO
IDENTIFY AND ASSESS FIVE
PRIORITY PRODUCTS. IT
STREAMLINES THE INFORMAL
RESOLUTION AN APPEALS PROCESS
SEES AND IT CREATES A FAST
TRACK FOR WIN EXISTING HIGH
QUALITY STUDIES SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT MOVING QUICKLY TO
REGULATORY RESPONSE. TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH SO WE FIRST
INTRODUCED THE BILL LAST
SESSION WE WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. TO ADDRESS ALL
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPONENTS OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THE CHEMICAL.
INDUSTRY WERE CONCERNED- BUT WE
REALLY WORK WITH THEM TO ENSURE
THAT WE- ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS
WHILE STILL KEEPING OUR EYES ON
THE PRIZE- IN IT WITH REGARDS
TO OUR OUR NEEDS TO ADDRESS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERN SO I'M
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE. THAT WE REINTRODUCED
HERE REFLECTS THE COMPROMISE
REACHED BETWEEN ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. THAT'S A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH TO IMPROVE THE
PROGRAM IN PUBLIC HEALTH. AND I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE A CAR
FROM IN OUR DC AND ANDREA
VENTURA FOR WILL. CLEAN WATER
ACTION YOU MAY RECOGNIZE THEM
FROM THE- RIVAS BILL- AND HERE
TO STAY N SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ARE THEY ONLINE MADAM MODERATOR.
HI GOOD ENSURE HEAR ME. YES HOW
GREAT I MEAN SURE NUMBER IS THE
KEY TO CREDIT WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL SORRY
FOR PUTTING THAT MONEY AGAIN- I
DON'T HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
WORKING ON TOXIC ISSUES OUR
WORK IS FOCUSED ON ELIMINATING
HUMAN EXPOSURE TO TOXIC
CHEMICALS AND ON LOGGING
PROGRAMS TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES
FROM THE MOST HARMFUL
CHEMICALS. CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM IS AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT OF THE DRAFTING TOXIC
CHEMICALS BEFORE THEY BECOME A
PROBLEM FOCUSING ON PREVENTING
TOXIC EXPOSURES IN THE FIRST
PLACE RATHER THAN CLEANING UP
OR FIXING THE EFFECT OF THAT
EXPOSURE AFTER THE FACT HOWEVER
AS AS YOU MENTIONED THE PIECE
OF THE PROGRAM WHICH LOWER THAN
IDEAL BECAUSE OF STRUCTURAL
DEFICIENCIES IDENTIFIED IN A
TEN YEAR RETROSPECTIVE REVIEW
OF THE PROGRAM BY DR GINA
TOLEMAN AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE SB FIVE OH TO ADDRESS
A NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE REPORT. THE BILL IS
CONSIDERED LAST SESSION HAVE
NOT CHANGED THAT CONTINUES TO
HAVE NO OPPOSITION TWENTY
GAMPOLA THE IMPROVEMENT IN THE
BILL OF THE PROGRAM'S LACK OF
ACCESS TO PRODUCT INGREDIENT
DATA THE RESULT OF PROP
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE HAD TO
RESORT TO GOOGLE SEARCHES AND
I'M TO CRACKLE BOLLINGER EACH
INDUSTRY REQUEST TO GET
INFORMATION ON PRODUCT
INGREDIENT THE RESULT OF AN
UNNECESSARY AND SOMETIMES
LENGTHY DELAYS. IF I GO TO
PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT WITH A
CLEARER STRONGER DATA
COLLECTION AUTHORITY THAT STILL
PRESERVES THE KEEP TRADE SECRET
PROTECTION ALREADY IN THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY MOCK THE BILL ALSO
CREATES THAT LINES AND CLEAR
REQUIREMENTS BUT THE PROGRAMS
OUTLINED TIMELINE FOR ACTION
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FINALLY THE BILL INCLUDES
PROVISIONS TO REMOVE REDUNDANT.
MINISTRY TO PROCESS AND TO
STREAMLINE THE PROGRAM WORKLOAD
BUT WILL ALSO HELP IMPROVE THE
PIECE OF THE PROGRAM FOR ALL
THESE REASONS YOUR SUPPORT FOR
SB FIVE OH TWO I ALSO LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
ON BEHALF OF THE BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS THANKS.
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. NEXT TO IF
SUPPORT. YES HI- THIS IS AN
EVAN AGAIN WOULD COME WATER ACT
IT IS MY HONOR TO BE HERE TO
WOULD SET AL TO SEE S. B. OH
TWO. WE THE UP CLEAN WATER TO
BE INVOLVED IN DEVELOPMENT OF
THE ACTUAL BILL THAT
ESTABLISHED THE FAVOR CONSUMER
PRO- EXCUSE ME SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM- AS WELL AS
ITS IMPLEMENTATION EVERY SENSE-
AS YOU'VE HEARD THIS PROGRAM
TAKES AN EXTREMELY INNOVATIVE
APPROACH THAT ALLOWS INDUSTRY
USING TOXIC OR HAZARDOUS
CHEMICALS IN THEIR PRODUCTS TO
REASSESS THE NEED FOR THOSE
CHEMICALS. ANALYTE SAFER
ALTERNATIVES BY WHICH TO
PRODUCE CONSUMER GOODS AND SO
THIS IS ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT
NOT ONLY PUT HER MODES CLEANERS
PAPER PRODUCTS BUT ALSO WITH
HIS MANDIBLE ECONOMY AND YOU
ALSO HEARD THE REALITIES OF THE
PROGRAM IS NOT LIVING UP TO ITS
POTENTIAL GIVEN ITS SLOW PACE-
AND DAD- THE RESULTS HAVE BEEN
USEFUL BUT- BUT LIMITED.
FORTUNATELY WE'VE HAD THE TIME
AND EXPERIENCE TO IDENTIFY
WHERE THE PROBLEMS ARE IN THE
REGIONAL LEGISLATION AND WHAT
THE PROGRAM NEEDS SO THAT WE
CAN FIX SOME OF THE BARRIERS
THAT MAKE THIS DISTILLATE
PROGRAM THAT IT NEEDS TO BE AN
SB FIVE OH TO RESPOND DIRECTLY
TO WHAT WE BELIEVE ARE THE MOST
NEEDED REFORMS IN THE PROGRAM
INCLUDING THE LIMITED DATA FROM
THE MARKET PLACE AND IT
MINISTRY TO INEFFICIENCIES THAT
EAT UP PUBLIC RESOURCES- YOU
JUST HEARD FROM THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER WHAT SOME OF THE
SPECIFICS WOULD BE HELLO I'LL
JUST AND- SAY. THAT THIS BILL
IS ABOUT REAL WORLD ATTACKS ON
WE ALL CALIFORNIANS PEAPACK FOR
INSTANCE HAS BEEN LINKED TO
CANCER REPRODUCTIVE AND
DEVELOPMENTAL HARM IMPAIRED
IMMUNITY AND EVEN INTERFERENCE
WITH VACCINES- AND THIS PROGRAM
HAS THE CAPACITY TO ADDRESS
THOSE METHYLENE CHLORIDE IN
PAINT STRIPPERS HAVE RESULTED
IN AT LEAST. SIXTY FOUR DEATHS
AROUND THE COUNTRY INCLUDING IN
A FORTY YEAR OLD WORKER IN
HONEY TO PARK HOW. THESE ARE
CHEMICALS PRODUCTS THE C.
BECAUSE PRODUCTS PER IS ACT ON
THE OTHER WE IT MAY WORK AND
THAT IS WHY WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND- THE-
THE- AND IT IS THAT IT WILL
HELP WITH THE PROGRAM MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN FOR
INTRODUCING IT AGAIN. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WILL NOW GO
TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT AND I DO
NOT SEE ANYONE HERE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE- BUT ABOUT I DON'T
SEE ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
ALTHOUGH I DON'T SEE THE SCREEN
OUT. THERE IT IS. THEN LET'S GO
TO THOSE WHO ARE ON OUR ONLINE
DATA MODERATOR DO WE HAVE A
LITTLE FUN. ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND OTTOMAN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE OH TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
BUT AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE OH TWO
COULD PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
NOW. FORMER MANAGER LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE SOMEONE SHOWING UP. AS
GOVERNOR MY NUMBER MY NUMBER
ONE SEVENTEEN YEAH LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI BILL ALIRIO
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP IN SUPPORT WERE GLAD TO
SEE IMPROVEMENTS TO THIS
PROGRAM TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS SAFETY- FASTER THANKS.
AT THE TIME AND HERE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE COULD YOU. THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION- ANY
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE OH TWO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ABOUT SB FIVE ZERO
TWO. ONE MOMENT MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU AND I HAVE SEEN- IN
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE OR-
TWENTY TWENTY FORTY. SO WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS COMMITTEE
MATTERS COMMITTEE MEMBERS JUST
ONE QUICK QUESTION WHERE DOES
THE FINE MONEY- IT'S A HEFTY
FINE FIFTY IT COULD BE FIFTY
THOUSAND A DAY. I'M ASSUMING
THAT'S NOT GONNA BE RALLY GATE
BUT IT WOULD BE AND I CAN
EXPLAIN THE FINE SYSTEM AND
WHERE THE MONEY WOULD GO IF
PAGE. YES I REQUEST TO GO TO
THE TNC- ULTIMATELY IT'S REALLY
ABOUT DISTANCE DURING
COMPLIANCE ARE THERE THERE'S NO
OTHER WITH THIS IS HOW YOU PUT
INSIDE YOUR GET PEOPLE TO
COMPLY WITH WITH- NOW WITH THE
WITH THE PROGRAM. I MEAN DATA
THEN AND I JUST OBVIOUSLY
REMIND YOU THAT IF. IT'S STILL
GOING TO BE A LONG DRAWN OUT
PROCESS EVEN WITH THIS BILL-
NEAR THE END OF THE DAY THIS IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT- THE
FINES WOULD ONLY KICK IN IN THE
CASE OF THE COMPANY THAT'S
PUTTING A KNOWN. TOXIC CHEMICAL
OUT THERE THAT- IS IN VIOLATION
CLEAR VIOLATION. ANALYSTS SAY-
YEAH THE VERY SINISTER GROUPS
WHO WOULD HAVE MOST TO FEAR
FROM THIS- HAVE OF NEGOTIATED
THAT WITH US AND HAVE NOW
DROPPED OPPOSITION. DO IT IN
YOUR ORIGINAL TESTIMONY YOU
SAID THAT THAT THE YOU KNOW THE
PROCESS HASN'T REALLY WORKED
OUT WELL AND IS THERE MUST BE
SOME DEBATE OR SOME. THE BILL
BILLY NOT GET INFORMATION OR
HAVE INFORMATION BUT THE
PRODUCTS ARE STILL. BEING THERE
SO I MISS MY CONCERN IS IT'S
LIKE. I REALLY DON'T LIKE
AGENCIES HAVE AN ABILITY TO
FIND THE MONEY GOES BACK TO
THEM IT'S THERE'S AN INCENTIVE
FOR THEM TO FIND IF THAT'S- THE
SCENARIO WE SEE NOT AND OTHER
AGENCIES WHERE THEY- KEEP THOSE
REASON. THOSE MONIES IN THEIR
COFFERS AND SO. THERE'S AN
INCENTIVE TO FIND WHEN YOU.
DON'T HAVE A GOING BACK YOUR
COFFERS THERE'S LESS INCENTIVE
FOR YOU TO FIND AND ACTUALLY
GET TO THE RESULT. THAT'S MY
PERSPECTIVE. THE FIRM HAS
CONCEPTS BY EMINEM I'M WILLING
TO MOVE TO THE BILL I MEAN I
THINK THE IDEA OF HAVING BY
PROTECTING TRADE SECRETS BUT
ALLOWING PRODUCT INGREDIENTS TO
GET THERE IT'S A TRICKY IT'S A
TRICKY PROCEDURE FOR YOU CAN
HAVE THE SCIENTISTS LOOK AT IT
JUST SO THAT THEY CAN ANALYZE
THE HARMFUL EFFECTS AND I
PLUGGED IT IN OBVIOUSLY
ADMINISTRATIVE A- EFFICIENCIES
IS ALWAYS SOMETHING GOING ON%
LOOK FOR BUT I THINK MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND AUTHOR YOU'RE A
LITTLE BIT TOO HARSH ON
YOURSELF AS FAR AS- IS FAR AS
THE- SUCCESS OF THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM AND- AND IT
IS A- UNIQUE. ONE OF A KIND IN
THE WORLD WHEN IT GOT CAUGHT UP
CAUGHT BUT THERE ARE LOTS OF
PRODUCERS. CENTER PICK MAKING
SAFER. ATTACKS AND USING LESS
HARMFUL PRODUCTS AS LONG AS
IT'S STILL CLEANS MY HOUSE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
ON THAT LIST THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE A CHEMICAL OF CONCERN THEY
WERE THERE LOOKING FOR
ALTERNATIVES SO WELL WE MAY NOT
HAVE A- BODY COUNT HERE AT DGSE
ABOUT. THE CHEMICALS ARE OUT
THE INDUSTRY HAS SORT OF SELF
CORRECTED AS BEST THEY CAN
THERE'S NOT NECESSARILY THEY'LL
BE PEOPLE COME AND SAY WE HAVE
TO USES BUT- THE- THE- TOTAL
AMOUNT HAS ACTUALLY BEEN A
SUCCESS AND I THINK. THESE ARE
IMPROVEMENTS. TO STATE AND SEE
WHAT THAT'LL HOLD THE BILL. I
DO HAVE A QUESTION OR A COMMENT
OF SENATOR ALLEN I DO BELIEVE-
THE PENALTIES ARE EXCEEDINGLY
HIGH. IT WHAT TROUBLES ME ABOUT
THEM AND THEY SEEM TO BE TIED
TO AN AUTHORITY THEY DE TFC
HAVE- IF THEY AREN'T. YOU KNOW
LET'S SAY CONVINCED BY THE
ALTERNATIVE ANALYSIS THEY'RE
ALLOWED- THAT MANUFACTURES
ALLOWED TO MAKE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY ARE. YOU KNOW
SUPERSEDE THAT AND DO THEIR OWN
AND THAT'S WHERE I THINK THAT
THERE'S A- POTENTIAL FOR AN
SANTA. ANA VERY LARGE FINE. ART
TO SAY GEE I DON'T LIKE WHAT
YOU PRESENTED TO US SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR OWN OUR-
SOURCES AND GET ANOTHER
ANALYSIS PHILIP FEELS A
DIFFERENT DOES THAT PERSON
DOWN- IF THAT PERSON SUBJECTED
TO A FINE ENOUGH NOT CLEARLY
DEFINED ENOUGH. SO I THINK ARE
THERE NEEDS TO BE A TIGHTER-
RESTRICTION ON IT WHEN THOSE
PENALTIES APPLY. AND WHAT AND
NOW THE FEES ON. MEET THE
STANDARDS HEAD DOES SEEM TO BE
A LITTLE LOOSE IN THE WAY
THEY'VE CONSTRUCTED AND I KNOW.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THAT FOR SENATE CHALLENGE TO
GET BUSINESS OPPOSITION OFF
BECAUSE I REMEMBER IT FROM.
LAST YEAR BUT THOSE ARE STILL
PROBLEM AREAS FOR ME. ARE YOU
JUST IT IT MAKES ME CONCERNED
THAT IT'LL TURN OUT TO BE
SOMETHING LIKE PAGA. WHERE YOU
DIDN'T DODD AND I AND CROSS THE
T. THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN. THE
YOU KNOW YOU'RE HERE HERE AND
HERE IN TROUBLE WITH THE AGENCY
SO- TAKE A TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
I THINK WHAT I'LL DO IS I'LL
JUST LAY OFF. BY IT DOES COME
TO APPROPRIATIONS IF I'M
READING THIS CORRECTLY OFTEN IN
MY WORK. BETWEEN NOW. AND THEN
MAYBE WE CAN HAVE A DISCUSSION
ON THAT. YEAH I MEAN I WELL I
GUESS MY QUESTION THE FOR THE
TO YOU. MY FRIENDS I MEAN I
YEAH ELSE DO. SO YOU KNOW. B.
THERE ASKING FOR INFORMATION.
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO BE ABLE
TO. MAKE THIS DETERMINATION
NECESSARY IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH. SO
THE COMPANY JUST. OUT NOT
REFUSES TO. COMPLY WITH
INFORMATION REQUESTS. AND THEY
MAKE A REASONABLE EFFORT TO GET
THEM TO COMPLY WHAT WHAT OTHER
WHAT WHAT WHAT SHOULD WE DO I
MEAN SHOULD WE DO IT REALLY
JUST. TELL THE COMPANY THAT YOU
KNOW THAT OKAY WE'RE WE'RE
GONNA LET YOU OFF SCOT FREE
WITHOUT PROVIDING THIS
IMPORTANT INFORMATION OR- IS
THERE THAT IS A DIFFERENT WAY
TO ENFORCE I GUESS THAT'S MY
THANK YOU CAN APPROACH THE FINE
MEDIAN ECONOMIC. TEARS SO IF WE
CAN USE THAT PART. THE BASE.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THE OUT
RIGHT OR GOING TO REFUSE- BUT I
DO THINK THERE THERE CAN BE A
DISPUTE CLEARLY BETWEEN MY
ANALYSES THAT I PROVIDED YOU
AND YOU NOT ACCEPTING IT. AND
THAT'S WHERE THE AGENCIES KIND
OF BECOME THE RULING CLASS ON
ON OUR BUSINESSES LIKE I DON'T
LIKE WHICH YOU PROVIDED ME
THEREFORE- I NEED SOMETHING
DIFFERENT AND I. I DO THINK
THAT THAT WILL OCCUR BUT THAT
BUT THAT'S JUST INEVITABLE SO
MAYBE. YOU KNOW IF YOU DON'T
MEET THE STAFF IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A STANDARD THAT THEY NEED
TO MEET IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY
PROVIDE YOU. DID THEY GO OUT
AND SEEK SCIENTIFIC ANALYSES OR
DID THEY JUST TAKE IT IN HOUSE
AND EVERYBODY DECIDED WILL
SHOOT WE'VE HAD THAT THE
PRODUCT FOR THIRTY YEARS AND
DOZENS OF PEOPLE THERE'S NO
DATA TO SUPPORT THAT. WHERE IS
THE TFC WOULD HAVE SOME NEW
VERY UPDATED INFORMATION THAT
YEAH THAT IS THAT THE FUNDING
THAT'S NOW CREATED A WHOLE
CLASS OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE A
CERTAIN KIND OF BILL NOW FOR
CANCER WHATEVER. FULL BUT IF
I'M GETTING INTO THE WEEDS BUT
BELIEVE ME THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN. WHEN I GET THE
INFORMATION FOR MY CONSTITUENTS
WHEN THEY'VE GONE BEFORE AN
AGENCY GONE TO THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THAT AGENCY
TO TRY TO GET FROM FLORIDA. YOU
KNOW LESS ON OPPORTUNITY TO
REMEDY LET'S PUT IT THAT WAY.
MOST OFTEN THEY'RE NOT GIVEN
THAT THEY ARE IMMEDIATELY THE
THAT THE- CLOCK TICKS ON THEM
PROVIDING THE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEEN REQUESTED THE
STANDARD OF THE AGENCY VERSUS
WHAT THEY THOUGHT THEY SHOULD
DO AND I'M JUST SAYING. IF YOU
WANT TO LOWER THE FINE OR PUT
IT IN YOU KNOW A TEARS. ARE
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL BUT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY STARTING
EIGHT THIRTY ONE. THAT'S HUGE.
THEY WERE JUST COMING OUT OF A
PANDEMIC. WE'VE GOT
MANUFACTURES THIRTY YOU TO GEAR
UP AGAIN ALL OF THE OUTSTANDING
OF THE POWER WITH THE BACK.
RIGHT THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
MAKE A- ENOUGH BECAUSE AEN'T.
AND SHOW WERE ALL OF THE IS
PRETTY. SO I I'M JUST. I'M
WE'LL SEE SO SECTION. WHICH IS
YOU KNOW. IS NINE TEN ELEVEN OF
BILLS SERVE DOES LAY. THE YOU
KNOW THE INFORMATION OF YOUR-
IT'S IT IT. IS NOT A ENDED I
MEAN IF YOU KNOW. HAPPY TO.
LOOK AT WITH YOU TO TIGHTEN UP
IF THAT'S- THERE'S DIFFERENT
LANGUAGE AND ABOUT WORK GOOD
FOR- YOU KNOW I MEAN LOOK I
HEAR YOU AND I UNDERSTAND THE
KIND OF THE BROADER CONCERNS
ABOUT THE REGULATORY STATE I
GUESS I. YOU KNOW I WE'RE WE'RE
ME THAT THE PROBLEM WE HAD HERE
IS THAT WE KNOW THERE'S DAM
DANGEROUS THIRD INTEREST
CHEMICALS OUT THERE- YOU THE IF
THE AGENCY DOES ITS OWN
ANALYSIS BY THE WAY THERE'S NO
FINE I MEAN THIS IS LITERALLY
JUST TO ALLOW THEM. TO GET THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED- AND
THERE IS. A CLEAR DELINEATION-
IN IN THE BILL SECTION FIVE
THAT BEING SAID YOU KNOW HAPPY
TO HAPPY TO. GO THROUGH IT WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FURTHER IF
THERE'S WAYS THAT WE CAN. TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S THE DOESN'T
ALLOW FOR. YOU KNOW SOME SORT
OF GOOSE CHASE. YEAH WELL STILL
I MEAN THE OTHER DAY WHAT'S
WHAT'S GONNA REPORT TO ME AND
WHEN I'M NOT GOING TO BE HAPPY
TO COMPROMISE ON IS IT. IS
MAKING IT SO THAT. IN THE- THE
COMPANY'S CAN'T HEAR MY MIGHT
GIVE THE- THE DEPARTMENT. TOO
MUCH OF A RUN AROUND AS THEY
TRY TO DO THEIR WORK AND AS WE
SAY. THIS WHOLE PROGRAM HAS
GOTTEN BOGGED DOWN OVER THE
LAST TWELVE THIRTEEN YEARS NOW.
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH. THE
AGENCY DOESN'T HAVE THE TOOLS
IT NEEDS. TO TAKE TO GET THIS
INFORMATION TO MAKE DECISIONS-
SO WHAT COMES TO APPROPRIATIONS
SUB FINISH OUR FULL IN BETWEEN
NOW AND THEN LET'S HAVE OUR
STAFF CHATTER I CAN TRICK YOU
ACTUALLY T. OKAY BECAUSE I
DIDN'T READ PAGE WHATEVER IT
WATER SHOULD NOT. FULLER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO THE TO PROVIDE YOUR
CLOTHES YEAH I KNOW HAPPY SO
HAPPY TO WORK WITH MY CALL I'M
SORRY IT IS A GROUP THAT'S
GOING TO GIVE YOU A SCENARIO
OF. THOSE SO CALLED- THE METAL
BROMIDE. I'M SURE YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT IF YOU
AGAINST IT NEVER CULTURE USES.
ARE USED TO USE I SHOULD SAY.
AND YOU KNOW. THEY WENT THROUGH
ALL KINDS OF REGULATORY.
HURDLES AND BASICALLY DID TO
ERADICATE METHYL BROMIDE WHICH
IS VERY CRITICAL TO. KEEPING
MEMENTOS AND STRAWBERRIES AND
THEIR THEIR SEASON AMMONS AND
THEN THERE'S REALLY NOT OTHER
VERY GOOD- ALTERNATIVES. AND IT
MESSED IT NATURALLY OCCURS AT
80% WORLDWIDE IS A NATURALLY
OCCURRING THE GASES THAT COME
FROM NOT THE BROMIDE. AND SO MY
CONCERN IS EXACTLY OKAY WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU GOT IT WE HAVE
A PRODUCT THAT THERE IS NO
OTHER ALTERNATIVE. ALL RIGHT
EVEN THOUGH WE ALL WANT TO FIND
SOME OTHER ALTERNATE BUT THERE
ISN'T AN ALTERNATIVE. THEN
WHAT'S THE PROCESS AFTER THAT.
I JUST USED BUILT THE BERLIN IS
NOT PROBABLY IN THIS CATEGORY
BUT WELL RIGHT WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT'S THE PROCESS FOR THOSE.
COMPANIES THAT ARE HAVE A
PRODUCT IN OBVIOUSLY THE REASON
THAT WE'VE SEEN THE DELAY FOR
ALL THESE YEARS IS THERE
STRAIGHT THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
USE LIKE WD FORTY. DO WE REALLY
KNOW WHAT SENATE BUT WE KNOW
THAT IT TOOK HIM FORTY TRIES TO
GET. WATER DISPLACEMENT- AND
THERE WAS ACTUALLY LAWSUIT OVER
THAT YEARS AGO ABOUT. PEOPLE
WANTING TO KNOW WHAT WAS IN IT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
DUPLICATE IT SO. I WANNA GO
DOWN THAT ROUTE TROUBLED MY I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS WORK
WHAT'S THE ABILITY. FOR THE
PRODUCERS TO BE ABLE TO SAY HEY
THAT THERE'S JUST NO. THERE'S
NO OTHER- ALTERNATE. YEAH WELL
THAT I MEAN IT'S SO THAT'S
THAT'S SORT OF DOWN THE- I MEAN
THAT THAT'S DOWN THE DOWNTHE
LINE RIGHT AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT JUST GATHERING THE
INFORMATION AT THIS POINT- HERO
BY THE NEAR THE DAY IT'S- THE
REGULATORY RESPONSE VANS. IT'S
ALL ABOUT MITIGATING EXPOSURE-
FOR THE PUBLIC. AND IF THERE IS
NOT A GOOD ALTERNATIVE AND BY
THE WAY ANOTHER THING THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT DURING OUR LAST
DISCUSSION AGREE CHEMISTRY IS.
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE MAKE SURE IS
WE YOU KNOW YOU CAN GET RID OF
ONE CHEMICAL AND THEN. THERE'S
NOT A THERE'S AN ALTERNATIVE
INTO BEING A REGRETTABLE
ALTERNATIVE BECAUSE IT ENDS UP
BEING JUST AS DANGEROUS IF NOT
MORE. THAN THE ONE THAT YOU
FACED OUT. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
MAKES THIS THIS IS COMPLICATED
STUFF IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY OUR DEPARTMENT NEEDS. THE
DAY THAT I NEED THE INFORMATION
IT NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
SCIENTISTS WORK WITH AND REVIEW
AND CAN GO THROUGH THE DATA. SO
THAT THEY CAN THEY CAN HELP
MAKE WHY EVEN MORE WISE
DECISIONS I DO THINK HOWEVER.
THAT THE PRODUCERS. WHO HAVE
SUCH A CLEAR VESTED INTEREST
ASSOCIATED WITH- YOU KNOW WITH
WITH WITH WITH DEAL WITH A LOT
OF. YOU KNOW. BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO PRODUCE THESE
PRODUCTS AND GET THEM OUT
THERE- YOU HAVE TO HAVE THEIR
WORK CHECK THERE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE. A MECHANISM IN PLACE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO LOOK OVER
THEIR DATA AND THEN AND THEN
MAKE DETERMINATIONS- AND BUT
BUT YOU THIS WHOLE REGRETTABLE
TURN OF ISSUE IT IS A BIT A
REAL ONE AND THEN AND- YEAH. I
BUT THE ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I
GUESS THE BEST ANSWER I CAN
GIVE YOU THAT ULTIMATELY IT'S
ABOUT. OKAY THERE IS NO TO
ALTERNATIVE IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PRODUCT THAT IT'S ABOUT
MITIGATING EXPOSURE IT'S ABOUT
JUST FINDING WAYS TO MAKE. MAKE
EXPOSURE IN. TRYING TO REDUCE
EXPOSURE AND MAKE IT SAFER FOR
FOLKS AND- YEAH THIS IS THIS IS
NOT GOING TO DO AWAY WITH.
TOXICITY IN OUR ENVIRONMENT.
THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT
CONSUMER PRODUCTS WE'RE TALKING
HERE. YOU HAVE TO. ROBERT THE
FACT STROKES. SO HERE THAT THE
PUBLIC HEARD THOSE COMMENTS
WERE TAKEN. HAVE YOU COULD PUT
IT ON THE MIKE RIGHT. CENTER
SOME ACOSTA JUST SAYING THAT
THIS IS ALL TO THIS ABOUT
CONSUMER CONSUMER FACING
PRODUCTS AS OPPOSED TO AS
OPPOSED TO COMMERCIAL THAT'S OF
THAT'S ACTUALLY RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATE. ANYWAY I LOOK AYE AYES
AS WITH ALL THESE BILLS I'M
I'M- I'M- YOU KNOW TRYING TO
HELP MAKE THE SYSTEM WORK A
LITTLE BETTER AND TO MEET MEET
THE TENTACLES OF THE- ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION. IN THIS CASE AND-
HAPPY TO WORK WITH WITH MY
COLLEAGUES OFFICES TO SEE IF
THERE'S A WAY TO RUN. MAKE THE
BILL BETTER- YOU KNOW IN THE
END OF THE DAY MY CORE GOAL
HERE IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM. REALLY
HAS THE TOOLS IT NEEDS TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC IN. SO FAR
YOU KNOW IF YOU MAY HAVE HAD A
DETERRENT EFFECT AND THAT'S
FANTASTIC I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THEY CAN ACT. AND
WHEN THERE ARE. PRODUCTS OUT%
THERE THAT- HE DID SO WITH THAT
ARE THAT ARE CLEARLY- DANGEROUS
IN AND OUT OF COMPLIANCE SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR NEIGHBOR. AND YOU THIS IS-
DO PASSED TO BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. OF
COAL PLEASE. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION SIR IF I THOUGHT ON
THIRTY SEVEN. ITEM NUMBER NINE
SB FIVE OH TWO BY SENATOR ALAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN HI ALAN
I'D BATES. NOT VOTING. PAGE NOT
VOTING DOLLY. DALY NOT VOTING
GONZALEZ I DOLLARS SPY SKINNER
STERN BY CAL SKI A SKI I. OKAY
THREE VOTES ALL WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN UNTIL- BILLS- MEMBERS
CAN COME IN AND ACOSTA WROTE
AND I THINK THAT WE HAD SOMEONE.
NEED TO STAY RIGHT. I'M GONNA
STAY LET'S SO I'M GONNA STAY- I
THINK THAT THE THREE OF YOU
CAST ALL YOUR VOTES- BUT CENTER
DOLLY NEEDS TO VOTE ON HIS OWN
BILL WHICH IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HE SAID THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR FOR YOUR ABLE
TEARING AYE I WILL STAY ON BUT
IT CERTAINLY FREE TO CALL
CENTERS SKINNER AND STERN
CHASTAIN TO RETURN SO THEY CAN
CAST THEIR VOTES BUT LET'S
REOPEN THE ROLE. FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSULTED
PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS TEN AND
ELEVEN. WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I'D SAY AND THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING ICE CENTER DOLLY. DALY I.
THANK YOU SO WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THAT OPEN- AND SENATE OSBORNE
IS WOMAN OF THE YEAR EVENTS SO
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT SO AND IT
WILL COULD ASK OUR FRIENDS. THE
GOAL GAVEL THANK YOU THINK
MINIMIZE JERRY WE'RE GONNA OUR
FRIEND CENTERS AND- IS THE
BUDGET COMMITTEES TO GOING TO
YOU KNOW. DURING. PEOPLE ARE.
SEVEN SEVEN YOU EIGHT FIVE.
FIVE FOUR WE NEED FOR NOW FOR.
YEAH I AM YEAH. NOTICE YOU ARE
WORRIED YEAH SURE THANK YOU.
INVESTEC ARE PART A PROBLEM.
BUT IT'S OFTEN NOT NOT AT
CENTER SKINNER HERE- IF YOU
COULD JUST REMIND US- I ONLY
GOT TO VOTE I COULD STAND IN MY
OWN OKAY ARE A GREAT. ARTIST
TWO TWO NUMBER TWO. IF SEVERAL
SEVEN THREE THIS IS SB TWO
SIXTY ONE. HEY WHERE THE
HOUSING CARE ABOUT IT YES OKAY.
CAPITAL CALL THE ROLL UP IN IT
IT IS ACTUALLY THE CHERUB I ALL
OF THESE. JUST SO. THERE ITEM
THREE SB TWO SIXTY ONE SENATOR-
BY SENATOR ALAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON A ON
TRANSPORTATION WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE STERN.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA HOLD IT OPEN
FOR CENTERS STERN LOOKS GOOD
ITEM FOR SB THREE FORTY THREE.
I NEVER FOR SB THREE FORTY
THREE BY SENATOR ALAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY- THE
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING II THE VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING- SENATOR
SKINNER. BY INNER AYE STERN
WELL STERN HI THANK YOU BECAUSE
THE ROLE ON THAT AND WITH GOOD
ITEM NUMBER FIVE VISITS BEFORE-
THREE BY GONZALEZ OF REALLY THE
DRINKING WATER. AND SAID IT WAS
A CHANCE TO VOTE ON THAT.
SENATOR THAT- THAT'S IT THE
FORTY THREE- I'M HAVING
UNANSWERED BUT YOU HAVE THE
DATE AND FOR ANY OF US. FIVE
ZERO FIVE ZERO GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY SO
IT'S GOOD ITEM FIVE SIXTY FOUR
THREE THIS IS LEADING A DOLLARS
BILL ON DRINKING WATER ITEM
NUMBER FIVE S. B. FOUR OH THREE
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE- THE CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I AM THE VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. SKINNER FIVE SKINNER
AYE STERN STERN AYE OKAY THAT'S
NOW A FIVE ZERO VOTE ORGANISED
AND SENATE OVER. TO THE
PROPOSAL ROLE ON THAT. FIVE TO
ONE FIVE TO ONE OKAY FIVE TWO
ONE HI WITH ONE ABSTENTION
THAT'S HAT THAT THAT'S GOING
TO GO OVER TO THE GOVERNMENT TO
FINANCE THOSE CLOSER ON THAT
SAYS BEFORE THREE NOW IT'S
MOVED TO ITEM SIX IS SB THIRTY
IT WOULD COST HE'S BILL ABOUT A
BILL. L. IT'S ON PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AND THE NUMBER SIX SB
THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
MCCASKEY THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON.
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE TWO ZERO UP SKEWS ME
THREE TWO TWO. WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING OUTSIDE THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SKINNER AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN FIVE STERN I. OKAY
THAT'S NOW- FIVE TWO TWO FOUR
TWO TWO. FIVE TWO TWO FIVE TWO
TWO OKAY. I DO TOO WERE TO
CLOSE THE ROLE THAT'S GOING TO
HEAD OVER NOW TO THE PROBES.
WE'RE CLOSE ROLE THAT NOW LET'S
GO TO THE CENTER PORTANTINO'S
S. B. TWO THIRTY REALLY INTO
THE- WATER BOARD. IMPLICATED
USER IS CONCERNED. ASSEMBLY
COLORADO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S.
B. TWO THIRTY BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TWO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I AM
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING II
SKINNER OUR INNER I STERN.
STERN AYE THAT'S STARTS AT
SEVEN ZERO WILL WILL CLOSER ON
THAT SEND THAT OVER TO THE
SENATE MARTINEZ APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ALL RIGHT NOW LET'S
GO TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AT FOUR
TWENTY SIX CENTER RUBIO'S-
STORM SEWER SYSTEMS BILL.
CONTROL THE COLOR I THE NUMBER
EIGHT SB FOUR TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TWO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I AM
VICE CHAIR VOTING EYES SKINNER
HI IN OUR AYE STERN. STERN AYE.
OKAY SEVEN ZERO NINE SEVEN ZERO
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT. IN
SENATE TO PROBE NOW WILL GO TO
I. ITEMS S. B. FIVE ZERO TWO
THIS IS MY BILL ON GREEN
CHEMISTRY WE JUST DISCUSSED.
CONSULTANT ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
FIVE OH TWO BY SENATOR ALAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS- BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE TWO ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR RUNNING I'D AND A VICE
SURE NOT VOTING SKINNER HI
THERE I STERN. STERN AYE THANK
YOU SO THAT'S FIVE TWO ZERO
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT
SENATE'S APPROPRIATIONS- AND
THEN THE I THINK THAT'S I THINK
CENTER SKINNER I THINK YOU'RE
ALL SET. OKAY AND WILL AND
THAT'S NOT GOOD LET CENTER
STERN OUT ON A COUPLE MORE
LET'S GO TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THIS ITEM TEN AND
ELEVEN IT'S A SIX ZERO VOTE NOW-
COULD SOLVE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. UNDERSTOOD EARNED FIVE
STERN AYE OKAY WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN THE CONSENT BECAUSE I
WAS SEVEN ZERO VOTE LET'S GO
NOW BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
ORDER THIS NUMBER ONE SB TWENTY
SEVEN CENTER SKINNER'S BILL ON
CARBON SEQUESTRATION. I THE
NUMBER ONE SB TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FOR- FOR EYES. ED TO NOT VOTING
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND
THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
STERN AYE STERN I WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE THAT IT'S A FIVE TWO
ZERO VOTE. WE WILL- CLOSER ROLE
ON CENTER SKINNER'S BILL. AND
SENATE TO NATURAL RESOURCES
WHERE. THE CHAIR WILL HAVE HIS.
LOOK AT THAT LET'S GO TO MY
BILLS SB FORTY FOUR ON A
NORMAL. DAY TRANSIT PROJECTS- I
BELIEVE IT'S SIX ZERO NINE. YES
OKAY SO THAT'S SIX ZERO SO
ATTENTION PLEASE KALRA AND IN
ORDER TO SB FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ALAN. OKAY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX TWO ZERO STERN AYE STERN
AYE ALL RIGHT THAT'S SEVEN ZERO
WILL CLOSER ON THAT SENATE OVER
TO JUDICIARY WERE. SINISTER TO
CRACK AT THAT POINT. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO U. S. B. TWO SIXTY
ONE THE SINCE- REALLY INTO AND-
SB THIRTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE
AND REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANS MY BILL. SECTOR PLEASE
COLORADO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
TWO SIX ONE BY SENATOR ALAN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION- THE CURRENT
VOTE IS. FOUR IT TO- WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I'D AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO STERN FIVE
STERN AYE. OKAY THAT'S FIVE THE
TWO. IS OUT WE WILL SEND THAT
OVER TO ADD TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE I THINK THAT COVERS
ALL SENATORS BILL VOTES YEAH.
THIRTY SEVEN. THE PRESIDENT
AND- YOU WILL YOU WILL SEE MANY
MORE THESE BILLS AND OTHER
COMMITTEES YEAH SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO DISTINCT THE STAFF
AGAIN FOR THEIR HARD WORK-
PULLING THIS TOGETHER WE HAVE
TWO MORE HEARINGS. AND WERE
QUITE FRANKLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT MEETING ALL OF OUR OUR OUR
OUR- YOU GET EVERYTHING TAKEN
CARE OF SO- APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S HARD WORK AND WITH
THAT THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED.